Hi, welcome to my free Java video course.
Lesson One. My name is Marcos B. I'm a software
Craftsman with 14 years of experience in Java.
My goal is to teach you Java in the easiest
possible way. Okay, we will start with a briefing,
which is basically a lot of theory in the
beginning. Second, we will do a practice session,
where we will actually write our first Java
program. Finally, we will do a short key briefing,
where we will recap what we learned so far,
and add some more theory were needed. In this
first lesson, I'm going to introduce you to
the following 15 Java key words or concepts,
which you will need to understand your first
coding session later on. Please note, especially
if you already know some programming, I really
focus on not using any term before I officially
introduced it, getting a keyword explained
using concepts I don't know, something that
always ticks me off in classes, so I aim to
do better in this aspect. Therefore, intentionally,
I might explain a few things, not 100% academically
correct in the beginning. When necessary,
I will add the academically correct later
on. As stated earlier, my goal is to teach
you Java in the easiest possible way. If I
can achieve this by looking just a bit stupid,
that's fine with me. Last but not least, this
is really only a first introduction. It's
okay if you don't directly grasp everything.
We will go in more detail and recap the important
parts later on.
A package or better package structure is like
the file structure on your computer. It helps
to organize the different files of your program.
The top root folder of a package structure
is usually the organization's domain name
in a reverse order. In my case, that would
become Marco spiele. For example, if you don't
have a domain for the program you're writing,
it's okay to invent your own domain name,
but make sure it's a unique name. The reason
for this is that the name of a program file
is actually a combination of its own name,
plus the full package structure of the package.
It recites and there are millions of other
programs out there, and chances are high that
someone else has already used exactly the
same program file name before you. As Java
code is heavily shared worldwide, a strategy
was needed to come up with a unique name to
prevent name clashes. Each domain names can
technically exist only once. Therefore, using
a domain name as the prefix for your package
name as the default. Think of the package
name, like an absolute file name of your program
file. Using your package name is optional,
but I highly recommend you to do so even for
the simplest program. When used, the package
must be declared on the first line of your
Java program. The package name is starting
with a domain name in reverse order. As stated
before. The reason for this is that the package
name from left to right gets more and more
specific. Using lowercase and singular for
package names is the recommended default.
Last but not least, the package name also
serves as a high level description of all
the Program Files related to a certain topic.
code written for less than one of this Java
course would end up in a package called con
Marco spiele. java course lesson one for example.
Please choose package names for fully. It's
not just a stupid name. The package names
reflect the internal structure of your entire
program. Last but not least, I recommend you
to choose package names related to your specific
business topic. Rather than just using technical
terms. Good names are key. To simplify programming.
Every program file will reuse existing code.
To do so you have to import the code into
your program file. In our program file, the
import statement or import statements will
follow directly after the package declaration.
Here you can also see how the package name
must be included in the import statement,
as it is actually part of the programs falling.
You may import specific files, or all files
of a certain package using the star symbol.
Besides regular import statements, they are
also static imports, which we will cover in
detail at a later time. A simple program can
easily consist of 1000s if not 10s of 1000s
of code lines, it's very easy to get lost
in such a big pile of information. Therefore,
it's really important to impose a structure
on the program code besides using packages,
as explained before, in Java, the program
code is classified into different units of
code. Such a unit we call a class.
The programmer is the one who may decide how
to name and structure packages, as well as
classes. One aspect of Java is to improve
cooperation between business clients and programmers.
The client is able or should be able to tell
what he wants, the program is able or should
be able to know how this can be expressed
in code. The closer this code is related to
the business easier, the cooperation between
programmers and business people will be forming
a common language related to the business
and use throughout the code is therefore of
utmost importance. By convention, the name
of a class in Java should be a noun, starting
with a capital letter. opening curly brace
defines the beginning of the definition of
the class, where we will later write all our
code related to a car. The closing curly brace
defines the end of the definition of the class,
a class should be focused on only one topic.
As a recommendation, keep your classes as
small as possible to improve reusability as
well as readability. A class usually consists
of one or more methods. As the name implies,
it defines a method of how to achieve a certain
thing, like a method double could be defined
to calculate the double amount of an input
given methods are sometimes also called functions.
For now, one at 100%. Academically correct,
it's okay to use the terms interchangeably.
By convention, the name of a method should
be a verb that best describes the purpose
of the method. Methods define the actions
you can execute on classes, so they further
refine the structure of our program code.
methods can do pretty much everything for
us. methods can operate not only in numbers,
but also on text, colors, sounds, you name
it. A book would have chapters, every chapter
would have paragraphs and every paragraph
would have sentences structuring your Java
code in a similar way. Packaging name would
be like a chapter, a class would be like a
paragraph, and a method would be like a sentence.
For example, methods internally can call other
methods, which will then form a hierarchy
of methods calling each other. As a programmer.
It's up to you of how you want to structure
your code, how long you want a method to be,
which method will use which sub methods. I
would recommend however, to always think of
the current level of abstraction, just as
if you would write a book. For example, a
method prepared dinner could internally call
a method prepare appetizer, followed by a
method called prepare main course, followed
again by a method called prepper. Desert.
The prepare main course method for instance,
could internally call a method called boil
water. Mixing the levels of abstraction work
for example mean to have a method prepare
dinner, internally calling a method prepare
appetizer 30 followed by a method called warm
water without having a proper main course
method surrounding it. Coming up with clean
structure is key in programming. Make your
Code speak to you. Today with problems of
millions of lines of code. The most important
part of programming is structure and readability
for humans. As soon as you start to lose focus
and have difficulties in understanding what
a program does, chances are high you will
misunderstand some concept of the code. And
so you might introduce an error. Keep your
methods as short as possible. As a rule of
thumb, I would recommend 123 lines with 20
lines as a maximum.
The definition of a method follows a similar
concept of that of a class. First, we define
the name of the method. As stated before,
he was a word and start with a lowercase letter.
The name of a method is followed by an opening
and closing bracket. This is the place where
we mainly find the names of zero to an unlimited
amount of input fields. When using the method
later on, you will need to choose a value
for those values. These values are called
method parameters. In order to further improve
the structure and readability of your code,
I recommend you to use as few as possible
method parameters, with three to five parameters
as a maximum, everything more than that will
not be readable. The opening curly brace defines
the beginning of the method definition. closing
curly brace defines the end of the method
definition. Later, we will define the actual
code of the method that will go into the space
between the curly braces. As the name implies,
a variable is a variable value, a placeholder
for a value that you can set. The value of
a variable may change while the program is
running. For example, when the third value
is calculated over the lifetime of your program.
variables can be used as input or output values
of methods. For example, variables can be
of different data types, like numbers or text.
data types we will cover in detail at a later
time. Just for example, possible variable
names for a car could be my old car, my pushy,
or mom's car. There are different types of
variables, like instance variables, static
variables, local variables, parameters or
arguments, we will cover the differences in
a later session.
Public is an access modifier that defines
that any class from any package may use the
class or method with public access modifier.
Besides public, there are also other access
modifiers like private default or protected.
Here we are only skimming a topic. In a later
session we are going to cover access modifiers
in detail. Here you can see the access modifier
public in action. The class as well as the
method now posts have public access defined.
For every method, you actually have to define
our return value. Ironically, even when you
don't want to return any value at all. In
this case, you will send void as return value
of the method to explicitly define that the
method will not return a value. Besides void,
a method can actually return any kind of data
type. Here you can see the void return type
in action or drive method suppose to make
the car drive which is expected to execute
an action but not to return any value to us.
As a rule of thumb, it's good design to differentiate
between query methods, which will return a
value but do not alter the state and command
methods which offer the state but do not return
a value. In respect to this best practice
rule. Drive is a command method and therefore
does not return any value. The Add symbol
indicates an annotation. We will cover annotations
in detail in a later session. Just for now,
I want you to know that with ADD test, we
indicate that a given method will be used
as a test. When a class a variable or method
name consists of more than one word In Java,
you use an uppercase letter to indicate the
beginning of a new word. This is called camel
case, as the ups and downs of upper and lowercase
letters look like camel humps. In other programming
languages, and underscore is used to separate
two words from each other inside a variable
name. In Java, however, camel case is used
instead. To indicate the end of a sentence,
we use a thought in English sentences. In
Java, however, the DOT has a completely different
meaning. The dot between the variable car
and the method drive indicates that we want
to execute or we will alter. Alternatively,
say call the method drive on car. As the.is
already used to indicate a method being called
a colon is used to indicate the end of a statement
in Java. Here we can see an example of a test
method that is expected to test that our car
drives. The method drive is executed on car
with the value of 100. Colin says I want this
to be executed period. I talked about classes
already. I said that a class is a way of structuring
code in Java, a unit of code. This is perfectly
true. However, it's only part of the magic.
A class is like a template, like a definition
of what you want the class to do for you later
on when the program is running. The class
car for example, defines the behavior of a
car. However, when your program is running,
we say at runtime, there will usually be a
number of cars, each car may have its own
unique set of values, one car might leak oil,
so the value of oil could drop to zero while
the program is running. So our classes like
the human DNA, a definition of how something
should be created when the program is running.
When a Java program is running, it would usually
create a certain number of objects that will
exist as a set of values in the computer's
memory. And those values might change while
the program is running.
Each program language for certain concept,
Java is an object oriented language. Everything
is focused around objects in Java. In Java
writing classes is a way of defining a model,
which focuses on necessary aspects to solve
a specific problem. It needs the brain powers
of a clever Java programmer to fully understand
the problem and to extract a theoretical model
from it and transfer this model into classes.
The skills of the programmer will have high
impact on how precisely a problem is transferred
into a class model. Simply speaking, the more
accurate this is done, the less code has to
be written and maintained. The fossils or
program will run, the less errors it will
have. The power of Java is to be able to define
an execute table model, like a virtual machine
on your computer. With concepts and names
taken from the real world, which heavily improves
the communication of the programmer, and the
business client, programmer and business client
can both talk of a car. While the one is talking
of a real car, and the other of the representation
of this car on the computer, they will understand
each other. Here we see a simplified definition
of a class car. Now imagine a game where each
player creates a car when the game starts.
The program in this example, might create
three different cars at runtime. Now I talked
about classes and objects that will be created
from those classes. But how will these objects
be actually created? We will need a method
that will create the objects for us. This
is a very special method. It is called on
a class and we'll create an object each time
we call this method. But as soon as the object
exists, we cannot call this method anymore.
The special method is called a constructor,
as it is used to construct objects from class
files
to create a new object of time car, you write
new car. For example, the constructor in this
case, just like a method is given two different
numbers, one for the age of the car and one
for the maximum speed. In our example, when
the program is running and executes this line,
a new object will be created in your computer's
memory. We will, we talked about variables
already. However, before we can use a variable,
we need to define it beforehand. Call my Porsche
Colin is an example of a variable declaration,
we declare the variable which we called my
portion of the type car. Now that we have
a variable declared, we have to allocate the
object we created a variable declaration,
object creation, and allocation can all be
done in one single line. So this line reads
as when the program is running, and when this
line of code is executed, create an object
of type car with first of all you won, and
a second volume of 320. Then create a variable
of type car and give it a name my portion.
Last but not least, assign the car object
to the variable named my portion. After this
line, whenever we use my portion, we actually
referenced the object created in memory. Also,
you might notice when looking at this line
of code, we put two values into the constructor
of car. But without looking into the code
of the class car, we wouldn't even know what
their meaning actually is. This is one reason
why you should try to limit the number of
variables used in a method as well as in a
constructor, the less the better.
In session, to have this free Java video course,
we're going to write our first Java program.
When we write code, we actually start by writing
a program, which is actually testing the program
or class we are going to write. We do this
for two reasons. First, the test forces us
to properly think our idea through which will
improve our code a lot. Second, the main effort
in the lifecycle of a program is actually
not the first time effort of writing the program
code, but to maintain the program, like extending
or improving the functionality or fixing arrows
called bugs in your code. Whenever you write
code, there is a high risk you will introduce
defects in your code. When your program is
written once with the help of a test, this
test will ensure that whatever happens, your
program will continue to function as designed
initially. To recap, in Lesson One of this
free Java video course, I explained the necessary
theory to code our first Java program, which
we are going to do in a minute, we are going
to use these 15 Java keywords and concepts
described in detail in the prior session.
If you haven't done yet, I would recommend
you to start with session one before watching
this practice session. Okay, so now I'm in
my development environment. I've created a
folder structure of calm Marcos build Java
course, lesson two in a folder called test
and also here source main. Java. com Marcos
build Java course lesson two. This is where
we will write our tests have already created
the fall person test of Java. This here is
where later we will have our actual program.
But okay, so let's start person test. As described
in Lesson One, we have to start with a package
declaration. So I write and you see here,
I actually get support by my environment,
about the development environment. I'll tell
you later. For now just see that it actually
assists you. Actually, when you start learning
to program, I would recommend you to start
with a regular text editor because you need
to learn all these keywords. And so I guess
it's easier in the beginning. I mean not easier,
but it helps you to learn the stuff from scratch.
If you really have To focus and concentrate,
and you don't get assistance. But as soon
as you manage all these keywords, as soon
as you know all them section environment is
really helpful. Okay, so I use package, and
then I have to define it. COMM macros, we'll
see how it assists me again, it already knows
the package, because I have here the folder
structure, and the folder structure, and the
package declaration in my file actually have
to be the same. Otherwise, this would be an
error. So actually, I don't even have to write
it anymore. I can just follow. Okay, so this
is my package. And you see, before we have
an underline or red underline, which means
something is wrong. Now, oh, editor seems
to be fine with what I wrote so far. Okay,
here we are. Later, we'll have imports, as
described in lesson one. But we will add them
later. Normally, you start defining your class
first. See, again, I wrote public and see
how it's underlined red, so something is missing.
So I say class, and now I have to define the
class name is a person test. So I call my
test person test, it's a test for our first
program, which is the class person. Okay,
now I have to add the brackets. When I add
the first one, my editor already adds the
second one. Because for every opening bracket,
you always need a closing bracket.
Okay, so this is the beginning. And this the
end of my person test.
Okay,
no at the annotation test. So that I define,
I want to write a test. And see, magically,
the input appeared. Because my environment
already knows, I want to write a test. The
test also, I mean, it's actually a class.
And it even has package. And this is all three
unit test. We'll talk much more about j unit
in later lessons. But for now, we just know
this is a test magically somehow. Okay, and
we need to test the method. test method will
be public. It won't return any value, so it
will be void. And I will give it a name what
I want it to do should return hello world.
Hello World is actually like a running gag
of programmers. Someone I don't know who once
started. That first program you write in a
language should return hello world. So we
do that to write a test. For my first HelloWorld
program, I expect my person to return hello
world to me. And I'm going to test this. We
haven't written any actual code for person.
But we're starting reverse. So we're starting
with the test, as explained before. So now
I can just assume I was done. You see, it's
red, which means we don't have a class person
yet. But this doesn't matter. Now for this
person, I need a variable name. And as my
name is markers, just for fun, I call it person
I call the person Marcus. Okay, now I have
to create person markers. Remember, this was
calling the constructor creating the object.
And so this is creating the object of person
from the type from the class person. And the
equal sign assigns that object which is created
in the memory of RPC to the variable, the
reference variable person because this is
a reference that we can later on use referencing
the person.
Okay.
Now this is read, but we'll take care of this
later. We just continue. Okay, so assuming
we were done, what do we want? We want to
test something And testing, we say we want
to assert something, we want to assert that
a method we're going to write is returning
the hello world for us. So, we want to compare
if our expectation is equal to what the method
is going to return. So we say assert equals,
this also is starting as red, because we will
have to import more stuff. But for now, we
just take it, I use this was again metric
I add one quotation mark, and my environment
already adds a closing quotation marks. This
is what we call a string. And I say hello
world, because I want my person to return
HelloWorld for me, so, the first part here
is the expected return Well, you know, I add
a comma. And now I have to add what is going
to be tested Marcus dot for calling a method
Hello, world. So on the object, Marcos of
class person, I want to call a method, hello
world, with no parameters given and what is
returned here, I want to assert that it equals
to hello world. Now, this is not going to
work. Because we still have some red stuff.
For example, here, we don't have actually
written the class. But here we will let our
environment help us, you see. Now I just have
to say create a class person. Sorry, again,
create class person. And here, it already
asked us destination package, create class
person. COMM walkersville. java course lesson
two. Okay, sounds good. Because our test,
and the actual class of the test will be in
the same package. This actually helps us a
lot. But more about this later on. I say,
okay, and magic magically, or first class
got created. You see the package, and the
class. This is actually kind of the smallest
class possible, just with opening and closing
bracket. But it doesn't do anything yet. Okay,
but you see, it's not red anymore. So let's
go to from next, assert equals, oh, it wants
to import something statically. I said before,
I will later on tell you what means static
import. But for now. Just believe me, we have
to import this. This is another import from
org j unit. But this time, it's an assert.
And so this is like a method. We import the
method assert equals. But, um, don't focus
too much on this. We'll go in more detail
later. For now, what is important, we want
to write our first test. So we still need
to define a method. And it also tells us cannot
resolve method HelloWorld. Okay, help us please
create method HelloWorld. We had enough it
moved the method to the wrong place, but I'll
fix that. Of course, we need to have it here.
Okay, no, nothing read anymore. And we can
start calling our first test. I say run. And
this actually executed our first test, which
again executed our first class that was automatically
written. And here we see we have an error.
It tells us a missing return statement. So
I said we want to return a string you see
string. But as you see the method is empty.
We don't return anything. So let's fix that
fix that return. This is how we say it, we
have to say return. And I just have to type
Hello, world. exactly as I was expecting it,
I get the column to say yes to it return hello
world. Okay, now we switch over to the test.
And I'll execute the test again. And that's
green, all tests passed. This is our first
test. And it worked on in our first class,
Tara. Okay. Thank you. That said, lesson three
debriefing. For debriefing, we will go back
to our development environment, and have a
look what we learned so far. Okay, now we're
back in our development environment. And now
let's repeat what we learned so far. The first
line of our program is the package declaration.
It must be unique. And it usually consists
of your domain name in reverse order. So in
my case, calm, Marcos, bu Java course, lesson
two, and we ended with a color. Actually,
it's not mandatory, it's optional. But please,
I really recommend you to use a package name.
Later on, you will probably see why you just
need to have some practice. But for now, just
believe me treat this as if it was mandatory.
And always define a package name. After the
package declaration, we can have one or more
import statements. This just for our lesson,
now I made up I created a new class called
name. And this is an A sub package called
lesson three. Actually, all classes that are
in the same package. So person has an a package
called macro spiel Java course lesson two,
for all classes that are in the exactly same
package, lesson two at the end, we don't need
to import them, Java will find them automatically.
But here I made this lesson three. So if we
want to use the name class that I just wrote,
we have to import it. Okay. Next thing is
class definition public class person. And
with these brackets, that says the class begins,
this says the class ends. Public means all
other classes, for example, my new class name,
in any package can see the class person. What
this can see means is still a bit work. For
now, just take it as it is, I don't expect
you to fully understand it yet. This will
need some practice. And here for now, some
new stuff, I added the class that I defined
name, and I made it private, which is also
best practice to have we call this a reference
variable, because it is a reference to later
on an object of type name. And I made it private,
which means other objects that get created
will not be able to see. See again, I say
See, or access this field here directly. If
they want to use it, they have to go using
this method I also just created this one is
public and it returns personally. So when
they call person dot name, the method you
can give it any name I just call it salt,
but you could also call it I don't know.
Return the name. So this can be anything um,
and it will return the person's name. So here
again we see return, which means I want this
to be returned to whoever calls that method
and the colon which means do it execute it.
Okay. What else did we learn? We learned that
this stream, and that having a class, returning
HelloWorld is like a running gag in programming
for the first program that you do. So this
is why I made class person return hello world.
I mean, actually, it might not make sense.
But yeah, just was all made up. Then also,
going to the test, we learned, we actually
start with writing a test. When we wrote the
test, we hadn't defined the class person yet.
We hadn't defined the method HelloWorld yet.
We did all this on the fly. In our development
environment assisted us with some auto completion,
it was able to create the class as well as
the method. So this is really a handy way
of programming. First of all, you define the
test. So this gives you an opportunity to
think about the property sign. And then you
define what you need, and you don't have to
actually even write it yourself. And when
you did everything correctly, you can simply
execute the test. And when it returns, okay,
and it screen, you will see that you did a
proper job. Okay, see, here, you'll see a
green bar, which means the test executed successfully.
So when testing we often speak of green or
red bar, because the green bar is such a good
signal that you understand your test passed
successfully, that people got used to just
speak of green and red bars. Okay, so we learned
some more stuff, for example, that this is
an annotation. And I told you, you don't need
to know more details about it yet. We will
go into details later. Besides on top of input
static, and also, I just want you for now
to know that something static exists, but
we will go into details later. Okay. I think
that's it. It's okay, if you don't understand
everything perfectly yet, I don't expect you
to. Um, so we'll go in more details later.
And we will repeat all this stuff. So it's
fine. I mean, the start is really tough. I
know that I don't expect you to be an expert
in Java yet. Um, this is just an introduction,
and you will grasp it soon. lesson four. Okay,
we're back in my ID E. Id is actually the
short form for integrated development environment.
And as this is much shorter, usually you just
say ID e. m, let's recap what we learned so
far. And the first one, you have the package.
And the second line, you might have import
statements, you don't necessarily need something
I didn't tell you so far is here we use name.
And we use the classes short name, because
actually, the classes real full name includes
always the package name, so that the name
is of the class is unique. So we could also
use its full name, including the package name,
and then we would not need to import the class.
But I mean, as you see, this is much more
readable, much shorter, so also much more
handy. So this is what you normally do. There's
only one exception, which is a bit more advanced.
So I will just shortly mention it. Sometimes
it rarely happens that you would have two
classes of the exact same short name
but have different packages. And so to define
which one you mean, then you would have to
use one with the full package name. Okay.
So next, we define the class. The class starts
with a curly opening brace and ends for the
curly closing brace. Um, we have here, we
say it's an instance variable actually. And
this is an instance method instance variable.
And instance methods could be, of course,
much more. But those together we call the
members of the class, because they belong
to the class. An instance is just like an
object. So of one class, you can create various
instances, like, one person could be Marcos,
another person could be, could have the name
of Peter. And you could have hundreds of hundreds
of class of objects, sorry. And each one of
these objects is an instance. And for the
instance variables, this means that each instance
has their own version of this variable, which
each might have a different value does not
need to. But it's like a duplicate version.
There's also another thing, which is called
a class variable. And a class method, which
we do when we add static to it, we can add
static here, as well as to the here. In this
case, now when we create different instances,
and we change the person name of one instance,
this means that all other instances will also
have the name change to the new value. This
is a bit more advanced and static. We should
talk about this in detail later. So I just
shortly, just to be complete, wanted to mention
it. For now, it's totally enough, if you know,
this is an instance variable, and this is
an instance method, okay. Besides that, I
would want to add a constructor, I think I
talked about constructors already.
Okay.
Opening and closing curly brace. This is what
we call a default constructor. It does not
have any parameter here, not any variable.
And so this is the default constructor. When
we want to create an object of type person
of class person, this constructor will be
called and everything that we would do in
here would also be executed. So this constructor
is actually used to initialize an object.
Because for example, let's do something else.
Now let's add a parameter, prison name. So
this now gets a bit more dynamic, more interesting,
because we could try to set the inner person
name to the given person name. Now, you see
something is wrong. Variable person name is
assigned to itself. Well, of course, how should
our ID or Java know? What do you mean? Here,
we need something to differentiate to tell
Java, what we want is we want to set this
instance variable to the value of the parameter
person name. One thing we can do to fix that,
we could just rename the variable to see it
works. Now we can automatically automatically
resolve the problem. But usually you don't
want that I mean, person name is better name,
of course. And now what we have to do, we
have to add this to one of them. And as we
want to set the value of person name to the
instance variable person name, we add this
dot person name. And so Java knows that we
mean this one here. And now, when someone
calls the constructor to create an object
of type person, it'll also have to add the
person's name. And then the person named darts
directly gets set at the time the object is
created. Okay, one more thing that you should
know is now that we have created our own constructor
that has the parameter person name, this means
this class does not does not have a default
constructor, an empty constructor like I showed
you before this one has gone. Java will automatically
created when there is no constructor defined
by us. But as soon as we have defined one,
General will not do that. Now if you remember
our test from the last version, we use the
constructor without any parameter. So this
will later on fail, but I want to show you
so I will let it as it is. Okay, so, um, remember
we had that method here HelloWorld, I told
you that in the first program in every programming
language has like a running gag, you return
hello world. Hello World is actually a string.
And here we say the method should return a
string. Now, I want to do some more advanced
on, I would like to have a method, I can give
a parameter of string. And then I want to
say hello, the person's name. Um, okay. And
as you also might remember, usually we start
with a test. So let's write a test for what
I'm planning. Okay, so how do we write the
test? So we have to first of all at the end
here, and then say test. This is what we call
it a notation. Much more. We don't know yet.
And you don't need to know for the moment.
I mean, this is all confusing. So relax. I'll
repeat everything various times, you will
understand that very soon. For now, let's
just write the test. So I say should we turn
Marcos.
Okay, because this is what I want the method
to do. Okay, now I have the opening and closing
brackets for the method. Okay, so we need
to create an object of type person. Last time
I called it, Marcos. This time, I want to
show you how we can use any name we want.
So it's called person, new person. So with
that new person, and the regular brackets,
I call the constructor. And this is like a
method that is being initially executed at
the time when the object is created in our
memory, and see something is read here. Because
I told you the default constructor is gone.
So if we want to do that, we have to go back
to our class. And we have to add the default
constructor again. We can add it at any place,
put it here. Okay, and now this is empty,
and it'll work. But having an empty method
or an empty constructor might be confusing
for a colleague. So usually what we do in
this case, we leave a comment. To mention
we haven't forgotten anything. We have done
this on purpose. So let's see how do we do
a comment actually.
So I say empty. On purpose, default constructor.
So what I have here is a multi line comment.
There's also also a single line comment, which
you do just like this single line, comment.
But I really recommend you should prefer the
multi line comment for various reasons. I
will go in detail about comments in a later
session. So for now, this is all I want to
show you. Okay, so we have fixed the test.
Yes, the red thing is gone. Great. We have
created an object of type person, let me copy
this to show you one thing. You can actually
create various objects one after the other.
But now, we already have one object that we
called person. So this will not work. So we
would have to give this for example, person
two. And so like this, we could continue.
We could create any number of objects, just
so that you see. We have one class of type
person. And we have two objects created calling
the default constructor. And so we have two
objects when this is executed later on. I
will delete this again. I mean, this was just
a short demonstration. Because we should remember
what we want to achieve actually is we want
the method to return Marcos. Well, actually
I was wrong. I want to say hello, Marcos.
Okay, so now let's assert again. assert equals,
I want Hello, Marcos. And I want to say person
dot Hello. And I want to give it here, when
we use a variable here, we call it an argument.
This is just to make it more confusing, and
people use this interchangeably. But to be
correct here, it's called an argument. But
it's all about variables. So we add a string.
And I add markers. Okay, and see something
is missing our ID, he tells us something right
here, we need to call him to finish this.
So I want on the object of person we created
in the line before, I want to call a method
Hello. And you see it's red. And it also our
Id even already tells us cannot resolve method
Hello. It doesn't exist. But we are programming
in a test driven style. And so we will have
to create a method right now. Okay, I'm actually,
with some magic, I can automatically make
my array he created for us. Well, there are
different IDs, and I will speak about it specifically
later on. So for now, I just did this to speed
up it up. Just believe me. I mean, you. I'm
sure you could create that by yourself. Now
and he did something it said return now about
now this is something special. I don't want
to talk now. I'll tell you later. Okay. Sorry,
I don't want to confuse you. But I also don't
want to tell you too much. So one after the
other. And now, I would add well Marcus's
a bit. Let's say name. Name, because it could
be any name, not necessarily has to be Marcos,
we could add any name we want. And what I
want is I want to add name to Hello. What
we say here we want to concatenate hello and
name. And something is missing. Oh, it doesn't
like it. What is missing is a plus. This is
how you concatenate two strings together.
So a new bigger string is created. And you
can do this any number of time. But for now,
I mean, all we wanted to say is Hello, and
the given name. So this should be fine. Actually,
there's a little back hidden, which you will
see very soon. Which I did on purpose, because
I want our test to fail.
Let's execute it. Ah, so you see expected
Hello, Marcos. But actual Hello, Marcus. So
there's a space missing. So see, this is one
reason why tests are really handy to help
you to think about the stuff you code. But
also when you do introduce a back an arrow,
then you will directly spot it and you're
able to fix it before it goes on production
and destroy something. And yeah, this can
be really expensive. So let's fix this. Let's
go down to our method. And here was a space
missing. Let's add it. We go back to the test.
executed again. And now the bar is green.
It's works. Oh, that's great. Okay. Um, yeah,
I think that's it for now. Lesson five. So
now, I would like to talk about modifiers
first of all about visibility modifiers. Actually,
we already talked about them a bit. One visibility
modifier is private. Another one is public.
So public, I think I already said this class
is visible or usable. From all other classes
in all other packages. This class now resides
on the package comm Mako speelde. java course
lesson two. So here, for example, name is
in lesson three. So if we would go in the
code of the name class, it could easily use
person as long as it's public. A private class,
we can try that. No, it says modifier private
not allowed here. And of course how That makes
sense. I mean, a class that's not usable anywhere.
But just in this class. This doesn't make
sense. But actually, there is one more option,
we can leave the modifier away. And this will
give us the default modifier. This is also
why it's called default modifier, also package
level modifier, because now, person can only
be used from other classes within this package.
And we can do the same for the variables,
the constructors, we can even have a private
constructor, we could have that public, we
could have that method private. And this one
default. And we can even call, let's use this
one. Let's call HelloWorld. From this method
here, all this is working. And this actually
even makes sense. Because especially when
your methods are growing, I personally would
say not more than three or 10 lines. Then
to break things up, you can split a long method
into smaller private methods, and then calling
the private method. Like, I mean, here, we
have only two methods. So to make things up,
you can call one method three times. But of
course, I could define further methods. We
don't have this now. And then you can call
any number of methods later on. Okay, so to
recap, visibility modifiers, we learned so
far is public, private, and default or package
level. Besides there are other visibility
modifiers, one, for example, is protected.
But we don't need this at the moment. So you
should be perfectly coming alone, along with
just public, private and default. So for now,
let's just concentrate on these few. Let me
fix the class shortly. Because very soon,
we are going to need it in our test. And I
don't want to adjust the test, I want to have
the code as it was before. Okay, because now
I want to show you a new concept. I have this
idea. I have prepared the test should return
number of persons. Let me create a few objects
of type person, one person, person to
person,
we could also use the other constructor, but
then I would have to create an object of name,
as this at the moment is just too much work
for me, I'm not doing it. And I can also give
it a different name, like my person, just
to show you, we can have any name for the
variables. So what this means is when the
test will be created here, after this line
is executed, which is just after the column,
we will have one object and memory two objects
in memory. And after this line three objects
in memory. So what I want now I want to test
on a number of objects. Now I should have
three objects created. And I want to create
a method that tells me exactly that. Just
dynamically, my person thought number of persons.
Okay, still read, remember, we'll create it.
And today Ah, int appeared. Because I mean
three is a number. And a number in Java is
an integer, or he In short, an int an int
this actually a primitive. And the default
of this is zero. So this is why my ID he put
zero here. So it's not red anymore. We can
have a first run. But this will not work of
course, because it statically returns zero
we expect three. So this is not what we want.
Well of course we could say three statically.
So, now this should work. It's a bit cheating,
of course, greenbar Tada. But, I mean, I want
this to dynamically work. So why not only
have two persons, I want this to be two. And
well, of course, I have to rename a variable.
Let's copy it. And now when I execute it,
of course, this is not going to work expected
to, but it's still three. So my first approach
the static one, always returning three. Nice
gag, but yeah, not what we need. So what we
need is, at the specific time, when each object
is created, we need to count each object that
is created. So what would be the place where
the object is created, there is one thing,
similar to a method that is called and this
is, you might guess it, the constructor, we
used the default constructor for creation.
So we would have to do something in here.
Now, I want to invent a variable, an instance
variable, I also call it or let's call it
person counter, person counter equals two.
And now I say person counter, because I want
the value it had before. And then I want to
add one to the last value of person counter
to have the new value dynamic. So on the left
side, is the new value. On the right side
is still the value from the prior calculation.
And I add one to it. Now, this is a lot of
code again. And this incrementation by one
is used so often, that they invented short
form for that, which is plus plus. So with
plus plus, we say take the current value of
person counter incremented by one and save
it again into the value of person counter,
it's still red, because we still have to create
it. Let's do that. Make it private, of course,
it's an int. I call the person counter and
column. Because I don't have to say zero,
I could also say equals to zero. But the default
for end is zero anyway, so what we usually
do is, we just put it here as is. So the idea
would be it starts with zero. The first time
this constructor is called, it's incremented
by one, and so on. So that my method now should
not statically returns three, but person counter
instead. Okay, let's try that. Execute the
method. Still not working it returned one.
It didn't return zero. It didn't return three
it returned one. How is that? We didn't say
one anywhere. Maybe you guessed it already.
So we started with zero, we incremented by
one. Now I told you something in the prior
session, which is this constructor is part
of the instance. So each object has their
own constructor has their own method. So this
is called for each of the objects. So in the
end, both objects would have the counters
set to one. So what we need is more like a
global counter. That is not on the instance
level. But we say on the class level, because
for all the objects of type person, there's
only one class person and this we achieve
with a modifier called static. Okay. However,
as a recommendation because this will help
you in the future, I won't go on details Why
just believe me. As we have the variable of
types of static, you should also have the
method of type static, it would work also
without that, it just better believe me. Okay,
so now let's execute it. And this work Great.
Let's try another thing. Let's add this time
for
free
for for an exit executed and it works, I said
actually person to why not saying person one.
And it works? Well as you see this might be
confusing I mean which variable to decide
on. And also there is a recommendation. Actually
what Java does is Java sees that number of
persons as a static method, it sees that you
have an instance variable off type person.
And as this is a static method, it doesn't
call the method on the object. Because as
this method is static, it's not part of the
object anymore. This is like moving it out
of the object. This method now is part of
the class. So Java does some magic here, is
trying to be smart and is smart, and calls
the right method of the class. So what we're
doing here is working because Java knows how
to do it properly, but it's not so nice. What
is better is darkly saying person, so that
everyone knows you're not going to any specific
instance, we're just calling a static static
method. On the person class, let's execute
that again. And it's working. Thank you. So
in lesson six of this Java course, I'm going
to talk about the tools which I'm using. So
first of all, let's start with this computer.
It's an apple MacBook Pro. This ID that I'm
using here is IntelliJ IDEA, which actually
at the moment is my favorite ID. Before I
was using many, many years, Eclipse clips
is open source is also very popular at the
moment, especially with companies because
it's open source and free. However, I think
intelligence here is really getting better
and better every year. So I really like it
and recommended. And they're not paying me
for saying that. But I mean, this is your
personal preference, and every person is different.
So I would say just try it out yourself. There's
also NetBeans. NetBeans is also very popular,
and it's also for free. I'll just in a second,
I'll show you where to get them. But let's
have a closer look at my tests before. So
in the tests, might have seen it already.
I'm using j unit, which is a testing framework.
framework means it's like a tool set. It's
a set of tools to set of classes. And it's
open source. So it's free to use. And I mean,
writing such a framework, it's not really
hard work. But why doing it if it's already
done. So this makes it really easy to start
with testing. J unit also is only one of a
few testing frameworks. The second one I would
tell you about is test and G, I think they're
pretty much the same. And really depends on
the company that you work in some use j unit,
some use testing G or any other framework,
I think between j unit and test ng g there
knows not so much big differences. So it doesn't
really matter. I just decided to use j unit
in here. IntelliJ IDEA actually supports both
of them out of the box. So you can easily
try them. Um, I'm not going in much more details,
by the way. I mean, this is a Java tutorial.
So I focus really on Java. Just to be complete,
I wanted to mention what I'm using here. But
I do this in less than six because at the
beginning, I think learning a new language
is already quite difficult. So I wanted to
focus on Java, but not that you puzzled. What
the heck is that here? What are you doing?
I wanted to mention this is J unit. And there
is lots of documentation on the internet.
Yeah, so you can read a lot about it. Okay,
so maybe we just go to the browser now. and
have a look. So first of all, I told you about
intelli j idea for you pops up.
So you can download, I would first of all,
go with the free edition, and then see if
you like it or not. Besides, of course, there's
Eclipse. This one is open source anyway. And
then you can choose your operating system,
and 32 or 64 bit, whatever you need. Last
but not least NetBeans. Just press the download
button, choose your language, and operating
system. And then also j unit, let's have a
look on that. In most It is these days, you
won't have to install it, because it would
come pre installed anyway. But just for the
record, I mean, this also has lots of documentation.
So yeah, he you can download the most current
version. Let's check documentation. Here.
It also talks about Maven, which, by the way,
also using so this way, you can define in
Maven that you want to use the current version
for 12 of j unit, which I actually did, because
I'm also using Maven, which we're going to
in a second. But after j unit, let's also
have a look on tests and G
test ng g on this page just provides the false
for Eclipse. But as I told you in IntelliJ
IDEA, it's included anyway. And I checked
for NetBeans. I mean, I'm not so familiar
with NetBeans, I have to admit that beans,
but I saw there is a plugin, which you can
download and install. So probably works just
as well. Now let's talk a bit about Maven.
Maven, there's what's called a build management
tool. So as the name implies, it manages your
build. Now, what's a build? Well, when you
program your programming consists of hundreds
of classes, and then you would want to release
them on production or send them to a client.
And then of course, you would not want to
send each file separately. So the so you would
usually do a package a single file out of
all the tasks together. And in former times,
and say in prehistoric times, this was done
manually. And this is really not a funny job.
So people very soon started to program, some
little scripts to make this task easier. The
first tool that I know of is probably make
it's a Unix tool. And often make they came
up with and and Maven again is the successor
of Maven of m sorry. And Maven currently exists
in version three. Besides Maven, there's also
Gradle and other build tools, I'm using Maven,
here you see it find that I'm using j unit
412. And also the find that my source encoding
is UTF eight, because what this bill two also
can do for you. I mean, it can do so many
things is environment specific settings. So
that I tell that my source encoding is UTF
eight, I can do it here. And so much more.
So also about Maven, you can visit the website,
Maven. There, you can download it. They also
have a free book, which is really a great
book. You can download all the files, even
the sources that you would need. And also
check Maven book. I really recommend that.
As far as I remember. It's available as HTML.
And also there should be a PDF somewhere.
All this is just too long. Anyway, I know
there is also a PDF available which you can
download. And so you can read all about Maven
Last but not least, let's also talk about
bit about text editors. Because I think in
at least one of the lessons I did so far,
I told you, you should start not with an ID.
But you should start with a text editor instead,
well, there are two that I would recommend,
first of all testbed for Windows, I really
like it using Windows. for Mac, it's unfortunately
not available. In this, you can write your
code, then you would save it. And then assuming
you have already downloaded the Java JDK,
which I have also not talked about, because
I assume I should be easy, but maybe we could
first, shortly go there. So for the JDK, so
that you can download your code, you can just
go here, say download, by the way that was
NetBeans, if it was soiled, and you can choose
your operating system and download it. I assume
you have already done that. And so when you
have installed a text editor, or like text
pad, or sublime, you're on. Mac, I'm using
sublime, which is also a great editor. Download
button. It's also available for Windows and
Linux. So using this text editor, here, I've
loaded the class person that we saw before.
I mean, it helps you a bit like see, I click
on person's name, it highlights the variable
person name and all forms, but it would not
so heavily assist you, like you might have
seen when I was in my ID, which for the beginning
is actually good, I think. Because when your
ID is too smart, then you don't have to use
your brain cells too much. I mean, after some
time, when you have coded too much, this is
really welcome. But for the beginning, I really
recommend to use your brain cells and so that
you get used and familiar with all these keywords,
public class, private static, should really
get familiar with that. And so for the beginning,
just use a text editor, then you can also
go on the console and called Java arc and
compile the class. Also, this is one show
you because in this course really I only focus
on the theory of Java. So yes, I think that's
it really short introduction of the tools
that I'm using.
If you have any questions, send me an email
as always, um, yeah. Lesson seven. So now
let's start with the topic of this video,
which is conditional statements, and of course,
conditional statements, and Boolean. So a
Boolean is a new data type. This one is actually
a primitive and it can have two values, Boolean,
true or false. And this is all there is to
it. So conditional statements, I mean, there
is a condition and it can hold true or not.
And that is something is executed or not.
I think, already from the wording, it makes
sense, and you might easily understand it.
But what exactly is a Boolean? Why is it called
Boolean? I mean, this is a bit weird, I think,
well, at least this is what I found. So I
just looked it up on the internet. Here on
Wikipedia, we have Boolean algebra, and I'm
really not a big fan of mathematics. So let's
go over this really fast. The only thing that
matters to me is Boolean algebra was introduced
by George Boole in his first book, blah, blah,
blah whatsoever. So it turns out that the
Boolean is called all the end because of this
guy here. Um, I leave this as your homework,
read everything about George Boole and Boolean
algebra, of course, this is again a big topic
by itself. We have folk focusing again on
Java, I just wanted to help you that you get
a feeling why Boolean is called a Boolean.
So this thing here is really helpful when
we want to say if something happens or something
exists, some condition, then only execute
a specific area of code. And then you can
also say else if this condition does not hold
true execute something else. So this is really
the if statement is probably the most important
statement, not only in Java probably in all
programming languages, at least the ones I
know of, because it allows us to, like really
have a different execution flow each time.
For example, we could say, I mean, B is a
bit boring. Let's call this Monday. And let's
add all the raining. I was raining. Let's
also have Monday. Okay, so in this little
example, it's Monday, and it's raining. And
nobody could say if it's Monday, and percent
twice,
raining.
So what these two M percent mean is, and so
this tells Java to check on this boolean value,
check if it's true, and only if the first
boolean value. Or he could also be a function,
like, is it Monday, which would have to return
a Boolean. And if it does, only then Java
would execute, go here. And check if this
is also true. Which also could of course,
be a function if Is it raining or whatever,
right. And if both here are true, then this
block here, starting with the curly braces,
is going to be executed. Now. I mean, I don't
want to implement the functions. So let's
make this Monday again. And simply raining.
Just to keep it simple, and then drink beer.
Because rain. I mean, what else can you do?
Um, but now let's make this more easy to drink
beer. I'm from Munich, so I'm really a beer
lover. So on Mac, I mean, as depends which
platform you use. On Mac, you press just out
and seven, twice. This is called the pipe
symbol. And the pipe symbol symbolizes or,
um, yeah, I know this is a bit weird. This,
you just have to know by heart that this means
or, again, as before with the two ampersands.
When you repeat it twice, it's called the
short circuit operator, which means if the
first condition is already not true, for the
end, at least, then it's not going to execute
the rest. So whenever In a statement, it sees
that a condition will cannot hold true anymore.
It will stop at the beginning and they will
not execute the rest, which is very handy.
Because I mean, if before we had a method
here, is it raining. Now imagine this method
takes like two hours to execute, we could
really save that time if we already see. This
is only true if both are true. So this is
why you use the ampersand twice. And the pipe
symbol wise, this is I would say the default.
So I want to even spend time to talk about
the other alternative. But now this is so
much nicer. If I have an orange here, if it's
Monday, or if it's raining, I drink a beer.
So this really increases my chance my chance
to get a beer. So I personally liked the statement
so much more. I'm just kidding. Um, so this
is the difference. Or, and, and, and of course
you can further combine that led so I don't
know what to do. Let's say raining and let's
say Tuesday and sunny. So we have to introduce
these Boolean variables first. So Tuesday.
Well, if it's Monday, it can't be Tuesday.
So we will say false here. And Boolean, if
it's raining, it can't be sunny. So sunny
will be false. But of course, let's change
this. Now it's not Monday. It's Tuesday. So
this will be true. And I misspelled that sunny.
Okay, now they're not red anymore. So now
what do we have here? Monday is false. So
if Monday is raining, but it's not Monday
at the moment. So this is the whole thing
here is not true. But here we have an or true
Tuesday, this is true, Sunny is still false.
So this is also false, which means the whole
if statement is false. And we cannot drink
a beer. But let's make this true. And now
it's Tuesday. And it's sunny, and we can drink
a beer Ray. Of course, I mean, when it gets
more complicated, I'd recommend you to introduce
more brackets to really tell Java first execute
this. And the result when you have it, then
only execute the next statement. I mean, if
you go more in more detail on the algebraic
logic, you will see there are preferences.
And they're really rules on that. But if you
don't know them, and if you always just add
the brackets, you're on the safe side to show
what you want. Okay, now, let's make this
not so complicated. Because let's introduce
something, something else. And this else is
the else statement. Because if it's not money,
we can do something else. And this is the
new keyword that I'm introducing the else.
statement. So here, we can say drink, milk.
might also be nice. Okay, so, only on Monday,
we drink beer. And on all other days, we drink
milk. So that means we have to drink a lot
of milk. So if you I mean, milk is really
healthy. So I recommend you to drink milk
like this. It's much better. But of course,
let's introduce some more variation. If no
sorry, else if, um, as you introduce a new
day, let's say Friday. So we have to introduce
Friday. At the moment, it's Tuesday, Tuesday.
So we'll change that in a moment. Make this
false. So else a Friday.
Sorry.
Drink water. Okay, so what do we have now?
And I mean, you can format this in any way,
but usually, you formatted like this, too,
so that you can see this all this whole construct
belongs together? Because it starts with if
money. And if this is not true. Java has to
check else is it Friday? If so, then call
this function. And in all other cases, we
still drink milk. So, okay, and you can have
any number of L's if statements here.
Else if I don't know some other condition,
we could just say sunny. Um, if it's sunny,
um, what should we do? go swimming, go swimming.
Yeah, we can do anything here. Okay, so you
can have any number of L's if statements.
And you can have just one l statement, of
course, but you don't have to, I mean, this
is not obligatory. You can also leave it away.
You just you cannot have AIDS if by itself
because else what I mean, there has to be
the whole statement has to start with some
Eve. I'm okay. I think this pretty much is
enough for if else if and else. Now let's
do some more cool stuff. Let me Remove all
that. Because normally, you evaluate some
condition. And then when the condition is
evaluated, this returns a Boolean. Under the,
under the covers, I would say, for example,
you could say in E equals to four. And then
we could say end. j equals to three, omit
that. Okay, so we have two primitive data
types of the end, which are introduced in
a form of video. And then I can compare those
values. I can say, I mean, of course, as well
as with the Boolean is it's obvious. But I
mean, in a big program, it's not so easy.
Normally, one function calls the other, and
he would like have the user typing in nature.
And then you don't know if the user typed
in four, three, some in this is a really stupid
example. I think we know that four is bigger
than three. But let's assume that we don't
know. And then I could say, if i greater than
j, then do something. Else. Do something else.
I mean, here, it's again, you can say ELLs,
if you could say if j greater than I, what
else can we say, oh, if i equal to j, which
at the moment, of course does not hold true.
This, by the way, you see there are two equal
signs. The reason is this equal sign we use
here when we assign the value of four to i,
or j, so we can't use that again. Instead,
in Java, here use two equal symbols to express
I want to have a Boolean check. And what you
also can do so so you see the result of this
will be a boolean value, you can assign that
boolean value are equal to a boolean variable.
And this is actually quite often very smart.
I mean, here, it's very easy to understand.
But sometimes you have way more complex terms.
And then if you give it a name, your code
will be much more easy to read, because now
you can say are equal. Okay. And then there
is also greater or equal, smaller or equal.
And then also unequal, which I will usually
I'm typing like this, but it's actually the
same. So not equal, you can say with the exclamation
mark equal, or with greater, smaller, like
this, it's both the same thing.
I really prefer that one. I think it's more
readable. Because this is like, exclamation
mark, really easy to read. And with this,
you can also whatever condition you have,
if this no holds true, when you put the exclamation
mark in front of it, that is false. If this
before was holes. Now it's true. Thank you
can even Yes, you can, you can add any number,
exclamation marks, and every time the value
is inverted. So from to false than true again,
and false again, and so on. I mean, this is
not really readable. So I wouldn't do it.
Just to be complete. I wanted to mention this
as possible. Okay, on. I think this pretty
much wraps it up. We talked about Boolean.
This is a condition. If it's true, we execute
code that is in here. You see it can also
be empty. I mean, it doesn't really make sense.
I mean, I would really recommend you to write
something, execute some method. You can also
of course, you don't have to have an method
in here, while again, I would recommend it
because it might be much more readable. But
in here, you can also do crazy stuff like
i equals to eight, for example. J equals 299.
So you see, now we have actually some code
or plus class, the increment operator that
I talked about, I think it was in less than
five. So if j with three before, when this
is executed will be four, or minus minus,
it was three before it will be two. Okay,
so you can have 30 Booleans. And here, what
you cannot do is compare a Boolean to another
data type like int, amin, this wouldn't really
make sense what you can do, but, and this
really, a lot of beginners do like to compare
a boolean value let's make this Monday again.
Monday. True. And now you could say, if Monday
equals to true, what does this mean? I mean,
this means if true, equals to true. Of course,
this works. And if this was false, if false
equals to true, false does not equal to true.
So the whole thing is false. But I mean, this
is one comparison too much. To say, if Monday,
this is enough. Yeah. But really, comparisons
like this false or true. I really see very
often in code. So if you see that, you're
free to refactor the code, and just shorten
it. If it's true, then just say, if Monday,
if it was, if Monday false use just say, if
not Monday. So, see, this is not. Okay. Lesson
eight, I would like to introduce you to loops.
This is really exciting, because it's a very
cool feature. It allows you to execute a repetitive
task much faster than any human could do.
So this really makes our programming very
powerful. So it's very important to know how
to program loops. So there are certain different
types of loops. The first one is a for loop
for because it says like, for a number of
times, execute something. So this is why for
and then sorry, this writing here will be
a bit cryptic. I'm sorry. The reason is because
this loop is really also a very old loop.
That was also introduced before Java, actually,
I think it's, for example, is part of C and
c++, which are much older than Java, actually.
So and when they invented Java, they just
took over the same style. So this is why it's
a bit cryptic. So
we have three sections here. Let me first
of all, type it and then explain. So this
the three sections that this first loop usually
has, which means First of all, introduce an
int, and assign it a value of zero. calling
this variable II, I sorry, is like the default,
because I just for integer because the guys
that invented programming, are sometimes also
mathematics, mathematicians. So yeah, they
really like short variables like AI. And it's
so it's so common. I also used AI, but you
could also call it like culture. It just that
people would expect you to call it AI. In
this type of loop. It's mostly always called
AI or just why are some some variables short,
just one letter. Okay, anyway. So this is
our counter variable that defines how many
times we want to execute a certain statement.
Our statement that we want to execute is actually
that Create a person object. And we want to
do this four times. In programming languages,
again, mathematicians, they're to blame. They
don't start with one, but they start with
zero. So if we want to execute it four times,
we have to make sure that we stay that I stay
smaller than four, because from zero to three,
this is four times. And each time when we
are finished at the end of the loop, I is
incremented by one, see, this is the plus
plus. So afterwards, it's incremented by one,
and then the next round, it will be one, one
is smaller than four. next one will be two,
two is smaller than four, three is smaller
than four, and four is not smaller than four.
So for the fifth time, the loop will be exited.
And so afterwards, the court will be here,
the cursor kind of, and we will not execute
it a fifth time. So I copied this into the
for loop.
And then this should make sure that four persons
on the fly are created. Actually, because
this variable is defined within the block,
we cannot access the person object anymore
in here, I think I showed you this, see it's
red. This is about the visibility, what we
could do is we could put the definition of
the variable up here. This way, we can still
access person one, but actually only the last
one because the variable person will always
be overwritten by the next one. I mean, for
this little test here, this is okay. Because
all we want is we want to calculate the number
of times the constructor was called. So this
works, as well as we could also define person
in here doesn't make a difference. In our
case, because this is a static method. We
talked about this in the earlier lesson. So
now, let's try that code. And it's green.
Now let's try it to put the time here. This
darkness does not work. Because see we expected
for but actually, there was 10 times the person
constructor was called because this is 10
a year. So this is how the first loop The
for loop. The regular for loop usually looks
to define an end, you give it a one letter
name like I, you assign it zero, and then
you compare it to some max value. In this
case, 10. Before we head for so that the test
is green again, you always have to separate
these blocks with a colon. And then you increment
i by one. You can also do any other statement
in here. Like you could say, I equals i plus
two. Which will then let's see. So I'll assume
something. See now we only created two persons,
because each time it was incremented by two,
which means the number of times that we were
going through the loop was only half the number
of course. And if we add four or even I don't
know 10 we will probably only executed once.
Let's try that. Yeah, see actual one. Okay,
so usually you could put any statement here,
but the default is to just increment a counter
variable by one. So, release. Try to stay
with the default and do it like This, I could
even further tell you crazy stuff. Like you
don't even have to do all this can have this
empty. This now would be an infinitive loop,
you can try this at home, because this will,
like probably crash your PC because it will
create lots of objects.
Um,
but it is valid. Okay. But this is how it
should usually look. So anyway, let's go to
the second loop, which is the while loop,
while some condition holds true, execute.
And each of these loops have their specific
reason to be used. I mean, actually, in theory,
you could use always just the one loop like
this loop or that loop, it just that when
you want to count something, I mean, this
really is helpful. Because it does all everything
at once, if you want to do exactly the same
code, we have to do it like this int i equals
to zero. Well, I smaller than four. And then
you have to say, at the end, I plus plus.
So this is exactly the same. And you see,
it's not so nice and short anymore. So this
while loop, you would usually do one, for
example, you have some condition that gets
dynamically calculated, like we had the function
here should drink beer. So if you had some
function here, like should drink beer. This
is when you would use a while loop. I mean,
I have not defined those variables here. But
I hope you get the idea. If you have some
function that is always calculated, you will
use the while loop. And then in here. You
could also create person, and you don't have
to do this now. Because we assume that this
method sometimes would return false. And when
returns false, this loop would be exited.
Okay, but let's go back because actually want
to run it once. And there is a bracket missing.
Because I promise you we can do exactly the
same thing. So let's try that. Okay, well,
this probably will not hold true anymore,
because then we have done it eight times.
So let me remove that code. Okay. Let's check.
Seems Okay. Let's see what j unit says. Okay,
seems like this is okay. So it's the same
one. And then last but not least, there's
also another loop, which is called This is
the newest loop because it was introduced
as far as I remember, with Java five, this
is the most simple and the coolest loop. However
I'm sorry I cannot show you this one. Because
for this I need to introduce you to arrays
and collection which I will do in one of the
next lessons. So for now just know there is
another loop the coolest one actually. But
yeah, so this was a very short introduction
to two different loops. Well actually yeah,
I could also show you the while loop you can
also do it kind of let's say backwards. So
you can say do while some condition um the
regular while and the for loop I showed you
that very common bows, but this one you will
hardly ever see because Again, it's a bit
more difficult to understand. What it does
is it executes this statement the first time,
sorry, without even checking a condition.
So the condition is checked only afterwards.
Of course, we also need to increment.
Okay.
So what we do here is we assert that number
of persons equals to four, well, no, this
is, this won't work, we have to sort it afterwards,
sorry. So now we create the first person without
even knowing how many times we have created,
then we increment i. And at the end, we check
that I is smaller than four. Let's try this
and remove that.
See, this also works. Um, this depends on
the logic that you need. Sometimes you may
use that. But actually, all the three different
loops I showed you, they are like equivalent,
you can do everything with each of those loops.
So it's just the different style. And this
depends on what you want to express what's
easier for you to use. This you will get used
when you're like, did a few months of programming,
and you use each of them, you will get the
hang of it. What's like usable in which situation.
Lesson nine, I would like to introduce you
to arrays. Arrays are also a very cool feature
of many programming languages. And they also
appear in Java. I kind of unofficially introduced
them already in the last video, where I mainly
talked about loops. And we stopped when I
said there is one more loop the for each loop
that is specifically designed for arrays and
collections. So today I'm going to introduce
you to areas at least. And so we can also
see the for each loop. And so an array is
really like container, a box, or let's say
a list. So an array isn't is also an object
is a data construct that can hold a number
of primitive data types or objects. And as
I already said, box, so far person, the way
we define it is with these were brackets,
which symbolizes something like a box, I think,
which is easy to remember, because we will
put our persons kind of in in here we could
think and because this container will hold
a number of persons, I will call this variable
persons. Okay, now I say new person. But now
there comes something new again. I don't use
the regular brackets, or again use the square
brackets. This does not call the person constructor.
This would be done like this, and should not
be working yet there's already a thread on
the line. So I'm not calling any constructor
here. This is a specific syntax that says
Create me an array of type person that can
hold a number of persons. And we have to now
give the number which is four. That was still
a red underline now it's gone. So now Java
knows we want an array of type person that
can hold four persons same thing we can do
with it. And by the way, on a Mac, you have
to press out five and six for the square brackets.
So in that same way is equals to new end,
which is also you know in this primitive but
now I say new ends because I'm not creating
again, I'm not creating an end, I'm creating
an object, an end airy object. Okay. And you
can also see that it's an object, because
when I put it here, and I'll put down the
button, I see a number of methods that I can
call. And we are this is actually not a method,
this is an attribute, which I can directly
access. So if you remember, I think you I
said you should have your attributes private,
this is accessible, it's not private. So this
actually violates that rule. And yeah, so
this is also a very old construct, and shows
us one place where Java itself violates the
rules of good object oriented design, but
we just have to live with it anyway. So what
this does, and we will use it very soon as
it gives us the number of
like the the length of the array than the
like, in this case for, okay, if this is three
year, why intz dot length should return three.
And in a minute, you will see what we use
it for, let's remove the end. Because I want
to continue with a person's I want to feel
this error. And the way this is done, again,
we need to break it we need a lot of times
is I say zero here, oh, I said person, of
course this is wrong, we don't have a person,
we have only this one object, persons. And
the type is person airy. So it's not a person,
it's a person airy object. Okay, and here
we can say new capslock. person. What this
does is it creates a new person object in
memory, and puts a reference to this person,
which is like a remote control a way to access
the person into the array at position zero,
which is the first position. Let's copy and
paste that four times. Three, four. So position
one, position two, position three. Okay. If
I would say position four, what you don't
have, I would again, get an error, which we'll
talk about in detail when I introduce exceptions,
which is again, a new big topic. Oh, okay.
So, and when you have done that, what you
can also do is, you can do crazy stuff like
at position three, put the object that is
in the person's array, at position, whatever,
zero or one or whatever. Right, because whenever
you write on every ad position, as it contains
a person, it's exactly the same as if you
would say, person, my person equals to a new
person. So now I created a person. And this
object was assigned to this variable to this
reference variable. And can also do it like
this. So now, this variable can access that
object, as well as all there's title. Persons
at position three, can also access the same
object. So we have like two references to
like remote controls to this one object. Yeah,
and you can do also the opposite. You can
say, my person equals to I don't know something
Let's take two persons at position two, which
means the object that is at this position,
the reference to it will be assigned to the
reference variable, my person. So this, my
person object now
should still be here, if I'm not wrong, I
mean, this really gets confusing. So, I mean,
I'm just explaining this so that you get the
hang of it. But in reality, don't make it
too complex, because you see, the more complex
the more box packs you could introduce. Okay,
so I hope you get the hang of it. Um, one
more thing I might mention. Of course, no
one forces you to, to really define to set
an object at each position. Now, when I left
out position one, this position is empty.
So what does that mean? What we say is at
position one, there is now because knowledge
the word like for nothing. So there is nothing,
there is no reference. If we access it, we
get an exception, because Java will not know
what to do. Okay. So that much about now,
which we could also specifically do, by the
way, we could also now it, it's called, the
wrong button. Sorry. Yeah, so now you can
also write, so this is like, put nothing here.
Or, here, that would mean that the beginning,
you have the new person object at position
two, later on, you kind of throw the reference
away. And if no reference exists to an object
anymore. In Java, there is something called
a garbage collector, I will talk specifically
about the garbage collector very soon, in
a specific lesson only about the garbage collector.
So this one is smart, and we'll throw away
that object, we'll clean up the memory. For
us, this is really a cool feature of Java.
In other languages like c++, this doesn't
exist. And so you have to take care of cleaning
up the memory by yourself, which is really
not fun. So this is really one of the coolest
features of Java. But anyway, I guess I'm
going too far, let's make this more simple
again. Because what I actually want to do
is now I want to take the for loop, and combine
that with the arrays and introduce the for
each loop. But let's start easy, let's first
of all, go to the regular for loop, take that
put it here. And now we have let's remove
all that all we have is an object of person
array called persons. And we have this for
loop that may create for whatever in this
case persons. And so we will use that dynamically,
so because I will change while we go through
loop, we'll start with zero will be 123. So,
we can say persons at position I this is really
a cool thing now, because this means this
one line Let me clean this up. So we create
each time an object of type person and we
put it into the array dynamically add position
I. So this will on the fly fill the whole
array with persons. And what we can also do
is in a different loop but also just in the
same loop. We can access this object by saying
persons at position I and call some method
on it like hello world that we created in
an earlier lesson.
Um, okay, I think I have not introduced you
how to print something on the console. But
maybe I should not do this now, because I
guess I feel it gets confusing with all this
stuff with Aries, but would be handy now to
show you that this can print all the name
of something for each person. But maybe I
will do this in a later lesson. Okay, so just
believe me, if we would print that, we could
like print, hello, and then a person name
for each person. Okay, this is already nice,
but it gets nicer with a new loop for each
loop. And this is not so much different from
the regular for loop. It was introduced only
in Java five. And this works like that. person,
person, and then colon and then persons. So
what this does is it automatically under the
hood, it does everything that this for int
it does. And now we can also access person
dot HelloWorld. Of course, this requires because
now we are using it. So this requires that
this has already run? Um, let me think. Yeah,
so this is only for like reading it. I'm fulfilling
it. Now fulfilling it, I wouldn't use it.
Because you have to specifically say what
you want to do. Because if this is empty,
this would also be empty. Okay, so but we
can call person HelloWorld on it, and see
how much nicer This is really condensed. So
this is the for each loop. And the for each
loop is like besides areas, there's also other
constructs, other container types, which I'll
also soon introduce, like collections really
a cool topic, because they're even more powerful
than just arrays. And so this for each loop
also works with these collections, whatever
that is. And it does whatever is required.
And it also does it in a very smart way. So
it's really smart to use that for each loop,
not only because it's more condensed, but
also because it's a performance and proper
way of doing it. Because Java will assist
you in doing it. Okay, so I think this pretty
much wraps it Oh, no, there is I have I have
a not sorry. I didn't know Have I told you.
I think I promised and then I didn't do it.
Person start length. This attribute which
is not private, I think is public. Yes, should
be public. This gives us dynamically the four.
So I mean, here, we know that it's four. But
just imagine what can also be yours, you have
a method, which just gets a parameter. And
you don't know its size. So you couldn't say
four. And so this just dynamically takes the
lengths that you need. And as you see in this
loop, we don't even need it because this is
dynamically calculated by Java for you. Which
of course also that's the person that links
in the background. At least this is what I
assume. Okay, lesson 10. I would like to introduce
you to enums. enums and Java represent an
enum eration. So they enumerate something
they were introduced in Java five. Now, I
want to further extend my explanation about
arrays because there is one more cool thing
and it also makes it easier for us.
We can actually even on the fly out five,
aisle six, well this is autocompleted id he
already PR Since two equals two, and now I
do something new, I say curly brace, this
is alt eight and nine on my Mac, by the way,
and see, there is no red marking anymore.
This actually also works. So what does that
mean? This actually is a shortened form. And
this says there should be an array. And we
don't have to say, a specific size, because
the size is automatically calculated, because
the brackets are empty. This means empty size,
that would be the same as saying zero, which,
of course, doesn't make much sense. But just
technically, it's possible. So and we cannot
feel this array. So and we don't have to set
the size, this gets calculated automatically.
So I'm just copying. I can also put your mouth
if I want to, I can also create a new object.
My let's call it my personal Sorry, I can
also just to show you what's possible define
a variable of type person and then assign
now to it or talked about now, which is like
nothing and put it here. So this actually
is the same like that. And I mean, I want
you to also see this, what this does is it
does not or what is not is, it does not like
combine this array and that array. Instead,
it says what you have at position zero of
this array, which in our case, is this person
object. Take the reference to add and the
reference, copy it here, which means this
position as well as later on, persons, zero.
So later on, after we have defined the array,
if we say, person to zero, that will be exactly
the same as persons zero. Because they both
point to this object in memory. All this is
a bit complicated, I'm sorry, I hope you can
follow me. And I will do a specific tutorial
only on memory management and show you how
things look in the memory. For now, I just
hope you can follow if not, it's not so important.
I mean, we're talking here about areas and
what I want you to understand is like this
is an array and this is a way of defining
the array and the specifics about the memory
Don't worry, we can go in more detail later.
And you will you will understand this very
soon I'm sure let's do the same trick again
just with a different position. You can actually
even do it twice or any number of times can
take another one or it doesn't matter let's
put this or we can also remove them now put
it here. So yeah, you can do what and you
can also do it on the fly you can say new
person. Now there is no a little difference
which is this object that defined here.
It sits somewhere in the memory and might
error a person's to has a reference to it
outside of my array there is no one who has
a reference to it, which we can change after
we have defined it. We could also say I have
not to count 0123456 I hope I have counted
correctly if not imagined I had counted correctly.
Okay, so I said six. So at position six. We
cannot copy this reference and I can say my
let's call it secret person. Let's call it
just VIP. So my VIP, now I have a reference
to it outside of the airy. So I created it
dirty on the fly in this line together with
the definition of this array. And later on,
just for the sake of it, I assigned it a variable,
which we then also can use and work on it
like hello world, which you can also do is,
say, person two at position six dot HelloWorld.
So you can really work with the areas at specific
positions, just as if you had a variable,
it's exactly the same thing, even though it
looks a bit awkward. But yeah, you get used
to it. Okay, anyway, I think this is a very
handy short definition. Because see how much
shorter This is here we find just for persons
and area for persons. And this was actually
five lines. Now in just one line, we have
defined an area of six positions, and we have
filled it, and this is all in one line. And
I think it's still readable. I mean, readability
is the most important thing. So it's not about
making something short. It's okay to make
it short, if it keeps being readable, or if
it's even more readable. That is okay. Okay.
And I might also already introducing new stuff,
I might also introduce you to final final
is another variable modifier. We already talked
about public and private and static, not final,
something new final says are like locked in
this variable, I don't want to anyone to poke
around with that variable. So if I later after
saying final, say this, Java will say Oh,
no cannot assign a value to a final variable
person to. So this is like a protection. As
you see, I have to say final. So this is one
more keyword. And this is one key more keyword
to read. This is one more keyword to write.
And so I would only do it if it makes sense
for a reason. And if you have code that is
just like here, two lines. I mean, while doing
that, I would assume you know what you do,
and you wouldn't like put this to now if you
don't want to just one line later. Where this
does make sense is if you have something like
some constant values, some status values,
for example, you could have a process a program
that operates on some values. And then you
want to remember the state that your processes
in Okay, let me give you an example. So for
this, we will again define an array, but we
would do it in the class on the class level,
and we would not do it for the objects, but
for all objects of the class. I mean, and
this, of course, is static. So static, we
talked about this already means we have just
one of this type for all the objects and no
final. So static and final, they're really
close friends, they are used together very
often. And all that say string
because I want to have a string. But actually
I want to have a string array. And I said
we said the braces right after it so that
we see it's not a string. It's a string array
and I call it my state values equals and then
the curly braces again. And now I can say
like pending, processing and processed. I
could of course sorry, brackets missing. Add
many more. Just for now. I have a short example.
So this is what we could do. Something is
wrong here. Yes, comma. Okay. And this means
now, and I've also, oh, I did something and
didn't explain you why I did that. So far,
all the variables that we defined, we had
in lowercase letters here, use the uppercase
letters, and the underscore. This is also,
again, a best practice, because like, we would
use this static final, somewhere down here
in the code. And you see, now the definition
is gone, we don't see it anymore. And so that
a programmer working in here and knows what
you're working on here is static final. So
I don't want you to touch it, I just want
you to read it. There, therefore, we use the
capital letters, and we separate them with
the underscores so we don't use the camel
case. And then we could, again, of course,
iterate through these values.
For
so let's do the for each loop, say, stream,
nice date, or just stayed. And then the curly
braces again, we could say, if we're talking
about if state has a certain volume, will
actually we can't on a stream, say equals,
this is not going to work properly. Because
the equals is working on on on primitive values
like int, and it's comparing the value that
is directly in the variable. Oh, no, sorry,
I'm going really complicated. Um, I don't
know if I, if I'm making it too complicated.
But now that I already started, I might as
well continue what we have to say for if we
want to compare two strings is equals. And
so we can compare that to some other value.
So we can do it, state equals and then a string,
some other value. So this is some that equals
is a method that is directly given to us from
the string class that we haven't written,
but we're using it from Java. And the says,
compare this string to some other something,
blah, blah, blah. Okay, if they're both the
same, we could do something. And then we could
do this a number of times for each value.
So we had, as far as I remember, something
like pending.
And
processing. And, of course, uppercase and
lowercase make a difference here. And I think
it was processed, but I mean, this is just
an example. So it doesn't really matter that
much. So, and then we could do some some something,
colo method. And here we would call a second
method and the third method and so on. Okay,
but actually, this is a lot of code. So there
is a faster way of doing that. And this is
the switch statement that are also promised
to talk about. And second. This string here
is also not so nice, because you could change
it any time. You could say in here, state
equals to love. And, of course with just a
few lines. I'm sure no one would ever do that
or hope. But he mentioned we only have always
see a very short examples. We could have like
a very complicated code, hundreds, if not
1000s of lines and we could like call other
methods For what is two other classes, and
then if someone in some other class, like
changes your value, you might not notice.
And you don't want that. You want actually
to have the value final. But this with final
doesn't work, because final only protects
the variable. It does not protect the value
in here, which you can change any time. And
for this, we have the email. The enum allows
us to define an enumeration. Oh, okay, oh,
let me just remove that. Or we can keep it
for the time being. But let's jump over I
have prepared here class will actually it
will be our enum and it will not be a class.
Okay, so far have just said package. For less
than 10, I have set less than 10. And now,
like you know it with the class, the class
we would say public class, logging level,
and
races. But this time we're not doing a class,
we're doing something a bit smaller. And this
is the enum. And now this is obligatory, you
have to start with the status definition.
And it's not a string. So we don't need the
double codes that we would have for the string.
Now this is really a value and enumeration
value, which we define as our email. So we
like we like program our own type. And we
already program the allowed values pending,
had processing. I think we had processed.
Yeah, and then we end
here.
And now we have defined an email. And we can
use that. Let's go back to our test. Let's
say logging level logging level, or let's
call it
my
state equals to logging level pending. So
this is a lot looking like static. And this
is already how it came. Because now we can
use these static values, we can also iterate
over them. But we cannot change this. I mean,
we cannot. Of course we can change it. But
we can only change it to the allowed level
allowed statuses that we have defined beforehand.
We can set pending, processed and processing,
the order is different but still the same.
It can only have one of the three values.
We could not say here. something crazy, because
it's not a string, we can only use the values
that we have defined here. And this is really
helpful and makes also our code more readable.
Now we can again, iterate through this enum.
In this case, it's a bit more complicated
actually, because we have to call a method,
which is called values. This method will give
us something like an array of all the allowed
values in here, pending processing processed.
And then, of course, there's not a string
anymore. We say let me also remove that. And
then we can do the same. Now, it's okay to
say equals, see this works. Of course, it
does not make sense. I mean, a string will
never be equal to an enum, but it's perfectly
fine. You may compare any object to another
object. Of course it makes more sense to say
equals dot for example, pending and then here,
processing and prose So
let's put processing.
Here.
Let's put processed. Okay? Um, but this is
not so readable. And we don't need equals
here. This is so cool. Actually, for an enum,
we can do the comparison, just with the double
equals, again, this does work. Because yada
yada, yada. Java DOES MAGIC under the hood.
So for now, just believe me it's working.
Because this is not an object, this is a static
value. Okay. Let's just remove this. Okay.
Now, you see, I think it already got so much
more readable and shorter. That However, there's
still a shorter form, which is the switch
statement. However, we will not do this today.
We'll do this in the next tutorial, the switch
statement, because I think otherwise, it's
just too much for one tutorial. Now we talked
about arrays repeated the for each loop. Yeah,
and I introduced the enum, which has here
this values method. Actually, there's much
more an enum can do. Maybe I should show you
this one. We can also add these brackets here.
Let me do this for a moment. And now we can
put values in here. So what is this going
to be? I'm adding a constructor, which must
be private. Let me check if it may be default,
but I think not. Well, let's just try it seems
to be working so far, but I'm sure it may
not be public, yet. This is not working. So
default, visibility seems to be okay. Even
though I think it's a bit awkward. And now
see this. It says the end cannot be applied
to this constructor. Because so far the constructor
is empty. Because what happens is, this is
calling the constructor. So let's put in here,
and now it's working. So having the constructor
here, you might also see I was kind of lying
to you, of course this is an object. But it's
just that for specific reasons, I don't want
to go in detail, we can still do the comparison
with the double equals here. Okay, anyway,
so we have a constructor. And let's now assign
the eye to some other variable. Of course,
you see, this doesn't make sense, assigning
eye to eye and we have already had that. This
thought I know, of course, I have to define
it. And make let's make this private. So now
it's working. I don't like it, I want this
private, this is just what he would do. Okay.
And then I mean, this, this depends what this
means could be some code of some form. So
let's have a method that returns public code.
And this was returned. I. So this enormous,
really powerful, is allows us in dismissing
to have methods to return something. But it
has these static values that we can iterate
over and that we can only choose from. You
could also think of a traffic like light with
like red, yellow, and green. You can also
of course have more values here any number.
I'm actually you don't have to have the enum
in its own file. You could directly on the
fly define it in line in a class, I would
just not recommend you to do saw, I mean,
forever, you're all there is an exception
and find out these exceptions for yourself.
But in 99% of the cases, you would be better
off having it in your own class. So yeah,
there's much, much more actually that you
can do with an enum. But I think we already
this tutorials already a bit long. And I think
I want you to digest this for now. We can
further extend this anytime, of course. So
that's the name. With its constructor and
a public method returning the I, you can also
have more parameters in here like a string.
But if you're if one of them has it, and all
of them have to have it, and every parameter
appearing here has to appear in the constructor
string, some string or let's just say s. You
may use it but you don't have to use it. But
usually, of course, you would use it as equals
s. And then something.
Yeah. Okay.
So I think that's enough for now. And the
next tutorial, I'm pretty sure I'm going to
show you the switch statement. Because this
is really cool for using for iterating over
these enum values, then the code gets much
shorter. I am going to talk about the switch
statement, which is another conditional statement.
Very similar to the if statement. However,
first of all, let's recap what I showed you
in the last episode. Actually, in the last
one, I covered a lot of ground, I think, I
hope this wasn't too fast for you. So let's
shortly recap. First of all, I showed you
this new way of defining an array. So like
the traditional, let's call it, the traditional
one was this one, where you just said, person,
square brackets, persons equals to new person
have four chairs with the size of four. So
this can hold four elements starting at zero.
Well, this needs a lot of lines. And this
actually is the short form just with the curly
braces opening and closing. And with a comma
separated list, you can define an array. And
my recommendation is end with a comma at the
end, so that you can easily extend the array
at a later time. Also, I introduced a new
modifier for variables, a final modifier,
the final modifier kind of protects a variable
for us. So what it does is when in a later
line, I try to assign something new. Like
let's use this area on top here, this is not
going to work cannot assign a value to final
variable persons to also we can try to assign
now, which is like emptying the variable will
also not work. This is nice ish. However,
I personally prefer to not use it locally
in a method. But instead to use it for static
final variables that are used read only and
are defined at the top of the class usually
like this here. I hadn't said any modifier.
So this at the moment is default visibility.
Usually I would prefer, like having it private.
And if you need other classes accessing it,
I mean, this is supposed to be read only.
So it would be okayish have this public. However,
even better. If you really want to focus on
clean code like I do. You could provide a
public method returning the string array.
I don't know some name. Let's call it states.
And in here, first of all, let me finish this
we could copy this out Because with a copy
if someone else, because the final, what it
does protect is as I set the variable, what
it does not protect as the content. So it's
safer if return a copy of the array. And there's
actually a helping Claus, which provides of
Java, Java util, which provides some static
methods and really have a look, see, we are
going to use the copy. But there's also many,
many more methods like here for doing a binary
search and so on. This is really a big toolbox
of methods that you can use, play around with
them. And I might show some of them at a later
time. For now let's use the copy off. And
then we take the array. And we have to state
the size, which again, we take dynamically,
array dot length, yeah, we also talked about
this. But this is dynamically returning the
length of the array, which in this case is
three, because the array has three elements.
So this is really a nice way of
generating clean code and returning this array.
Also, I told you, it's all in capital letters
and using the underscore and not written in
camel case, because this symbolizes that is
a static final. So in short, you just talk
of a static final, because this is how you
write it. Okay. Let's go back to the bottom.
I'm sorry, so not much about the array. I
also very shortly talked about equals, because
I had to, because for two strings, like ABC.
And you if you want to compare them, you cannot
do so with the double equals. This is not
going to work, even if it's the same. Because
the problem is that this comparison does not
compare objects. And this is an object, instead,
it compares the reference variable. So equals
does work for int three, and then you can
say three equals I, because the three is actually
in here. But if you have a string, let's make
it null for now. In here is not the object
or now in here is the reference, which is
something you can think of something like
a number also will be saved in here. And when
you compare with the equals the two equal
signs, then you compare this variable, which
means you kind of compare if it's exactly
the same. So what will be true is if you would
say my string equal equal my string, but this
usually is not what you want to say. And so
when you compare two strings, you have to
say equals talking about equals usually in
one sentence, you should always also talk
about the hashCode method. This is already
a very advanced topic. So let me keep this
very short for now. It just that if you create
a new class, like I created the class person,
it's often a good idea all depends, but you
might want to implement the equals method
in your person object so that you can compare
two persons. But if you do, so, you also have
to implement the hashCode method. What the
hashCode method is and all the details I will
explain at a later time. Okay, so that much
about the string comparison. Oh, one more
thing. I made this now because I also wanted
to make a point. What I see very often is
people that would write equals like this,
my string dot equals and then a static value.
This is not so nice, because as you see this
Might be now. And then this throws an error.
And of course, we don't like arrows. So instead,
always put a value in the front, which will
never be now, like this string here. I mean,
this is ACB, as a roll down, it will never
be now. So ACB equals now, we'll just return
false. But now equals ACB will always throw
an error. Okay. So let's stop here. Then,
actually, the biggest part of the last lesson,
we talked about enums, which I introduced,
I created this enum here logging level, let's
go to the class. So public enum logging level,
I do find, actually, the name is a bit awkward.
Because it's not a logging level, I was thinking
of something like info, warning, and error.
But then I decided we haven't talked about
logging either. So I
instead took pending processing process. So
this would more be more like a status. But
I don't know, let's leave the name for now
is just a stupid example. So this is the IEM
that are introduced, which is a bit similar
to a class, but has some limitations, but
also has some features a class does not have.
So it allows us to define these static on,
let's call them labels that we can act upon
in our code. So we can say if something is
pending, to this or that, so it's not only
more readable, it's also more safe. enon was
introduced was Java five. And before that,
people would have taken numeric values, like
if something is equal to not to zero, or one.
But then already people started to calculate
these values, this really gets nasty and problematic.
And I'm not showing you this because I want
you to do it in the proper way. And that is
using an enum. So this is really a cool feature.
You can you don't have to also introduce a
constructor, if you want to have extra values
for each enum value. And you can provide methods
that would return these values, or do whatever
you want, which are also like to make the
code more readable, is I often provide I mean,
not always. Whenever your code and you design
your code, always think decisions through
don't make a decision just because this is
never smart. So if for whatever reason, then
the code you work on, for example, the pending
value, and you need to ask is it pending,
that it might be nice to add this method is
pending.
And then you can say return this, which is
the minimum and not only the minimum, but
the current value of the enum equals equals
pending. So if in the code, you have an enum
let's do this modern level, still I call it
stage or status equals logging level, not
take processing. And then I could say if stayed
Dodd is pending, which now would be false.
Some code would have to be executed. But what
I want you to know is only add such a method
if you really need it. So it would not be
wise to always by default, provide a method
for each of these values.
People usually get lazy and when they see
something is working, they tend to just overuse
stuff and they just like I might be I might
need this. So let's just ask Method just because
no, never do that. Never add a method just
because always think think it through, I mean,
code lives. And you can always change your
code later. And you always can add a method
later. So only edit when you need it. Let's
say no, we don't need it. So we will also
remove it. Okay, I think this pretty much
rounds it up. For enums. Actually, they allow
much more crazy stuff, like each value could
have their own method implementations. I hardly
ever use it. So let's not show this for now.
I think this is pretty much what you need,
usually. And now, let's finally actually go
to the topic of this lesson, which is the
switch statement. So I think I already a bit
introduced it. In the last lesson, I said,
we want to shorten this here. So the switch
statement is also a conditional statement.
And that's pretty much exactly the same, like
these ifs here, just in a shortened form.
Okay, I mean, don't think about the exact
meaning here. This is just pseudocode. To
explain you something. Okay, this time, I
will not use a for loop, I will directly operate
on this state here. And then we can instead
of saying if we can say switch, so we are
operating on that value here. And then, instead
of if we're saying case, so if it's the case
that the state has this or that volume, case
pending. So this is the same as saying, If
equals pending. If you just have one, then
if it's of course shorter. But the switch
statement is usually used when you iterate
through all or most of them, because you have
this extra of saying switch, but then the
more states you have, the easier or shorter
it will get processing case process. Now I
mentioned we will have 100 different ones.
Let's format this. Now what happens is, I
haven't put any method here, and I have not
put a break statement here. So actually, what
would happen here, now let's put the same
method call, I mean, I have not implemented
the method, just the method. Imagine this
was a method. So for all these three different
states, while there is a common reason, we
would call this method. If imagine we use
a switch statement within a private method,
you could also like return a value. So this
depends, the difference with a return is when
you return something from a method, of course,
you also leave the method, while I'm pointing
this out is because normally usually, what
you want is you want to do something and it
might not even return something like printing
something on the console. And you would call
one method. And in here, you would call a
second method or do a second something calculation
or so. And here a third one. Now it gets problematic
if you forget the break, because what then
happens is a fall through this will be cold,
as well as that will be cold. So this is really
a big source of bugs. Very, very dangerous.
So in this case, never forget the break. And
if sometimes you'll want to have them together
because you want all the three of them for
example or to to call a certain method it's
recommended to leave a comment false through
so that you tell the next program I know what
happens and I did this on purpose.
Okay.
So that much about follow through. And you
don't have to set all possible values. You
can also leave One out, if nothing is found,
in this case, we will just leave the switch
statement, and we'll just not do anything.
What you can also do is you always have the
possibility to adding a default, which will
be called if none of the other case statements
apply. And then people sometimes say, I don't
know, call default method. Well, he, I really
want to warn you. And of course, again, we
had fall through would have to say, break.
This is not so wise. The problem is, I mean,
code lives. And who stops the next colleague
from extending your enum adding, for example,
an error state here for some text, your colleague
would just do this would not know there is
this switch statement. And now, you implemented
the switch statement, you didn't think of
the error case. And the error case might need
a specific behavior. But now you would also
call this method for this new error flag.
So usually, we don't want that. So what I
recommend you for the default statement, either
you don't use it, or even better use it. But
here, you would throw an error. He say, I'm
not doing this now, because I haven't talked
about exceptions yet. We will do at a later
time. But this is the place where you would
have like an exceptional case. And the good
thing about this is when someone extends your
income, and someone forgets to extend also,
one or more switch statements, you will see
this, I mean, you might say Oh, but then my
program crashes. And this is so nasty. Well,
of course it is. But there is a rule in good
design. And this is called fail early, it's
always better to have a high severe back on
production even. And to have to fix this within
let's say, seconds or hours than to have a
high severe bug. And no one notices it. Because
if it would not throw an error, it might calculate
something in a wrong way. But a client might
notice this, let's say three months later,
and then the problem will be so so much bigger.
So when programming, sometimes you just have
to be brave. I also see people that try to
prevent arrows and like return something,
for example, return now. So this is actually
just, instead of accepting I have done something
wrong. And let's fix it. This is just like
putting the problem to the future and making
it bigger. So I want you to be brave and throw
exceptions and handle them then this is always
better. I mean, I'm not saying you should
program buggy code. Of course, we should try
and concentrate. But sometimes bad things
happen. And then it's always better to fail
early. And so you you notice the problem and
you can fix it. This is always better than
hidden bucks. Okay. I hope you got my point.
Okay,
so also here. Well, if you have an exception,
you don't need to break because an exception
always leaves the block. But what is important
to always have a break, or, like here, we
don't have to break, leave a comment for through
to tell the next programmer, I know what I'm
doing, I want this and Tommy about warnings.
One more thing. don't overuse switch. as well.
don't overuse the if statements, these conditional
statements, you'll see how much the code grows
also in combination with for loops and see
how many levels This adds to the code. You
have to understand this switch. And then there
is different case statements or default. And
then inside of the case statement, there might
be a method called and so on. So this really
complicates the code. Same as with the if
statement. You have to See what is the condition
for me to enter this blog, ha, then this method
is called, you might click to the method,
you might want to check here. So this all
makes it more complicated. And actually, this
is also like a, let's call it a relic from
the past. This is what we call procedural
code. Because it's like a procedure, it's
like really, this makes you thinking like
a machine, like a machine would switch a state.
What's a case this dude that case this do
that. But humans usually don't, they don't
think like this. And the cool thing about
object oriented programming is that the object
oriented programming is very close to how
humans think. And this allows you to like
talk to business guys. And this really makes
your code nice. And switch is not object oriented.
There are some cases, corner cases where you,
it might just be easy and fast to use it,
but don't over use it. Really, I mean, there
are people that would have maybe hundreds
of lines in here, this is just crazy, really
hard to read. This is also why I had here
method, this is not yet perfect, but still
better than just having huge switch statements.
There are techniques, for example, just shortly,
you could have an object representing the
pending state, and an object representing
the process state and so on. So they are at
once techniques of how to prevent a switch
statement. And it always depends, like, what's
better? for very small switch statements?
It might be okay. Just remember, they are
a bit like evil and should not be overused.
Okay, I hope I have added enough warnings
of switch. And if statements. This is also
one reason why I'm only introducing it now.
Because I really want you to become a object
oriented programmer. I will further continue
talking about the switch statement. So I told
you that it's used to iterate over the different
values of enums enums, which are also told
you were introduced with Java five, um, before
that, the switch statement also existed, but
you had to emulate enums. And the way this
was done was by using int values. Um, this
is not so optimal. And this is also why enums
were introduced, because they're more typesafe.
And I would also not recommend you to show
to us ins in the switch statement. I think
I already said that in the last episode. I
even didn't want to show you but now I realized
I think I should still show you. Because you
will see it sooner or later. And so that you
can understand code of others, I will show
you, but just try to avoid it. Um, okay, anyway,
with that warning, I'll show you. And now
let's give it some name. Um, I call it my
state.
And now I give it some number 42. I mean,
this is just an example. And could mean whatever.
And this is already your problem. 42. What
does it mean? Does it mean pending? Does it
mean processed? How do we know? Well, to make
it a bit better, they then introduce static
final values, which I'll do right now also.
So let's go to the top and on the class level.
Let's introduce now this is a method. Let's
do it here. Private static, final, let's call
it processed, processed. Forgot to give it
the type of the primitive type int and this
is the 42. And we could also have pending
so this is like a trick. But you see this
is also where a normal use case From. So this
is also why in enums, we usually use the capital
letters. Okay, because it's a constant value
that will not be changed. So now I will give
this the name of pending cross cutting, let's
call this processing and processed. Now, of
course, we need different values, that could
be a 40, then this could be a 41. And this
would be a 42. And now I can copy that, go
back down. And then I can say, my state oops,
equals pending. And pending now, I think it
was 41. And then I can now switch on the end.
And now this is funny before depending was
of the logging level. But Java is smart enough
to realize, now we're not iterating on the
enum anymore, but on the int and s, we also
have processed there, as we have named it,
it still works. Of course, I mean, just to
show you, this is just because we named the
variable the variable. So if we processing
is not used, called is something then of course,
we will have to use this something below here,
because now you see pending as red, because
cannot resolve symbol pending. Because we're
not on the interim anymore. We only int something,
the problem is that my status an end. So no
one guarantees us that only these three values
that we want to use are used. anyone at any
time could say my state equals to 300. And
then it will not be something it will not
be processed, it will end up in the default.
See. And this is also a reason why here you
should not have regular code, but throw an
exception instead. Which we'll talk about
very soon, I hope. Okay, so anyway, this is
what you can do with an int. And since since
Java seven, I mean, at the time I'm doing
this video we are, we have Java eight. So
when they introduce Java seven, you now can
also use strings on my string, give it a name,
called also my string. Okay, not used yet.
and copy it. And now we can also switch on
strings. Of course, something doesn't work
because it's not a string, it's an int. So
now, I can of course start to use. Well, for
example, the empty string or a blank string.
I can use, again, something in lowercase letters.
And of course, here also I can do a column
labels, which then of course, are private,
static, final string. And now I call it I
don't know. I haven't used pending because
here of change it to something.
And I will call this pending. But it could
also be any anything any string 42 Yeah, whatever.
So of course, using that label, I'm only using
one now I think you got the point on too far.
Okay, so now, that label I can also use pending
in here. Um, you might remember from the last
session I talked about the fall through, which
is you don't have a brief statement here.
So if it's this case statement will be the
same one as that statement, which will both
then call this method and then break is called,
which will leave the switch statement. So
the court will continue online 122. The default
is at the end. It could also by the way, be
anywhere else. For example at the top which
would not be also a full Through. So if it's
not pending or something, or pending is, I
don't even know anymore what we put there,
I think it was 42. So, in this case, all the
threes different cases would call a method,
which he or we could have some other method.
As always, I'm not going to implement the
method. And then we could say break so that
for the default, just this method would be
called. And then we would end up here, leaving
the statement and ending in Wait, where's,
see, if I put my cursor at the beginning of
the switch statement of the curly brace, I
don't really see it ends up here. Because
if you have a method, and this is also a reason
why you should keep your methods very short.
You see, the method seems to go until line
141. And this method now got so big, that
it's really hard to see where it starts and
where it ends. So yeah, I can't say it often
enough, keep your methods short, I would really
keep them at one to 10 lines at most. I'm,
I'm really happy. If I'm able to keep them
at one to three lines. Some say I'm really
on my might be too strict on that. But you
will very soon see the fruits of your methods
are, the easier it is to understand them.
And also, the easier it will be to reuse them.
Yeah. Okay. But now back to the topic of the
switch statement. So you can use it with strings.
As of Java seven, you can use it with enums,
like I showed you in the last episode, you
can use it with ins and any other number types.
So far, I've only showed you int. I'm actually
there are others. I'm not sure if I should
really talk about the others, because they're
hardly ever used. They've just the range of
the number ranges just a bit smaller. In 99%
of the cases you would use it because I mean,
it doesn't really matter these days. how large
the ranges. So it is always fine. I mean,
not but maybe I still show you. For example,
this could be a bite. But now this is already
not working anymore. Why is it because I have
changed it on the string. Let's fix that.
So the bite here. This is just smaller than
the end. For example, if you put 3000 here,
it says this is incompatible, because it's
an int because it's too small. Um, yeah, but
the three works. But I really don't want to
go further in details. If you're interested,
you can also read this on the internet. Because
all you really need encode in 99% of the cases
is the end. So okay, I think this pretty much
rounds up the switch statement.
So you can use it with a string and an int
Oh, there's one data type, which I might show
you. That's also interesting. And this is
a car. A car is a string of a length of one,
while it's not a string, but it's very similar.
So it uses these single quotes instead of
the double quotes. So if I'm using the double
quotes, it's automatically a string. And this
doesn't work anymore. Here it says incompatible
types required car found string with a single
quotes, it's a car. So it's a character of
length one one single character. Of course,
it could also be a or b. But it cannot be
longer than one character. Because then it's
not a character anymore. Too many characters
in character literal. Okay, so we can also
iterate over characters. This sometimes might
be interesting. if you for example, parsing
a string or what is parsing it's have a string
five string equals something. And now you
can take each single character, because a
string is actually a combination of several
characters. And then you can iterate over
each character. And then you can switch over
this. Um, yeah. This you might need at a later
time. So I've also introduced car now and
told you there are other number types. I would
like to introduce you to logging. Well, actually,
what is logging?
Hmm.
Well, first of all, let's tell you what my
idea is. I have prepared this little test
here. I have prepared a little class car service.
I wanted to process this string, BMW, or Beamer.
And in the class, this class so far is empty.
My idea is I want to be notified in some way,
like a print out on the console into a file,
that database or maybe even an email or something.
So I want to be notified in some way I want
to monitor if someone calls this method, so
that I, like later on, can go through all
the course and can see if something happened.
For example, if my system was hacked, I could
go through a file and see what time what happened.
And then yeah, analyze it. So that's the idea.
And the way this is done, is by logging. So
actually, logging for me this word was a bit
weird. So I looked it up. Wikipedia is your
friend. So let's do this. So logging is called
logging for a ship's logbook. A logbook? Is
this thing here, you know, of ancient times
when the captain in his cabin was making plans,
and was writing down at what time he was at
which place and what speed the ship was going
in that direction. So this is a logbook. So
this is already like monitoring the state
of the ship. And but still I was asking, why
is the logbook called logbook. While this
article here have a read just very fast going
through it says it. The term originally referred
to a book for recording readings from the
ship lock. So what is a chip lock, let's click
and ship block, also called common lock shaped
lock or just lock is a navigation tool for
marinas used to estimate the speed of a vessel
through water. Interesting, so there's also
an image. So this thing here is the shape
lock from the end of the ship. And here's
even a picture they were throwing out the
ship luck and in equal distances they were
not in this line in this long line and the
faster the boat goes the faster Of course,
this chip block is taken away. And by measuring
the time they could measure the speed and
this was done given by knots. So this is still
why speed of a ship is given in knots even
today. So here it says ship log and associated
kit, the real of lock line is clearly seen.
So it seems I don't know this, but I just
guess it that it's called lock, because this
really looks like a lock, like, like a three
strong because it's this huge block. So I
would guess that this is why it's called lock.
So, this is why the ship lock is called ship
lock. And this is why the act of doing like
writing something into the lock is called
logging. And as a programmer, you can think
of yourself of like the captain of the code.
And as such when you want to write on events
that happen while your program is running,
you are logging and this is what we are going
to do today. So how is logging done in 2015
and 15 Well, currently you would use SL for
J. This is a framework for logging. I mean,
of course, you could write your own logging.
But this is a lot of work to make it
work properly. And this has been done already
for you. You can just use this framework.
Well, actually, this is only for Sade, well,
FSH is a design pattern that we haven't talked
about. So two, we could say it like, allows
you to use here is how it's used. you import
the code, Ork SL for j logger and logger factory.
And then, within your code, you say logger,
logger, logger, factory, get logger. give
it the name of the class. And you can use
it with different implementation of logging.
Because for many, many years, the most prominent
logging framework was log for J. Well, this
has changed. At the moment, you should probably
better use lockback because it's a more powerful,
and it's author is I don't can't pronounce
it properly. But I try shakey Goku, and this
is the same guy that actually implemented
love for J. So he continued with lockback,
because he wanted to make logging even better.
So today, therefore, we use SL for j in combination
with lockback. Because using this sl for j
visade. will allow us at a later time, if
there is a new logging framework introduced
that is even better than lockback, we can
easily each switch to the new framework without
having to change the code. Because the code
doesn't use the code of lock bag. It uses
SL for J. So how is this done? Let's jump
into the code. Okay, so first of all, I told
you, I'm using Maven for the configuration
of the dependencies. So here I've configured
to use the dependency org. So for j, and lockback,
classic. This is actually the implementation
of SL for J. And this is the core code of
lockback. So you need these three dependencies
to get logging in your code. Okay. And then
you should also have in source main resources,
our file called lockback, dot XML. Here, you
can define different things. Well, first of
all, you can say, how should you lock where
should you lock, in my case, I say, with giving
this class console appender, that will result
that my code is locked to the console directly.
There are also other appenders, or other implementations
for logging. So we can also look to the file
to the database, to email. And if there's
something you want to have locked to that
doesn't exist. You can also implement your
own implementation, like I don't know, maybe
like logging into Twitter in some way, if
that makes sense to you. Okay, and this is
the pattern, how, when a message is written,
in this case, to the console, it should look
like so the patterns has, I mean, you have
to read the documentation for details, but
it's like, give me the time when this event
occurred, the threat the logging level, because
the logging level is like a mechanism. It's
like a grouping mechanism. You can have different
levels of logging. This is like a signal of
the severity of the problem. Because debug
is probably for debugging purposes, use that
sparsely.
Then there is a logging level info and error.
So error you would use if there is an error
in your code, info for general information,
and debug, just for you know, some debug information.
But this really should be used partly because
for debugging. You can also use a debugger,
like in your ID, or we haven't talked about
debuggers either. But yeah, just for now.
Now there are different levels. So, in your
code, you can then say, I want to lock this
on level debug. And here I have defined the
package name. And I say here, this, when I'm
when there's some logging of a class that
is of this package, then I want to log it,
if it's debug, I could to also put your error,
that would mean only if it's an error, log
it. Or I could put here info, that would mean
only login, if it's info. info, of course,
also, it would include arrows, because this
is like more. So debug includes all includes
debug, info and error, but error would only
log messages that are locked on level error.
So you see, this is really makes it more flexible.
And you can even have here different loggers
for different packages. So we could also copy
this and, like have here a different package
like Java course two, and so on. And we could
then have this on the one on debug and the
other one on error. So this is really flexible
and can be changed. And here, this is the
root level. So like, generally lock on info
level just for this package. Log on debug
level, this is what it means. Okay, this was
only very short. There's much more information,
of course, on the internet. But first of all,
maybe a week go to our test. And we add the
login details here into car service, I put
it. So first of all, I need to import a few.
Like we saw just before in the documentation
here you see my ID, he already helps me SL
for j because I said we want to import only
SL for j and SL for j by itselves. knows that
it should be used, I should use lockback because
it will find the dependency of log back classic.
This one here. So SL for j is really smart.
So we don't have to tell it. Okay, so we say
SL for j lager and we say import org SL for
j.no. Just one dot logger factory. Okay, a
factory, by the way, is another design pattern.
At a later time, I will also do probably a
course, only on design patterns. design patterns
are like best practices on how you should
program code. And when you know what a factory
is, you will directly know what this thing
he does. Okay, more about design patterns
at a later time. Anyway, this is what we have
to do. And now in our class, we would probably
say private final lager. Let's call it log,
because it's all log. And then we say logger
factory. Get logger. So what this factory
does like a factory. This is why it's called
a factory. It gives us a logger. And we don't
know how is it created on the fly is a longer
reused, this is a smart thing and does all
the necessary work for us. Now, we should
still give it the name of this class. Because
this will be used car service class. That
sorry, in our log back XML XML file which
is in source main resources. As I showed you,
I mean, here we have a package, but we can
even extend that and lock only for specific
classes.
So this is the test and this is the service.
Okay, so this is how you generally find a
logger. Now, in here, you can now use it log.
Well actually, it's not static. I might just
as well have this in lowercase log dot and
in former times, like With log for j, some
of you might know it, you would usually say
like this is debug enabled. If it's debug
enabled, only then log something, log dot
debug. And now I could say, processing, car
plus input. So the input given in our case,
BMW, this will create a string, and then this
will be concatenated. together. And all this
will be locked, if the debug level isn't able,
at the time when the code runs, which at the
moment, as far as I remember, it is. So we
can activate and deactivate this. The reason
why we need this line, I mean, we could also
do it without just like this. But this is
not so good. I mean, in case of a string,
it's not so bad. I mean, all that would happen
is this string, and that string would be put
together. But you mentioned the string could
be really of in almost infinitive lengths.
So Java in the background for you, this concatenation
might take a lot of time, especially if we
have some very big object here, that might
internally consists of other objects, and
so on. So this creation of a string, as stupid
as this might sound can take a lot of time.
And, of course, I mean, here, we just have
a very stupid small program with just one
debug line. But of course, you would log maybe
not on debug, but on info or something, or
error, maybe a lot of stuff in your application.
And like, you could think of 1000s users concurrently
calling this method. And then if this only
takes, like, I don't know, 200 milliseconds,
200 milliseconds might not seem a lot of time.
But if this is done 1000s of times, then this
can really consume a lot of performance of
your server or PC. And so we would only like
to concatenate the string, prepare the string
for logging, if this will actually be logged,
because if we say log info, but then the logging
framework finds out, well, this does not have
to be locked, it would have to throw away
all the strings that were concatenated. So
we had done this without any need. And so
this we would want to prevent. And this is
why in lock for j, you would do it like is
debug enable debug. Or you can also say is
info enabled is error enabled, and so on,
is info enabled. Now it's locked for j and
SL for j However, there's actually even a
smarter way. Because you see, this was three
lines of code. And this is you can put here,
these curly braces. And then you don't have
to say plus, but you say comma. So within
the framework, the framework decides, well,
the user in this case, this would be us wants
to log on debug, first of all check is debug
enabled for this class. And if so, only then
take this input converted to a string if it's
not a string already, and only then concatenate
this string with this string. So this is really
a smart thing now. Okay, so another enough
of talking. Let's try this out. Okay, let's
check. We have the input given from the process
method. And we want to say processing car,
and then in our test,
we put here BMW or Beemer. Okay, so let's
also recheck our configuration file, log back
XML. We said comarca spiele. java course,
level is debug and the root level is info.
So if we no log on debug, within this package,
and comarca spiele Java course this is the
package. This means we should log it. Okay,
let's run the test.
Okay, so something happened. Process finished
with exit code zero. And here you see
at this time, which is now on level debug
from this class from this package car service,
we wrote processing car column BMW. So this
was logged. Okay. Now, let's try to deactivate
it. Let's say we only want to log on error
level for this package. Let's execute it again.
Run. Process finished. On top, this is all
information from lockback. When it gets configured?
Well, you see there is no BMW locked. Okay,
let's change that. We could say the root level
is debug. And we could say or, let's have
this on, let's have this on debug. And now
let's change the package. For example, Java
course two. Well, we're not in Java course
too. But we are in the package called Marco
spiele Java course, which means we should
log on the root level, which is debug. So
I would expect the test to log again. Let's
try it run. And there you see it already.
debug, call marks will Java course card service,
processing car BMW. So this seems to be working.
Okay. And here, again, you see the pattern.
This is what's compared. Here, we have the
minus that we have set here, minus and then
the message, and then this n, I think this
is for new line, so that when there's the
next lowing a new line will be attached. Okay.
And this is the console appender. So this
is the console that we can see here, in our
ID, if you would run this from the console
with like, for example, a terminal here, you
would only see it within the terminal. Okay.
So let's maybe go back to the documentation,
and check this a bit more. Okay, so here,
you see, and you should really use read it.
Now, I'm just really fast going through it,
you can read it typical usage pattern for
this is pretty much what we did. And here
with the curly braces, we locked on debug.
Well, we could also change maybe, after reading
the documentation, let's also log on Arrow
and info that you see this also works. And
here, it's also explained what I showed you
binding with a logging framework at deployment
time. So it says here lockback Classic, you
need this. If you want lockback as the logging
framework, which we used. Yeah, so really
have a look here and read this. And here you
see the dependencies, this is what we did.
You can also here you see you can use it with
lock for J. But lockback, as I showed you
is like the successor for for j and there
is also documentation of lockback which should
also have a look, by the way again. So the
author is chechi Goku, and others. Yeah, so
see they they worked on these frameworks for
12 years. I mean, you wouldn't want to work
for 12 years and there are at least these
three guys. So this is a lot of work and brain
power that has gone in that logging framework,
which you can use just by configuring it in
your code. Okay. Yeah, and you see we have
also done it import org. So for j logger,
and logger factory, here they made it static
which is also fine.
And here they log on info level. Okay. And
here's the configuration file. This I have
also showed you Okay, and there are also other
appenders I think I have put them here. Let's
see, oh, there's also the explanation you
can do it with logger is debug enabled, like
I showed you, or you see better alternative
with the curly braces. Because this is I mean,
basically, it's the same thing. But this is
three lines. And this like clutters your code
easily. And this is only one line. So it's
nicer. Because logging, I mean, it's important
that you want to focus on the domain, on the
business that you work in. And logging should
just not be in the way of your business. The
business is important thing. And logging is
important. Yes. But it's like not as important
as the business. So really have a look and
go through all the documentation. It really
explains this really nicely. Okay. So now,
I promised you, and then we should finish
already. We can also log on different levels,
like you can see error. Well, as, as far as
I remember, we're still on debug level. And
error is included within debug, because debug
is the finest logging level. So this should
also look just here, I would expect to see
not debug but error. So that we know, well,
we would use this in case an error occurred.
So that we can differentiate how important
some logging event is. Now you see an error.
So we would write, oh, some error occurred?
Well, in our case, this is not an error. So
we should also not log in on error. What else
can we use? Let's see, we should also able
to log this on worn for a warning. So you
would use a warning for something very close
to an error. But where no one has to manually
interfere, then you could use one logging
level. And info you would use for example,
when your server starts when your program
starts up, just so that the user of the program
knows everything is fine. And like here, this
is an info level. So we are informed lockback
is just starting up. Okay. And here you see
now we have one level processing car BMW.
So now that we're using one level, let's put
the root level to error. And now the package
that we're not using as well as the root level
are both on error. And it's printed to standard
out, which is this appender the console appender
which is this console here. Okay, and now,
I would not expect to see any logging. And
you see, just the info from doc back at the
logging is gone. Which again, we can change.
If we say here worn or let's change this back.
Here also we can say worn. So now we should
see the one locked again. Yeah, there it is.
Okay, well, as I Oh, I think I promised you
to show you the appenders and I have not.
So let's finally go back to Firefox. And see
I had it somewhere here found? employee No,
this is not yet. But it's somewhere appenders.
There, this is easy. Chapter four appenders
is really a good read. So I'm really fast
going over it. So outputstream appender, console.
appender. This one we used. File append Not
this one is of course very important to write
into a file and go through it read it. So
there you can set the encoding and all these
parameters. And there are some really cool
appenders like rolling file appender Well,
that means that new files are created when
like the file is has a certain size or like
for every day we could have a new file. This
is important for servers because otherwise
if we're always writing into the same file,
this very soon can reach
tons of gigabytes. Yeah. And therefore on
production for a server you very often use
a rolling file appender so that thing is really
important. Somewhere there should also be
ODP appender that is supposed to To log into
a database directly, really cool thing. And
this is really very easy to be configured.
Where is it, it was down somewhere. Somewhere,
somewhere somewhere, maybe I've already missed
it, there is an SMTP appender, I would assume
from the name that is used for logging, sending
an email when there is a lock event. And somewhere,
that was also the DB appender. I know it is
SMTP appender, blah, blah, blah, blah, ebf.
There it is. So this allows you to directly
write into a database, and you see all these
databases are supported. So this is really
great stuff, and so on, I mean, this page
still goes on. So there are really a lot of
appenders out of the box that you can use.
And as I said, you can always extend it and
write your own appender, which allows you
to lock to any other source. So that pretty
much rounds up logging. I would like to show
you the main method of Java. The main method,
as the name implies, is the method that is
used to start a program initially. However,
as this course, is done in test driven style,
or TDD In short, so far, we actually never
used it. Because we start programming by writing
a test. And so far, we use the test to execute
our code. Well, actually, as you might have
guessed, at some time, when you're done with
development, you would want to run the program.
And for this, you will need a class that has
a main method. So how does this main method
look? Well, it's not so different from any
other method. It is a public method, so that
it can be started from outside of the class.
It is a static method. Because we want to
run the method without having an instance
without having an object of car selector.
Because the class car selector in this case
here is only the like executer the, like the
frame that we use to start our program. And
therefore, I mean, we also only need, we don't
need further instances of this class. And
this is why the method is static has to be
static by definition. The method is void because
it doesn't return anything. And the name must
be made. So that it can be found by Java.
By the way, I might notice shortly, I always
say noticed by Java. Well, actually, what
I mean is noticed by the compiler, because
the compiler will compile the program to bring
it into an executable form. Well, compiler
is a big topic, there are huge books, if not
even libraries about compilers that you can
so you could even study compilers. So I tried
to prevent to keep you away from that topic.
But maybe, if I keep talking about Java, executing
something, I maybe should now say compiler,
and at a later time, I might do a dedicated
session on my bit of compiler details. So
that you will know more about compilers. So
anyway.
Okay, so back to the public static void Main
method. Now we add the brackets, but actually,
they have to contain something, because when
we start our main method, we want to be able
to give it arguments that the program might
need to run and this is obligatory. So these
are arguments that come as input as strings,
but as there can be a number of strings. This
is an area here. So square brackets, and all
the name of the string array. You can use
any name, people usually would set here arcs.
This is what you would see in documentation
I usually prefer arguments, because this is
more readable. Okay. And then of course, as
always, for our method, you would have the
curly braces, the opening and the closing
curly brace. Um, yeah. And that's already
it for the main method. Now, let's leave it
empty for a moment. And now when you compile
this class here, on the console using a terminal,
you can execute this Java class. And it will
then call this main method automatically.
So this is the place where you like set up
your whole program. In the last episode, I
created a car service. So we can use this
in here, car service car service. But I mean,
technically, it also works to run just the
empty main method, it will just not do anything.
So let me directly say new car service, no
title car service.
Okay.
And then you can call the method, car service
dot process. Yeah, remember, and this requires
an input. By the way, just to show you what
is possible in Java. You can also do all this
on the fly, you can say new car service thought
process, the only difference is that, you
will then just call the method, and you will
not have any variable to access the core service.
If you don't need it, that might be fine.
Well, the only thing missing now is a string.
And I mean, we could use any string here,
like PVC. But I mean, to make it a bit more
interesting, we could no, take the string
array. And as as this as this is an array.
Of course, we need a for each loop, which
are also introduced already. So let's say
string argument for one, colon arguments.
So this is iterating through our array, that
will be given to us. When the program runs
at runtime, opening curly brace again, closing
curly brace.
Okay.
That was formatting it. Okay, and now I can
take that argument. And so dynamically call
the process method, dynamically creating an
object. While this is always creating a new
object. So I mean, I wanted to show you that
this is possible. But of course, it would
probably be smarter to just create one object
and then put a reference on this object. So
this would be from the performance perspective,
probably faster. But it's really hard to talk
about performance. Because the compiler these
days is really smart. It might, it often recognizes
stuff. And when before a while it compiles
it can optimize your code. So talking about
performance is a topic by itself. And you
would usually test for performance just by
saying this will be fast or slow. You can
hardly do but again, performance. Yeah, I
could also do a course only on performance
really a big topic. Um, yeah. So now I created
an instance of car service. And in the main
method, I have this for each loop. And then
for each argument that is given to our main
method when the program is run, we call the
car service. Now let's execute this. Because
now we can run this without actually a test.
Well, I mean, in this episode, I want to show
you the main method. But I mean, what I said
still holds true, you should always start
programming with writing a test. But anyway,
see, now I have a run car, see, like the domain.
And I can execute the main method directly.
Here. This shows me the console directly in
my ID. Well, it seems like there's nothing
printed. This could either be because in the
class, remember, we had the logging, the logging
could be deactivated, but so far, I remember
it's still active. It should log on worn at
the moment. Well, the reason this doesn't
work. Anything is a different reason. And
the reason is, well, we didn't give our program
any arguments. So I mean, this is running,
this is not throwing any exceptions. By the
way, we will talk about exceptions very soon.
But it's empty. So the for loop will actually
not be executed at all.
When the program is run, so we will directly
jump to line nine or 10, just after it so
the program will directly exit. But we can
change this easily using our ID, I can click
on Run, and I say Edit configurations. And
here, I can configure how my main class see
this also contains always the full package
name. So how this is run, I can give it some
program arguments. So on the console, that
would be car selector, and then whitespace,
and then the program arguments. So let me
put here a few car names. BMW, or shi. C,
Mercedes. Yeah. And then Okay. And then let
me run the main method again. And now you
see, we have three warning loggings processing
car BMW processing card pushy, and processing
commerce. seeders. Yeah. So that's the main
method.
Um,
one more thing just really slightly mentioned.
What is also possible and not many people
know is you can do this. Now what does that
mean? And see, all the code is still working.
This thing with the three dots here is called
a foul arcs. Like a variable argument parameter,
which means when this is defined like this,
the code, the method that would call our main
method, while in this case, it's directly
started by the virtual machine itself. This
would have the ability to directly put in
strings that will be converted automatically
by the compiler to an array. So this is very
close to an array, but it's like just more
convenient for whoever calls that method.
Just so that you have seen this would also
be possible. The question is, does it make
sense because, well, Normally, you would not
call the main method directly.
So if you don't call the main method directly,
it doesn't make a difference. But of course,
you can write a test and you can call the
method directly. And in this case, it would
make a difference because you could directly
call the method which just one string? Yeah,
but let me talk about Fox arguments at a later
time. Okay, so let's re add. Let's make this
an array again.
Okay.
So now, string array arguments. Okay. So that
much about the main method, now, maybe a bit
of background knowledge for you. So I don't
know if my Java course is actually the first
Java course you ever listened to? I guess
in most cases, you would probably already
have heard another course or read the book
about Java. And in this case, you might not
directly understand why didn't talk about
the main methods so far. I mean, this is Episode
14 already. So let me give you the reason
for this. Because I really decided to do so
specifically. Because this is really a main
a main decision for me. Okay, so the reason
is, first of all, I think, in the very first
lesson, when you have never heard about Java,
and its keywords, it's hard to directly be
confronted with public static, void. This
is just the name of the method would be okay,
but public static void, and then even an array.
All all this stuff for a very first lesson
in Java is a bit much I think. Now in our
episode 14, you should by now know what public
means What static means what what means. And
we have also talked about arrays. So I hope
that by now, you can easily follow my explanations,
and you understand what all this means. Okay?
And then second, also, this is a static method.
And I told you, I think various times, Java
is an object oriented language, where you
usually focus on creating objects, but static,
this method is not object oriented. There's
just one version of this method. I mean, of
course, it might make sense. But, yeah, as
you should try to avoid static, wherever possible,
I think showing you a static method in the
very first Java lesson might lead you to the
wrong conclusions. Yeah. And then also, next
reason is, um, even though, I mean, the main
method is, on the one hand, very important,
because you use it to actually execute your
program to actually get your program running.
For any program at hand, you would have only
one main method. And usually programs would
consists of hundreds, if not 1000s, of classes.
And just one main method. And last but not
least, I mean, this counts for Java, se. But
if you like program a server application,
what you usually do is you don't re implement
all the server code. But you would like use,
for example, an open source server implemented
in Java, for example, Tomcat, and such a server,
I mean, has already been implemented for you.
And so you use that as like an infrastructure,
even though it's software. And so the Java
code you write will run within that Java software
infrastructure. And therefore, when you program
code for server, you usually don't write even
a main method at all. So, for example, in
my case, I mean, I have programmed in Java
for pretty much 14 years now. But I have maybe,
I don't know, 10 times 20 times, well, definitely
less than 100 times I have programmed a main
method, while I have programmed really 1000s
of classes, I'm sure. So the main method is
not so important. And, yeah, so we started
with writing a test anyway. So you are also
able to run your code, at least for testing
without the main method. Of course, I mean,
the tests. For example, let's look at this
one. This one is based on the framework j
unit. And j unit by itself is a Java program.
So j unit does have a main method. Of course
it does. But you don't see it. All you see
is the test methods that we write. And his
test method, they like plug into the whole
j unit mechanism, bet so we don't have to
write the main method. I mean, this is why
just using a framework, like j unit is so
handy, because it saves us from writing our
own main method. Yeah, and I promise you,
you can actually even execute even the main
method as if it was a regular method. Now
here you see I have prepared that he is an
array of string arguments, BMW and Porsche.
So this static method is called with the given
arguments as execute the test. And yeah, you
see, this works just as well processing car
BMW processing car pushy.
And,
as one last thing, maybe you'll see I could
change the signature of the method. Like I
could say the method returns some end. In
this case, just as an example 42 I could even
not make it static anymore. I can change it
in any way. This is okay as it's a Java method,
it just will not be recognized as a regular
main method. So this will will not allow us
to execute it as a Java program, but our test
can still execute it as it was before. I mean,
now this is returning something. So we don't
use the return value, but we could in return
use equals to Yeah. So you see, it's really,
we're calling the main method returning something.
And we can still call it from the test. But
if we want this to be really a main method
that will allow us to start a program, then
the signature must look like this. Okay, so
I think that's pretty much all I can tell
you about the main method, I'm really happy
that we were finally able to have a look at
the main methods. So now, with the 14 episodes
that I've done so far, I think this course
now really has gone quite far, by now you
should really know quite a lot about Java,
and should be able to write your own programs
by now, I will, of course, add a few more
things. But By now, you should really be able
to write your own small programs. I would
like to talk about Exception Handling in Java.
So first of all, let's have a look at some
theory, and some background information about
exception handling. And then later on, we
will as always, directly jump into my ID.
And I'll show you how to do Exception Handling
in practice. Okay, so as you see, this is
the Wikipedia article about exception handling.
So first of all, let's have a short look at
the definition. So here this article says
exception handling is the process of responding
to the occurrence during computation of exceptions,
and animals or exceptional conditions requiring
special processing. Okay, let's stop here.
Let's digest that. So, um, I think what is
very important is two things. First of all,
it is about exceptional conditions. Because
in my opinion, this is something that many
programmers get wrong. I mean, an exception
is called an exception, because it should
handle exceptional conditions. So the question
really is what is an exceptional condition.
While in my opinion, an exceptional condition
is something that really, as the name implies,
only happens exceptionally which means only
really rarely, only in very specific situations.
And those situations are an animal's soul.
So for example, programming errors, you when
your program, you introduce the buck, you
forgot to like you have an array, and you
have one field that is empty. And I talked
about that means it has a field that is set
to now. And then when you try to access this
field, that, for example, can throw a so called
null pointer exception. Well, that would be
really an exceptional case, which you wouldn't
have guessed it would happen. And yeah, that
would be one reason for an exception. So exception
handling is really the, as it says here process
of responding to the occurrence of exceptions.
So something exceptional happens. And then
we need
a way to react on that to handle that. Some
special processing, which is not the normal
program flow. But the cool thing about Yeah,
this also sent here, often changing the normal
flow of program execution. because ideally,
we want like a central place that handles
the exceptions. And so we want to leave the
normal program flow and we want to just specifically
take care of this exceptional case. Okay.
And here continues, it is provided by specialized
programming languages, which gives us a hint,
it is not provided by all programming languages.
Well, let's have a look at the history which
will tell us. Yeah, software Exception Handling
developed in Lisp in the 1960s and 1970s.
Well, I think the first programming language
was invented by Conrad Sousa in, like 1943,
or something. So you see, it took a while
until they finally came up with the idea of
exception handling, that something like this
is really necessary. And, well, maybe a bit
more about the history and Java, because again,
with Java, there was some something new introduced,
and that is checked exceptions. Before all
exceptions were unchecked, which means any
line of code can throw any kind of exception.
And there is no mechanism that forces you
to handle it, if you don't handle it. That,
for example, causes the program to stop. And
well, therefore, as soon as exceptions were
like introduced, many times nasty things happened.
And so when they invented Java in like 1995,
or something, they thought, well, maybe we
should do this a bit better. And well, first
of all, let's have a look. Check the exceptions
here. The designers of Java device checked
exceptions, which are a special set of exceptions
here.
Okay, and to make it short, so what's the
difference about checked exceptions, he is
also already an example and i o exception,
which happens when there is a problem with
an IO operation input output operation. The
difference with checked exceptions in Java
is they must be declared explicitly in the
method signature, or be handled. If you don't
do that, you will directly get a compile time
error, which means you're not able to even
compile your program. I looked at actually
up I think it's here it's quite interesting.
Like how it came with the checked exceptions.
The Java programming language introduces the
concept of checked exceptions, checked exceptions
must be handled in a method, or the method
must declare the exception in our throws clause.
Now it continues, I think here it's even more
interesting. According to Anvil wrath, who
was there at the beginning, the credit for
the Java exception scheme should mostly go
to Jim Waldo. And then they go on. And here
after some consideration, Java was retooled
to have checked exceptions, only those exceptions
for which there was no recovery, or reflect
application errors would be unchecked, and
the world was safe again. Well, so they thought.
Now, in the meantime, it's 2015, which just
like 20 years later, and it turns out, that
was not so smart. Because the problem is,
and this is also why stated at the beginning,
maybe we should go back to the very top. Exception
handling is the process of blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, exceptional conditions.
And this is the important part. Because they
had the idea to have still unchecked exceptions
for something like programmer arrows for something
that is, as the name implies, exceptional,
and to have the checked exceptions for everything
else. But now I ask, why have checked exceptions
for these cases that can be handled? Why not?
If you if you can handle a specific situation,
why not that instead validating that situation?
And not at all throwing an exception? And
also, and now maybe we should already jump
into the ad because I guess it goes too far.
on too much theory. Let's directly jump into
the code. So yeah, so here you see An email
that I've written car stayed with a different
states driving, waiting and parking. I've
written this public static from method that
converts a string to a car state using a switch
statement. I told you, in a previous episode,
that since Java seven, it's possible to use
a switch inside air to use a string inside
a switch. And I want you not to do it. This
still applies. But in this case, I assume
that we are getting input from the console.
And input from the user coming from the console
cannot be an enum must be a string. So this
is all I mean, for every rule, there is an
exception. So this is an exception to the
rule, which is here, we do have a switch,
switching on a string. But now here, we have
the default case. And I also told you, I wouldn't,
I will only throw exceptions and the default
case, so that it cannot happen, that someone
adds a new state. And this new state would
then be handled by the default case without
anyone noticing, to have the fail early principle.
And so I told you to throw an exception, but
I didn't show you yet. While we can do this
now, and this is quite easy. You can just
say throw new exception, because an exception
in Java is just an A class. Like almost any
other class, while it has some specific
methods and stuff, but at least it's an it's
a class and we create, we can create objects
from it. Now, you know, you already see a
checked exception and action. And you see
how the compiler already wants me unhandled
exception. java. lang exception. So this is
also the package java. lang exception. And,
yeah, this is the number one checked exception.
Don't ask me why it's called exception. If
it's actually a checked exception, something
like a checked exception. I mean, the name
was not used within Java Lang. So you just
have to know that this exception is a checked
exception. And on top, the default, unchecked
exception is an is a runtime exception. This
sorry, also not my fault. This also you have
to know I mean, runtime makes sense, because
something that goes wrong at runtime. And
so you would normally use a runtime exception
for things where you don't know how to handle
them directly. And the idea was, as I said
before, to have checked exceptions, for cases
where you know how to deal with them. But
as I said, if you know how to deal with them,
why not dealing with them without throwing
an exception beforehand, using validation?
But anyway, let's continue. So how can we
fix that compile time error? One reason is,
at exception to method signature, let's use
our ID to help us and here it adds throws
exception. Now you see the compile time error
is gone. Nothing is read anymore, it seems
like we fixed the problem. So we told the
Java compiler, we know there is a checked
exception. We just don't care. The color should
take care of it. And now I have this car service
class here. And I made it to use the static
from method that I implemented. And you see
now this class has the problem. Okay, again,
let's do the same thing. Add exception to
method signature. Okay. And I guess you know,
where this leads to. Now we are the main method.
And again, we have the same problem. Well,
we can notate This is all the wrong stuff.
Seems like we're on the wrong line. But yeah,
I can no here appears add exception to method
signature. Okay. Well, sorry, I'm just lazy.
I could of course have written that myself.
But whenever you write something, you have
the chance of introducing a typo like this.
So whenever possible, I prefer to have my
ID he helped me and to have code written automatically
by the ID that can save From introducing bugs
with typos for example. Okay, so now this
will be, like fixed. But now the question
is, what did it help us, we have here throws
exception, we have here throws exception,
and we have here throws exception. So three
times we had to add this throws exception.
And only because Java tells us this is a checked
exception. But besides, we didn't handle it,
which means what will happen when I execute
the code, and the default case is chosen,
the exception will be thrown, it will be Bob,
it will bubble up to the top to the main method.
And as the main method doesn't handle it,
the program will stop. And we will see the
exception stack trace. Yeah, same thing we
could do, for example, with a runtime exception,
throw new runtime exception. Also in in both
cases, you can and you should add some meaningful
message that tells us why the exception happened.
So let's say on state, and concatenate that
with a given state. Oh, okay. So now, I can
still keep it. But I don't have to. It's not
obligatory anymore, because this is not a
checked exception anymore.
Same here, I can remove all these. And this.
So now I have exactly the same code. The only
differences I mean, I'm not handling the exception,
that my method signature doesn't get any longer.
Because he mentioned again, I'm always bringing
this example, you have a huge program of hundreds
of classes. And as soon as one method has
that throws exception, this is really contagious,
which means another method, sooner or later,
we'll use the method that says throws exception,
will then also have to say throws exception,
this method again will be used. And sooner
or later, you will have that throws exception
in each and every method. And then it doesn't
help us at all. It just makes the code more
wordy, let's say. And yeah, it's not really
meaningful. So anyway, let's first of all
provoke that exception that we see how such
as exception stacktrace looks like for this
to happen. I have to call the main method.
And I have to give it some some argument that
we don't know yet. Okay, let's go here run.
I think I have prepared something already.
Edit configuration. And yeah, flying parking,
driving, driving ABCD E, F, G, because also,
I wanted to show you, I mean, I've introduced
the main method only in the prior episode.
So here we have some valid states, as well
as some invalid states. Also in lowercase
letters, it will should be invalid. And as
we're iterating through the arguments and
a for each loop, we should see. Well, let's
just let's just do it. actually still have
to run it. And let's have a look what happens.
Okay, so you see, the exception happened.
I'm on state flying. So I would assume the
reason is that this happened for the very
first time the first argument was already
flying. So this is our program stopped. This
is the reason because it's not handled. Now,
we could also handle it to show you what's
the difference. Now the question is where
to handle such an exception? Well, always
as early as possible, like at the class that
can do something about the exception. In our
case, um, I just defined that. In the case
that I get a wrong argument from from when
the program is called as an argument. I want
this to be printed to the console, so that
the user knows which means I mean, I wanted
to be printed here, which means the first
place where I can handle this exception is
only here on the very top. And so there is
this new construct, I say, Troy, which is
like telling the compiler, I know something
evil can happen. And I just want to try it.
But now I can say catch. And I can catch this
runtime exception. Usually, I mean, I don't
like really short variable names, because
they're not readable. But in the case of an
exception, because an exception log is always
very, very short. The default is to call the
exception for with E, for exception. And I
think here, this exception is okay. Because
we don't want too much with the exception,
and the block will be so small that everyone
knows the E is for the exception. Okay, so
curly braces. And now we can do various things.
First of all, we could say e dot print stack
trace.
Well, this is actually exactly what we have
here. This is the stack trace, the stack,
you can think of as a list of all the methods
that were called in reverse order. So here
you see main process from can also jump there.
I mean, this is not, this doesn't hold true
anymore, because I've no edits code. But at
the time, we executed this code, and the exception
was thrown. This told us exactly in each class,
where the exception happened while he is still
true. And he also, but in my car selector,
I have adjusted the code, by the way about
this. The fact that I've adjusted the code,
also, when you sometimes have a stack trace,
and you need to analyze where it came from,
this is really often happening, that the code
that is running on production is older than
the code that you develop on, because of course
development continues. And then you can only
find out the exact place where the exception
happened, if you keep the exact same code
that you have running on production. Yeah,
but this only really, I don't want to go into
more details. Um, this would be a topic on
its own, again, about revision control. And
this is really a huge topic. But yeah, just
that, you know, the stack trace is really
helpful if and only if you have exactly the
same code that was implemented at the time
this code was running. I mean, that they're
both in sync. Okay, so print sectors here
wouldn't make sense, because in this case,
it's just the default anyway. But this can
be used. And it's often used to lock for example,
in I don't know, was it Episode 13? I think
I talked about logging. And so when you want
to log an exception, you can do it like this.
This is usually how you do it. Well, I haven't
got the log class here. And I don't want to
do log error or log one you will say and this
depends error only when there is something
that has to be done. For example, a database
that has to be restarted. In other cases,
probably one is also okay. Okay, message is
the string that I added into the constructor
of the exception
here.
And I have removed the stack trace, because
this is actually done inside of the log object,
which I want to add. Now. If you want to know
more about logging, have a look at my episode
13 where I explain logging in detail. Okay,
so logging is one thing we can do. But in
this case, I say I don't want to log it, I
want to directly printed on the console. I
think also in the episode about logging, I
want you not to do it always to prefer logging.
But in this case, let's assume we have just
a very small program only be used to run something
from the console. And in this case, it can
be okay to just say system error dot Clinton.
Which I also wanted to show you once print
ln For new line, and here, then I can say
dot get message. Or I can also say e dot print
stack trace, which doesn't make sense, because
we already have that. So to alter the behavior,
let's do this. Okay, let's run it again. Now,
you see something else. You see the program
hasn't stopped. But instead we see unknown
state flying Unknown, Unknown state driving
an unknown state abcdefg. Yeah, so all the
invalid states were printed out. Without we
don't even see the exception anymore. And
it's red, because I use system error Clinton,
I could also use out print on because this
is a special channel, only for errors. And
this is printing in general. See, now it's
white. But really, I still warn you don't
overuse system out or system error print on.
Because Yeah, you can't configure it like
you can configure logging. So in 99% of the
cases, using a logger is better. Anyway. So
let's have a look at the code now and think
is this really nice. Now, we have a for loop,
we have a try, we have a catch. Um, you see
a lot of different hierarchies and a lot of
different levels that we have to understand.
And this is something I really don't like,
this makes the code quite complicated. Okay,
so this is something you should try to prevent.
And, anyway, I can also, alternatively show
you, we could do exactly the same.
If this was throwing an exception. The only
difference is that if we're not handling it,
we have to add the signature
throws throws. So yeah. Maybe also, I should
now show you the alternative. If If we don't
want to add the method signature, the exception
signature, we can directly in here, say catch
and then handle it. And then I mean, handling
an exception does not necessarily always mean
you have to print it, I mean, printing, it
doesn't really solve the exception, it might
be even better to really have a method that
does something about the exception, and which
I call no handle the exception. The only problem
with that is, and I'm not implementing the
method now. And this is what I said before,
I'm the case that you're really able to do
something about the exception, which in this
case, I mean, what could we do, if the user
typed in something wrong? There's not much
we can do? Well, there is one thing, we could
for example, ask the user to type in to fix
the state he typed in. But this we couldn't
handle here. So again, if we want to, like
ask the user to do something about it, I would
instead validate
the state. So let's remove all that. Let's
for the time being I add the runtime exception,
but I will change it very soon, because now
instead, I want a validation at it. And this
can be done in the following way. I remove
all that trycatch instead, I say Valley date
argument and now I can implement that method.
Create method validate my ad he helps me again.
I'm
now well actually I want to say is valid with
a Boolean returned. Okay. Now, you see this
is also interesting, by the way about the
main method because this method is static.
Also, this Method automatically esthetic.
So because when this method is static, a static
method cannot call a method that is not static,
because an instance method can only be called
when there is an instance. But for the main
method, we won't create any instance, of course
selector. So for this reason this is static,
and it's private, because we don't need to
call it from outside, only the main method
will call it. Now how can we validate it?
Well, for example, we could use a method directly
provided to us from the enum class, and that
is value of this is not implemented by us.
But it's implemented, like automatically,
when they implemented when they invented the
enum and Java, this is one method that you
get for free. So this will directly try to
convert your string to an enum. So here I
can say car stayed. Cars date. So this actually
does exactly the same thing. Like our switch
did. So actually, we won't need it anymore.
Very soon. The difference to the method that
I implemented is or bill, I did it actually
also like this, when the conversion doesn't
work, this will throw a runtime exception,
I think, an in because they have different
types of runtime exceptions. And I think it
will be an illegal argument exception to tell
us the argument that you are giving that you
are giving to me, sorry, is invalid. But still,
it's a runtime exception. So and because this
will throw an exception, we have to add the
try catch block here, because we want to handle
this. Try catch. And then I say runtime exception
he or I hope I'm right. I can directly say
in valid on
invalid
human exemption, there it is. I think that
should be the one if not, we will see it because
the exception will not be caught. Okay, and
then here, we can just return false without
logging anything.
Now,
let's see, this is the wrong one, because
we can't catch an exception that is never
thrown. So invalid. Let's see what the lead
catch. Now this is not what I want. Maybe
it's an invalid state exception. Yeah, this
works. So see, this is also how you see this
value off may throw an invalid state exception
if the argument given is unknown, in case
of, for example, flying driving ABC. Okay.
And
to be honest,
um,
I think this is also not optimal, that we
only have this value off method, I think it
would be much, much nicer if the IEM base
class will directly provide is valid method
just returning true and false. But again,
seems like the inventors of Java doesn't didn't
listen to my opinion, crap, just making a
stupid joke.
So for this reason, we do have the exception,
but we are able to convert it. So because
we converting it directly. The exception doesn't
be doesn't pollute our whole system, let's
say like this. And we can now say here, return
true. Which we could also put at the end of
the method. This is exactly the same. Yeah.
So wherever you have it. So and this is also
the jump. I mean, imagine you could have lots
of other code like system out print owns and
just print something. So you could have many,
many more lines. That would do lots of stuff.
Let's just copy and paste that to show you
many more lines. We could even reassign car
state to something else. Let's just say now.
So what happens if This line of code doesn't
work out, because the argument is unknown,
for example, flying. When the code is executed,
the execution will jump from here, directly
into the catch. So this is leaving the normal
program flow, the normal program flow would
go from line 2122 2324 25, and so on. But
here we're jumping from line 21. To line 28.
Yeah, and this is helpful, because, for example,
imagine we have done this several times, for
examples here. And there, even maybe in sub
methods, then we have just one catch, that
would handle all these different places where
an invalid state exception could happen. That's
the idea of exception handling. Okay, just
to give you some more details, actually, I
don't even need that. So I would remove it.
We're only like, abusing that volume of method
to have the information. Is that valid or
not? Okay, and now I can react on that. I
can say if not valid, or I can say only, like,
only process it if it's valid. Yeah, maybe
let's do this. Because you saw already hold
the invalid states are printed. Now let's
do something else. Let's only process valid
arguments. The question, of course, is, does
that make sense? Now we wouldn't even realize
we have a problem in our code. So maybe we
should also say else. Print that we have problem.
system error dot print. ln M. invalid. argument
given? Or let's say ignoring, ignoring invalid
argument. So this, by the way, whenever you
log, I think I'm not repeating myself, because
I already talked about logging, but I can't
say it often enough. Always add as many arguments
as possible, so that whoever is responsible
for a problem knows why this happens. Otherwise,
yeah, it's really hard to understand why something
doesn't work out. Oh, no, we still have an
illegal argument exception. How is that? I
don't know. And this is interesting, because
we can now check. Like, this is what I told
you. It's in car state. There's, ah, we still
have the from it seems like we call it somewhere.
But no, I'm wrong. Because the session line
five, so this is not yet. Car state. Illegal
Aha, this is why See, I was wrong. This is
the invalid state exception. And what is actually
thrown by Java is the illegal argument exception.
So see, this is actually what happens most
that we see it. No, no constant flying. So
this is what Java gives us. It throws an exception.
And this now we will catch. Okay, let's retry.
See, this is how everyone introduces sparks.
And this is why we need tests. Today, I'm
not doing a test because I just want to show
you exceptions. But
yeah. We do need tests. Tests are very important.
Okay, now it works. See, ignoring invalid
argument flying ignoring new argument driving,
ignoring invalid argument abcdefg. And the
valid argument was processed. It just didn't
lock just didn't do anything. Which of course
we can change. Here we could say system out
print. ln, again, this thing here is evil.
Only use it in very rare situations. Yeah.
I can say bellet. Stayed. Car stayed. executed
again. Yeah, so you see three invalid states
and two valid states. Okay. So of course,
I mean, this was just an issue. Sample Normally,
you would have some method doing something
about the state
further,
do something with the car state. I mean, I'm
just making this up, because all I want to
explain you is exception handling, but I hope
you get the idea. So anyway, there's one more
thing. And then actually, I would like to,
like, shortly recap the important points of
exception handling. And the missing thing
now is, oh, by the way, let's remove the from,
because I showed you, we don't actually even
need this anymore. Okay. Because what you
can also do is finally, finally, this is very
important, not in our case, now, I'm just
making some something up. Finally, as the
name implies, this is done. Finally, at the
end, no matter even exception happened or
not, this block will always be called. And
this is important. When you have resources,
when you have input output operations, or
in short I O, which you have, if you communicate
with a database, if you read something from
a file from your hard disk, Yeah, something
like this. Because when you like read something,
especially from external systems, who can
tell you that the external system is actually
available, or like the hard disk could fail.
And so with i o operations, there's always
nasty stuff that can happen. But there's one
important thing, which is, for AI operations,
you need resources. And so you have to close
them. In any case, otherwise, you really could
have a problem with more and more resources
lost. So yeah, this is a big topic, I can't
explain it in like a second. But all I want
to tell you for now, this finally is very
important when you deal with IO operations
that might fail. And in this case, you can
close these resources and close resource for
now I'm just giving you my resource, this
stupid method. You can implement that yourself.
But also they are very cool. Helping utility
classes found on the internet, open source.
Like for example, I Oh, utils. Oh, it already
find something. But this is not the one I
mean, the one I know of is for example, I
think from Apache, and they will have something
like close thing silently or so close resource.
And then this will do all the nasty stuff
for you. Okay, I'm stopping here, what is
important is, and this I want to show you
just by printing something system out, print,
ln.
And I will throw the exception again. Which
means what you can also do is you don't even
have to catch it. This also works try and
darkly finally. Okay, formatted the code.
So, now with the invalid argument, our program
will be stopped, execution will be stopped.
But in any case, let's say I am still running.
And I can also show you this line will not
be printed after exception. Well, it might
be that this runs once if the first argument
is a valid one. Because with the string airy,
we never know for sure the order is not guaranteed.
But so that you see, I would whatever happens
for this vote for every time we call is valid.
This will always be printed. So let's see
what happens. Okay, oh, something's still
wrong. Not Found. Yeah, because we have removed
the from Yeah, sure. Um,
so let's for now remove that. We at the moment,
don't need it. And see, this is again, the
reason why we need tests.
I'm really doing some nasty hacking at the
moment. Okay, and you see, I'm still running
And then the exception comes. So this is what
happens when the exception happens. We didn't
catch it. So we see the stack trace instead.
But I'm still running is printed before that.
And this is the place where we can do some
cleanup operations, like closing resources.
But you could do anything in here, basically.
Same thing, if we catch it, catch is a runtime
exception, runtime exception, because it's
also a runtime exception. We should talk about
inheritance very soon. So that I can go in
more details why that is. So now what is wrong?
Yeah, we need the closing curly brace, and
one less of this. So now we can say, oh, maybe
I just have I will also show you print stack
trace. So this should actually do the same.
And now I will say, system out. print on.
Hello, again.
So you get an idea. In finally block.
Oh, okay.
Oh, no, something weird happened. And this
is for all the invalid states flying driving.
The stack trace was printed. And it's red.
Because, yeah, it's the print stack trace.
So it's printed on system error. Okay. And
you see, this is the illegal argument exception,
the first one, the second one, and so on.
And you see at the end, hello again. Which
comes after the whole stack trace. Yeah. And
you'll also see this line will not be printed
off to exception. Because it seems like I
mean, we had different arguments in here.
So for the valid ones, this line was printed.
And you see also, I mean, now I'm really having
a hard time knowing why this happened. So
again, I violated my own rule. I didn't add
the argument. So here I can say, our arguement.
I say valid argument. Yeah, because if it's
after the value of if this is printed, it
means the exception did not happen. Now, let's
call this again. And let me also remove the
stack trace for now to make it a bit more
readable for us. And let's run the main method
again. Okay, see now it's more readable. So
what do we have here? Hello again. So the
runtime exception happened. And, again, I
did not add the argument. In this case, I
can also say get message, which gets us the
message of the exception. I'm not sure if
our illegal argument exception has a message.
But we'll try this.
Yeah, see, this is the message Hello again.
And the message is no II non constant car
marktspiegel car stayed flying. So now you
see he can understand the problem so much
better. And after this we under finally block
then comes the valid argument parking. In
this case, we're also ending in the finally
block. Then comes a second valid argument.
Also in the finally block. Here again comes
in invalid state
thriving,
but we're also in the finally block. And the
last invalid state also in the final block.
So the finally block is always executed all
K. I think this pretty much rounds up everything
I wanted to tell you about Exception Handling
today. Now because this was quite a lot. Let's
go Shortly through the most important gotchas,
okay, so, in Java, there are runtime exceptions,
which are unchecked exceptions, unchecked
means they are not enforced by the compiler
to be handled, you can just throw them, and
also Java will throw them for you. For example,
a very famous or infamous exception is the
null pointer exception, you should never throw
that yourself, Java will throw that for you,
if you try to access something that is at
the moment now, just now for the exception
is probably the most famous exception, because
when it happens, you will not be very happy.
Okay? So unchecked exceptions, or runtime
exceptions. And they can happen at any line,
because any line can also be null. And they
don't have to be handled in code. If they're
not, then in the worst case, the program will
stop, like we saw before, because the exception
will bubble up all to the top. And if it's
not handled in here, the program will stop.
And it will by default, print the stack trace.
Then Java was the first and actually also
the last programming language that introduced
checked exceptions. Checked exceptions are
exceptions, that are enforced by the compiler,
that you do something about them, or you add
a throws with the exception name. In your
method signature. There are various checked
exceptions. One of the most famous ones is
probably the i o exception. That will be C,
it's in Java i o package. This one will be
thrown if you have any problems with i o operations,
which is again a topic on its own. Okay, um,
and I said Java was also the last programming
language that introduced checked exceptions.
So this really shows us indicates us that
checked exceptions were not so smart. Because
you see, all they help us in the end, is they
add noise to the method signature. And the
case that to use them for cases that you can
handle them. Well, I say, if you can handle
them, why not taking care of the problem beforehand,
for example, by using validation, validating
the case, the given argument, and then handling
that without actually even throwing an exception.
And then maybe last but not least, for every
rule, there's always an exception, we saw
that. I've removed it, unfortunately, yeah,
let me go back. We saw that with the switch
on the string were set in a prior episode.
Don't do that, while I did it here. And, um,
we also saw saw that
here,
where I use the value of method of enum, which
throws an exception, and I said, Well, we're
trying to validate it. So if we are validating
as we don't need the exception, it just that
we can't do anything about it how the method
was written by the inventors of Java, so we
just have to live with that sometimes an exception
is thrown where we will just validate it.
But what we can do is we can catch the exception
and then return true or false, for example,
so we can convert the exception into a valid
return value. Also, there is a hack. If you
have a library, like an old library that will
still throw a checked exception, like an IO
exception. What you can always do is you can
wrap we say wrap a checked exception into
our runtime exception. And this is like this.
Let's create more ioexception Let's create
an ioexception shortly. So see, you can also
just create them like any other object. And
now on that exception while it cannot be called
IE because we already have that I can now
say throw new runtime exception and okay.
Give it the IO exception. And this is why
we wrap it. Because we put this exception
into the constructor of runtime exception,
which means this is the wrapper, it wraps
around the other exception. And now our compiler
will be fine. Because we're not throwing an
IO exception anymore. We're throwing a runtime
exception. Well, this is a nasty hack. But
I think it's still better than having checked
exceptions all over your code. And yeah, I'm
going to talk about interfaces in Java. Well,
interfaces are probably the most powerful
feature of object oriented languages. Well,
before I continue, first of all, some organizational
stuff. So this is divided into three parts.
Part One, I will first of all, talk about
the definition, what does actually the word
interface mean? And tell you a bit about the
history. Like how were interfaces introduced
into Java. I'll make this part as short as
I can not to put you to sleep. And then second,
we'll jump into my ID, he will do a short
coding session, and I'll show you how to practically
use interfaces in Java. And then last but
not least, I'll do a short discussion about
the pros and cons of interfaces from a clean
coder perspective. Okay, so let's start to
jump into the topic interface. So what does
interface actually mean? So I've opened up
the dictionary page. And the definition is
an interface is the point of interconnection
between entities. And interfaces do not only
exist in programming, but also in all other
kinds of areas, for example, in chemistry
and physics, and there is defined as a thin
layer or boundary between different substances.
And I think this perfectly also applies to
interfaces in object oriented languages and
Java. Because it's really a very thin layer,
you will see, there is not much code needed
to define an interface. And it also forms
a boundary. When I say boundary, I think of
something like the Chinese wall, which was
a big protection from the hordes that were
invading from the north.
And this is also what an interface is, it
can protect a class from other classes, but
more of this later, okay. And then maybe we
should also look at the object oriented point
of view. So in object oriented programming,
it's a piece of code, defining a set of operations
that other code must implement.
So yes,
all this holds true for interfaces in Java.
But now, enough of the definition. Let's have
a look at the history. For this, I actually
had to do some research on the internet. Finally,
I found this page here from Oracle, where
Oracle says the concept of an interface in
the Java language was borrowed from the Objective
C concept of a protocol. Well, pretty much
everyone says are things that Java was actually
the first language introducing interfaces.
Well, actually, Oracle itself says that this
is not true. It was birthed from Objective
C. I find this quite interesting. Objective
C. I thought we should also have a look on
Objective C, then. So I found this page here
saying, Brad Cox and Tom love created the
Objective C programming language in the early
1980s. So actually much older than Java. Java,
was released as far as I know, in 1995. So
15 years later, in an effort to get people
to write cleaner, more modular and clearly
Separated code. Yeah, that sounds actually
quite good. Now, what is interesting is here,
this paragraph also says, into interfaces
were introduced to Java to enhance Java's
single inheritance model. So whatever single
inheritance model means
they didn't say
they had introduced the interfaces to get
more cleaner, more modular, and clearly separated
code. There is a different reason. Well, I
haven't told you what inheritance means yet.
And this for a reason. Because, um, well,
Java was released in 1995, said before, and
now we have 2015 20 years later, actually,
in the meantime, the especially the clean
code community does not believe so much in
inheritance anymore. Because, of course, inheritance
has a lot of advantages. But also many disadvantages
about this, I'll tell you, and one of the
next episodes when I'm going to talk about
inheritance in Java. But anyway, so when Java
was introduced, Java is the successor of c++
we could say. And c++ still had a model using
multiple inheritance. So multiple inheritance
is even more complicated than single inheritance.
And here they write. multiple inheritance
created too many problems for programmers,
as well as compiler writers, because it's
actually not so easy to implement multiple
inheritance in into a compiler. So it seems,
because they did not support multiple inheritance,
they added interfaces to Java s, like replacement
for multiple inheritance, to like, fix that
Java did not support multiple inheritance.
And this is quite funny. And let me say it
in different words, I would say, it seems
like the really powerful feature of interfaces
was introduced into Java by kind of accident,
because they said before, they didn't think
about cleaner, more modular, clearly separated
code, but mostly just to have a way of having
something similar to multiple inheritance.
Okay, let's stop here, and jump directly into
my ID. Cuz I felt you were already feet been
falling asleep. Um, so here, this is my car.
So it was test that I've used in earlier episodes.
Also, I've added this should demonstrate interfaces
method, as the name implies, just for demonstration
purposes, I'm still using the car service
that I've implemented, also in one of the
earlier episodes, and I've added a drive method
to it. So the idea is to have a service class.
And when I call the drive method, that this
should, like start the engines of several
cars, and make them drive. So for this, in
my car service, I have now a method drive.
It creates First of all, three different cars.
I mean, this is just an example you mentioned,
were hundreds of cars. And now I call the
drive method on each of these cars.
Okay, actually,
all these classes are in the same package.
This is why I don't have to import any class.
But imagine each class would be in a different
package. We would have to import each class
separately like BMW and Porsche GE and mercy
is and so on. So what we say here is actually
this car service at the moment is really Deeply
coupled to these car classes, this is something
that we don't want more about this later.
And also, you see, we need a lot of code to
make all the cars drive. And this is something
that we want to improve with using interfaces.
Now what, again, what is an interface? Well,
an interface is also like an abstract type
definition, what this type should be able
to do. In our case, we have an I mean, I'm
already saying it three different cars. And
all these cars can drive and you see it already,
I have three different drive methods. I mean,
the way they hold how they are driving might
be different because of course, a BMW has
a different engine than a pushy, and again,
a different engine than ms cedars. But they
have some certain specifics, like, for example,
they would all have four wheels, and they
can all drive which we can make something
like a contract off. So in this way, let us
introduce an interface and I've prepared something
here, car dot java. So far, we only have the
package declaration, we have to extend that.
So let's start. Let's start as if we would
write a class. So let's say public class car.
And then opening and closing curly brace,
and now public void drive.
Okay.
And then in here, we could do something. Well,
the problem is if we do it like this, this
is not going to work, because then all the
different types will have to drive the same
way. But this is not what we want. For example,
He in pushy, I have implemented already the
drive method. I mean, this is just a stupid
example. I still want you hardly ever to use
system out print line. But here for our example,
I just wanted to show you that each method
is implemented in a different way. Here it
says masseter striving there it says Porsche
driving, the BMW actually even has three different
methods. These ones we will actually use at
a later time. And it also has the drive method,
which says BMW driving. Okay.
So now,
maybe before,
I'm going to
continue with doing the interface, we could
also try to execute the code as it is. Let's
do this. Now, just so that you see the code
should be running by now already. So it says
BMW driving Porsche driving Mercedes driving.
So what I want to achieve is exactly the same
just using interfaces with less and more readable
code. By the way, exit code zero means everything
is fine. If there is a problem, an exception
thrown, it would be exit code one. Okay. So
back to what at the moment is still a class.
Now there is a very easy way to make this
an interface. And this is I say interface.
But now it seems there is still a problem.
It says interface methods cannot have a body,
or what is the body, the body is this part
here in blue. So the body is actually the
method implementation. method also has a method
signature. This on top here is called the
method signature, public void, and the name
of the method is drive. Okay. Sorry. So it
seems like it cannot have a body. How is that?
Well, I guess even makes sense. Because we
said we just want to have a definition, like
a contract. But we don't want to actually
implement it. The implementation will be done
by the specific implementations by BMW by
Porsche and by my seniors. And we have already
done the implementations. So let me remove
the body. Now there's still something wrong
and you see it. Here it even says it It wants
now, the semi column because the semicolon
now says, I'm finished. I'm done. This is
all I want to say. So now we have an abstract
definition of a method that other classes
may implement. And when they implement the
interface car, we can also say they play the
role of a car. Because actually a class can
implement more than one interface. A class
can implement any number of interfaces. And
remember, before I spoke about multiple inheritance,
well, multiple is, this is why it's similar,
because it also allows to have,
like,
multiple implementations in a way, but more
of this later. So a class can also implement
multiple interfaces. Okay. And when I click
here, you also see modifier public is redundant.
Why is it redundant? because by definition,
all methods that we define in an interface
must be public, they are always public. So
even if I remove it, well, if you still remember,
the episode I did on the visibility modifiers,
you might now think, Well, now that there
is no modifier defined, it must be of default,
or package level visibility, no, it is still
a public visibility, because it always a method
is always have public visibility. Another
modifier that is implicitly here is abstract,
can put it abstract just means what we have
here, that the method is not implemented,
and that it just consists of the method signature,
and that the body is left away, and that we
have to semicolon here. So also, this is redundant,
we can and we should remove it. Always define
your methods without public and without abstract,
you should just know that implicitly, they're
there. Okay. And then there's one more thing
you can do in an interface. Um, but I warn
you not to do it. This is actually an anti
pattern. But still just to be complete. I
let me show you. And this is you can add public
static, final. So you can add constants, for
example, Max, Max speed. I don't know 320.
And however, you shouldn't do so. And when
you think about it, I guess you will easily
find out why. Because for example, the BMW
might only do a max speed of 240. Porsche
Yeah, maybe a Porsche can maybe do 320, but
maybe also even more than Mercedes, I don't
know. So this is actually not part of this
should not be part of the interface, because
this is an implementation detail. And such
an implementation detail should be hidden
within the class, or even better. In an email
about this, let me also shortly show you a
little page I found on the web. And this is
here it is on the page of sonar. Well, actually,
it's called sonar cube sonar cube is really
a very cool tool. It's actually one of my
favorite tools for static code quality analysis.
I'm pretty sure very soon, I'll do an episode
on sonar cube alone. For now, let me keep
this as short as possible, because we still
want to talk about interfaces. But in this
sonar cube, it's actually a rule that checks
that you don't use constants in an interface.
Here it says console should not be defined
in an interface. And there was also or there
is also very smart, cool guy, Joshua blah,
the author of Effective Java, which is, by
the way, also a must read, I have a link to
that book on my blog, on Marcus minus bo.com,
where you can directly buy it from MSN. So
if you have the time, you can also read all
this, but I think I already explained the
important parts. Here, we can also look at
it. So noncomplying code is to define the
variables directly in the interface. And you
see here they even didn't say public static
final because this is again, every variable
you define, is implicitly a constant. So you
don't even have to say public Static final.
But this is not good. Anyway, the much better
solution is to use an enum we have talked
about enums already. So I won't go in more
detail here. Another possibility, which I
would not recommend, you can also have something
called constant classes, which you make final.
And then in the class, you have the public
static final constants. This is possible,
but it's always better to have small enums.
Because usually what happens is in these constant
classes, they would grow. And they would grow
and have contain all kinds of different constants.
While this only contains the constants of
this status here. And also, I mean, talked
about this when I talked about enums is type
safe. Well, here, you could change any number.
Okay, so anyway, so now back to our code.
So, here, you already see it's redundant.
All this is redundant, and should be removed.
But this should also be removed. As I said
before, because it's an implementation detail,
this is not part of our contract. Because
the car should just define what needs to get
done, what behavior class implementing that
behavior has, like it should drive, but the
way how it's how it drives, if it drives fast
or slow. This is part of the class and not
part of the interface. This is really important
when you want to do clean coding. Okay. So
now let us implement, use the interface. So
now, when I say implements car, when you you
can now use BMW as a car. And when you do
so, BMW plays the role of being a car. And
as I said before, you can also implement several
interfaces, which we're going to do very soon.
But first of all, let me finish this quarshie
implements car. And Marie cetus implements
car. Well, the compiler was directly happy,
I hadn't got to do anything, or implements
car. Because the work I've done beforehand,
implementing the method will normally let
me know that this just to be faster in my
here, code example. You won't do it like this,
you define a class, you say it implements
an interface. And then you see I already have
a problem with the compiler, which tells me
I have to implement the abstract method, Dr.
Okay, and then you do this. And the compiler
is happy. It has to be exactly like defined
in the interface. You cannot, for example,
say int as a return value, because this is
not how it was defined in the interface. Okay,
now, let me also show you, oh, there's still
a problem with car. It seems there's the curly
brace missing, somehow. Okay, it seems like
I probably deleted too much. Okay, see how
small is is well, actually, by the way, I'm
an interface should have at least one method.
While this is also not true, there are even
something called market interfaces that don't
even contain a single method. This is a specialty,
which I'm not going to go in detail now. But
usually they would have at most, at least
one method, and maybe even many more methods.
But again, I want to warn you, I see often
interfaces with 10s of hundreds of methods.
And sometimes it's just too much. It's better
to have many, many interfaces and to have
your classes implement several interfaces
at once, so that you can decide what role
your class is going to play. And lo let's
implement more interfaces in here. I've already
prepared again, adding these methods, because
I have also what interfaces one interface
is the lockable interface, which I defined.
The idea for such an interface is
for example, you want to do logging, you want
to do you want to lock several different objects,
could have cars, persons whatsoever, everything
can be lockable. And I defined that in order
to be likable. Such a class must implement
a method called message, which I then later
in my learning framework can call. Because
I know that whenever I have a class that implements
luggable, it will then have a message method
that I can call and it returns me a string
that should be used for logging purposes.
Then also, well took me a while to come up
with examples, because what other roles could
a car play, I said, it could also be a property.
And such a property would have an owner, for
example, the owner of the BMW I made myself
I mean, I want to have a BMW, how cool is
that. And one more interface, I said, I just
came up with the idea, we could also have
a role of being an asset, an asset would have
a value. And so my BMW also has a value. So
I cannot easily say, implements luggable.
Think this one I have not implemented yet.
And I still have to do No, not twice implement
car, comma luggable, comma, asset, comma property,
the order doesn't matter. But now you see,
I've implemented already the value method
and the owner method, the message method,
I still have to implement. And as I said before,
the order is not controlled, so I can put
it in any order message.
And, yeah,
here, we just return something
on the car.
Okay, now, I have a class implementing 1234
different interfaces. OK, now let's use my
classes implementing the interfaces. For this,
we go back into my car service, what I can
already do is now my variable my reference
variable is at the moment of type BMW, the
class so my BMW can do everything that a BMW
can do, which at the moment is drive message
owner value, these are methods that we inherit,
see, there is inheritance already, from the
object class more of this very soon, but these
were the classes that we have directly implemented
in the BMW class, so I can use all of them.
Or let me show you a message, we can use them.
Now, what I can also do is, now that I've
implemented the car interface, I can say my
I create an object of type in W, but I put
a reference on it of type car. And now, this
will change the behavior. Now, I can just
call drive on it, because now my BMW just
plays the role of a car I can also say luggable
and then I will not be able to drive the car
because in the context of logging, I don't
care about driving all I care is about login
and for logging, I would need such a message
okay.
So,
now, let me make all these cars and this is
also something you should do I mean, the object
is the object, but the variable when you have
an interface, always try to like reference
with the with an interface to the object.
Because this way, you can more easily exchanged
your code like imagine the BMW would come
as an argument to the method. Now, at the
moment we have these three cars, imagine at
a later time someone in when so very cool
Marquess car, then when the when the method
is operating on the car interface type, this
method will work even with new classes introduced
without even knowing them at the time, we
wrote our car service. So whenever possible,
use the interface type. Okay. So now, I want
to have a for each loop. And for this, let
me put All these cars into a car array. We've
also already talked about array called as
cars equals two. And now the short definition
I can even do it on the fly. Make it even
more shorter. You W, you're pushy.
You're more serious.
Okay.
Hello, on this array, I can now easily iterate.
And I can now say car dot drive. And, or as
said before, each car will drive differently.
But this will be handled by the object. Now
our car service does not know any specific
implementation anymore. This is the coupling,
decoupling the code is not coupled so much
to the specific implementations, my car service,
all that it uses, all that it knows is now
the car interface. Okay, and with these few
lines, I iterate over all the cars and I drive
them. Let's execute this code to and have
a look if it works. Yeah, see, this is exactly
the same as before, my BMW is driving or a
Porsche he is driving and marmet cetus is
driving. Now let's also have a look at the
car reference. As you see, we can only execute
drive on it. That is defined by the car interface.
And we do have a BMW as the first element
in our area. But this headline 10, we don't
know. All we know is we have an area of cars.
Okay, so we cannot call any BMW specific method.
In here. I can also not say BMW, because this
is not competitive compatible. We need a car.
And we don't need to be in w because this
array is of type car. Okay, so let me fix
that.
Okay.
So
I think this pretty much wraps up my explanation
of interfaces in Java. A really cool feature.
And now let's have a discussion about the
pros and cons about the advantages and disadvantages
of interfaces in Java. Well, first of all,
let's start with the disadvantages. And actually,
I can tell you, there are not so many. Well,
you see, for every interface that are introduced,
I have to type down this code. And, of course,
this is here, not much, it could be of course,
much more. So, and each class that wants to
use an interface has to implement this interface.
So there is some added complexity. Also in
my car service, I'm using now the car interface.
And whenever you introduce complexity, this
complexity must be justified. So if it makes
sense, if it helps us with something, for
example, here, I'm not able to easily iterate
over all the cars. And you mentioned there
could be many, many, many, many more. But
my for loop would just be the same. So this
would be for example, a justification. But
my car service at the moment does not implement
an interface. Well actually, this is kind
of an exception to the rule. Most services
should implement an interface. Very often
this makes sense, because it's specifically
for testing so that you can exchange the concrete
implementation just here. In my example, it
does not make sense because I just want to
explain you interfaces and I want to have
it really short and neat and not too complicated.
And I know I will only have this one class
here for demonstration purposes. So why Would
I implement an interface here? So at the moment,
I don't see a reason to make my car service
implemented interface. Sometimes, of course,
there are corner cases, we're not sure. My
personal point of view there is, if I know
that for the next months, I'm not going to
need the interface. My probably leave it away.
Because code, I mean, it lives you are allowed,
you can change it, you can refactor your code.
So if at a later time you, it turns out you
need to interface then edit at a later time.
Just don't do arbitrary decisions. There are
people that like they love interfaces. And
for this reason, they do something I would
call interface readers, like an illness, blindly
adding an interface implementing an interface
always just because, and I think this is not
too smart. And then really, interfaces can
be a disadvantage, because they just make
everything more complex. But now, this is
already pretty much it. To the advantages,
so the advantages, I think a few ones are
already mentioned, while explaining the interface.
Probably one of the most important ones is
that it decouples your code, as I explained
before, like now, the car service only uses
the cotton Well, no, I was actually like,
sorry, of course, as it is implemented at
the moment, we still say new BMW new Porsche
new messages. So of course, at the moment,
it would still be coupled. But normally, of
course, he would also not do it like this,
what he would usually do is you forward an
array that is already filled, only then. Now,
our core service is not coupled to the specific
implementations. So it really allows to decouple
your code much better than without interfaces.
And this decoupling also helps with other
things, for example, team cooperation. Imagine
you have a big team of 10 2030 developers,
and you have a big project that you have to
work on for weeks or months.
And then you would probably form smaller sub
teams. And then each sub team would work on
a specific area. For example, one team in
our example here, could work on the car service,
while there would be another team implementing
different car types. Now the problem is, the
car service is then or might be dependent
on specific car implementations to test it.
And on the other hand, the team that implements
the different car types might need a car service
for testing, and for integrating their code
with the other code. So it's like, each team
is dependent on the other team. And so each
team blocks the other team. So nothing can
be finished. And interfaces can be a solution
to the problem. Because when you introduce
an interface here, for example, in this case
for the car service, then the team implementing
the different cars would just do a very stupid
dummy implementation, something similar like
I did here, where you don't have real code,
or just something where you see it's working.
And then the other team can independently
also work on their code. And also add dummy
implementations where needed. And only when
both are finished, they can be brought together.
So interfaces really help in team cooperation.
And then next advantage is interfaces really
include increase your flexibility, because
as you see, as I have changed it now we have
the cars array as a parameter to our drive
method. So actually at runtime, in this case,
in our test method, we have this drive method.
So now at runtime, I could have something
some condition if it's sunny, just making
this up. Then I want to drive in my Porsche.
And so I create a pushy here, so I would say
car car And then I would say if sunny car
equals to new Porsche else if it's not Sunny,
well, I hope I had so many cars, then I would
say I take the BMW instead. Because it's better
for rainy weather. Knew, of course, and now
I don't want to make an error, let me change
the method. And I don't implement sunny nose.
So I just say true here, just to have it simple.
So in this case, Now, of course, you wouldn't
be cold. And in my drive method to make this
work, make this a car to have it simple. And
I would call drive. So now at runtime, we
will decide what kind of car this is. So this
really adds a lot of power to our code.
So
it might be a pushy, and it might be a BMW
that is given to the Dr. method. Really cool
feature.
Okay,
I guess there are many, many more advantages
of interfaces. Let me know if you have more
to add. But I think this is enough for the
moment so that you get an idea of what interfaces
are. And all the advantages interfaces have.
Just also, again, the warning don't fall into
our interface, serious illness. This will
also be not wise. But I think this pretty
much wraps it up. I'm going to talk about
inheritance in Java. inheritance is actually
a very powerful feature of object oriented
languages. Similar to interfaces, inheritance
allows to handle a group of similar objects
in a uniform way. On top of that, however,
it also allows to prevent code duplication,
by inheriting the members of a class from
a parent class to its child classes. I'm the
members of a class in case you don't remember,
are the instance variables, and the instance
methods. So everything that is not static.
Okay, well, I guess that sounds very promising.
The problem is, I think inheritance is just
a bit too powerful actually. Well, if used
incorrectly, inheritance, can severely damage
your code. So really take here and use inheritance
sparsely. I mean, there are definitely justified
cases to use inheritance. But whenever in
doubt, I would not use it. Okay. And also,
it actually requires some experience to know
when to use inheritance, and when to avoid
it. To give you a real world example, I'm
at the moment I'm working on a project of
about maybe 15,000 lines of code. And there.
I used inheritance, maybe once. Yeah. So there
are alternatives to using inheritance. I'm
about this. We will talk at the later time.
Yeah. Well,
let's stop here for a moment. Because now
the introduction is almost over. You see me
in the button right corner talking to you
all very soon disappear, because I'll jump
into the code. And I'll show you how to implement
and use inheritance. Before that one personal
request. I'm doing this videos for you. So
that you can learn Java, I hope they useful
to you. If so, I would be very happy if you
could give me your thumbs up in the bottom
right corner of this video. And remember,
you can also subscribe to my YouTube channel.
Okay, well enough of advertisement Now, let's
really do a coding session and jump into the
code. Okay, so here you see I have prepared
this CEU test class for you. We are actually
not really testing something now. This is
just for demonstration purposes, any arbitrary
example. Um, this example is actually taken
from the book, headfirst Java, from Kathy
Sierra, she is really my favorite author of
any Java related book, highly recommended
to read
this and any other offer books. In case you
want to know, you can find a link
to her books on my blog on market minus b.com.
I have a must read section there, you can
find her books. Okay. Now back to the code.
So I have here the SU class. So the idea is,
we have here an area of animals, similar to
the area of cars I had in the last episode,
where I introduced you to interfaces, and
I had a car every with BMW and Mercedes and
a pushy, now we have an animal array with
a dog, a gorilla,
and a line and a tiger. So you should already
see interfaces and inheritance in Java. When
you use them, here, it looks quite similar.
And this, by the way, is called polymorphism.
You might have heard that.
And the idea of polymorphism is that on the
left side, you have a variable a reference
variable of this super type a parent class
animal. But Polly Morphe. I mean, this also
works with interfaces. So the idea is just
that you have an interface or a super or parent
class.
And on the right side, an animal can be a
dog, a gorilla, a line, a tiger, anything,
so different things can be assigned to the
left variable. Because the polymorphism means
like, many sides solve can have different
implementations on the right side. And they
will all be handled uniformly here, I have
prepared this feed animals method. Let's maybe
jump here. Okay, so you see I've prepared
this for each loop, everything that is read,
we still have to implement, I have only prepared
it. So we're iterating through my array, we
still have to implement the eat method. And
we still have to implement the H method. Now,
again, totally stupid, arbitrary example.
But just to have something to show you. And
to have variation. My idea was, I mean, totally
arbitrary. Really, this depends on the design
of your code that like because code is always
like a model of the real world. And so it
totally depends on the example that you're
working on. Well, in my example, I just defined
that I said, Well, every animal, a dog, a
gorilla, a line, Tiger, they all eat in a
different way. Because for example, a gorilla
would probably eat, I don't know what it eats
grass, or leaves or something will align.
I don't know. It's some kind of meat. So therefore,
my idea was to have an implementation, a concrete
implementation of the eat method in each different
animal subtype. And further, my idea was to
have this H method. Well, every animal can
be of a different age. But the calculation
Well, normally, you wouldn't probably calculate
the age. But I mean, this is just my stupid
example, I made it a method. So the calculation
would be the same for every animal. So my
idea is to have this as a concrete method,
an animal and have this as an abstract method,
because this is something here, where interfaces
are different. Sorry, yeah, but interfaces
are different to inheritance. In interfaces,
you only have abstract methods. And because
you have only abstract methods, the abstract
keyword is not needed. But here we can enhance
inheritance, we can mix it, maybe I should
already jump now to the animal class. So an
animal class this is still just a stupid simple
class totally empty. So you can use inheritance
with just a simple class. And now let's implement
two methods concrete
methods, public void, eat Later on, I'll make
this abstract. But for now, I wanted concrete.
public void. Ah, oh, okay. So now maybe we
should also do something in the method. And
again, avoid system or print boom, just, if
you're like me doing an example, showing something.
This is the exception polluter rules and it's
okayish to use system or printable, but avoided
in real code. Okay, so I say, animal is eating.
Well, this is not what we want. So it's just
step one, I said every animal is eating in
its own way. And here is say, h is cold. collated.
Okay, it's here the dots to just for fun.
So now, see, this class looks totally like
a regular class, you have seen so many times
before. Now, I go to the dog class, and I
want the dog to be an animal. Well, if this
would be an interface, I would say implements
you remember, but it's not it's a class and
we extend the class and therefore the keyword
is extends really, totally easy. Okay, so
we say extends animal. And all this is already
using inheritance. Now it's looks like as
if the dog class was empty. But in fact, we
can already use these two methods in dog Okay,
let's continue doing this for all the other
subtypes
gorilla
extends animal line extends animal. These
by the way are two interfaces, I also want
to show you and I might just as well do it
now, we can mix using interfaces and using
extending classes using inheritance we can
mix them the question is should we first say
extends or first implements, well, there is
a rule it must be that we say extends first
and then implements because in Java, we have
single inheritance. So, we can only extend
a single class, but we can implement any number
of interfaces, and therefore, this is a comma
separated list. And therefore, to make it
a bit easier, it's at the end. So, we say
implements and I can say this interface lockable
and comma printable. So, an interface plays
a role. So Aline can play the role of being
a lovable, when like, he mentioned, the code
is running on production at a certain time
where we want to lock the line or we want
to print it and therefore we can implement
this interface. Again, this is pulley Morphe
that align can be a luggable Okay, so, you
see there is something red, because now we
have a lot of methods that we have to implement.
First of all, from the animal, I mean, the
order is arbitrary. We can also start with
a printable. So there was a public void. Um,
was it print I hope method. And then there
was a public void I think message for luggable.
This might have Yeah, you see, so the rule
is, when we implement an interface method
as well as when we, when we implement an abstract
method from animal, the signature, the method
signature must be exactly the same. We can't
say what year because the interface said it
must be a string, return something just for
our little example. Okay, and in here, I say
system dot out.
Print.
ln
printing,
okay, get the idea.
So, now, there is still the eat method missing.
No, actually, it's not because we made it
concrete. So we don't have to implement the
method I'm already a bit too fast.
So see the red is gone. Everything so far
seems okay. But there's still a problem and
Sue test. Let's check this are the tiger,
we still have to do the tiger extends because
the tiger was not an animal yet. Maybe we
should look at this again. I mean, this is
interesting. So see, all those classes are
all already extending the
animal. And so these are already animals,
but the tiger is not yet required, we need
an animal with found is a tiger. Okay, so
let's make this also an animal. Now it's an
animal, and now it's working, the red is gone.
Okay, but we still haven't done what we want
it. Because I said I want this method abstract.
Now, you probably remember from when I explained
interfaces, an abstract method does not have
this method body, the implementation, but
just the method signature, this here on the
top,
the method signature. So let's remove the
body. And we have to say abstract in the interface
we didn't have to, because in interface, all
the methods are,
by definition abstract. But here I mean, how
would Java Nope, there's a concrete method.
And this one is supposed to be abstract. So
therefore, in inheritance, we have to explicitly
set abstract. But now there is a difference.
Because if one method is abstract, the whole
class has to be abstract.
Now,
what does this mean? Because actually, this
changes a bit of the behavior. And this, again,
depends on your personal design of the program
that you're writing. An abstract class cannot
be instantiated. Now, we cannot say the compiler
will not allow us We can't say new animal.
An abstract class is like just the contract,
just the protocol. Pretty much the same as
an interface is just the raw definition. But
we cannot create instances from an abstract
class, we can only do so from concrete classes.
But concrete classes cannot have abstract
methods. So this is something that you have
to clearly think of. And also amin, I said,
another warning, I said that this can be used
to prevent code publication. Now you might
think, well, cool, I just create some tool
class. And this has any method that I'm like
needed anytime for example, age. And then
I can say animal extends tool. Because even
the inheritance can have several layers. So
even though talk says extends animal animal,
again, could extend some class. So now we
could say, extend some to class haven't implemented
that. But I hope you get the idea. Well, even
though you can do so you should not do so.
Because the rule is you have to apply and
is a test. Also, this is from
the book of Kathy Sierra had first Java. They
you say an animal is a tool? No, it's not.
So because it's not a tool, we don't say tool.
Because otherwise, this can really get nasty.
And so you shouldn't do that as a recommendation.
But really a strong recommendation. Okay.
So yeah, it still has to be made abstract
because of this abstract method here and we
have to remove new animal as I said, doesn't
work. Okay, not everything read has gone.
Now,
let's go into our classes again. See, now
there is a problem. Now that this method is
abstract, we also forced to implement it.
So we have to say, public void, eat. And we
have to implement this method. And again,
stupid examples system called print ln dog
is eating dot dot dot Okay, So gorilla is
eating in a different way. It's, I don't know,
grass or something reuleaux is eating leaves.
Um, next one line, the line is eating something
again, and the tiger is eating something.
So in this case, they all implement the eat
method in their own unique way. So in reality,
you wouldn't, of course have your system out
print on but some specific, Tiger related
logic that only fits for tiger. And this is
why we have it here. And all the logic that
fits for all animals you put here. And this
by the way, I mean, on the one hand, this
is handy. But to me, this is really a double
double sided sword. I mean, this is handy
and can help. But on the other hand, it also
is really complex. Because when you're in
a class like Sue, how do you know which animal
implements eat, and which animal just inherits
the eat method, same for the H method,
because we could of course, again mix that.
And we can also override a method. So for
example, ah, this one is implemented. But
we could say, gorilla is implementing the
age by itself are not something. So this is
like, how you could define an exception to
the rule. You could say, well, my gorilla
does not use the H method. But instead, the
H method is replaced by exactly this method.
And the way this is done is, the signature
must be this method signature here must be
pretty much looking the same. You can't like
change the return value or the parameter
values.
Well, you see, you can, but it's just not
using inheritance. Now, this is also why it's
not yellow, but gray. Um, this is called overloading
a method. overloading a method means you implement
a method that has the same name as another
method. But it's just something completely
different. So this has nothing to do with
inheritance. If you want to inherit the method
and override me override it, it has to have
the same signature. Okay, there is one exception.
And for this, I have to introduce a new visibility
modifier. I think shortly, I talked about
it in an earlier episode, but I didn't really
explain you what it means. And this is protected.
Now what means protected? protected, means
it's visible, on the one hand, similar to
default, or package level visibility, and
the whole package. So now we can use the H
method. In Su. See, this is not read. It also
means it's visible in any class that extends
animal. In our case, now, we have all the
classes in the same package. But he mentioned
we had a car sitting, extend animal, I mean,
of course, we should not this would be stupid.
But just technically not from a design perspective.
We could then use the H method, because it's
protected. So the visibility is to any class
that inherits from animal on top, any class
that is in the same package. And this again,
makes it complex. Do you see how much I have
to explain? so that you understand, and this
is why I would avoid using it. So I just want
you to passively know when someone else uses
it. But I would really avoid it. But so protected
visibility is less visible than public. And
what I am allowed to do is I can increase
the visibility in a child class. So where
was I? Here? So I'm allowed you see it works.
I can say public void. Now this is still not
inherited. Nowadays, it's yellow again. So
I can say public And now I can also say protected,
which at the moment is the same visibility
as in parent class animal. But I'm not allowed
to say private, this will give me a compiler
error, attempting to assign weaker access
privileges. It was protected. So you're allowed
to make it public, but not less than protected.
The idea behind that is, I mean, an abstract
method defines a contract a protocol. Exactly.
Like with interfaces, by saying extends animal,
you promise any other class in the Java universe?
I am an animal, and you have a method that
is public. And you can call it. And me. You
mentioned the crazy stuff that would happen.
If there is one class that just does not fulfill
this contract. So this is why it's not working,
it has to have the same visibility. Oh, okay.
Then also, I mean, I said, we inherit the
members of a class. And I said, the members
of the class are the instance methods. These
are the instance methods, and the instance
variables. So you can also have here a protected,
I'm in H. And this will also be inherited.
We can now say, directly access is in here.
I mean, this is the H method. Maybe I should
now here have a public void. h method instead
of the eat method.
Okay.
And now I can say this dot age, or just age?
Or a statement? Yeah, of course not. It's
not finished
45. So this would now we'll set the age to
45. Or just age because here, we don't need
this. Because we know what we mean.
Um,
even though this is possible, we inherit the
age field, I would not make use of it. Well,
first of all, because I don't like protected
as I said, and second, because I think this
kind of violates the capsulation because the
animals should be the only one working on
its internal variables. Okay. So avoid protected
and avoid like, making the variables the members
the the instance members visible. If we have
a static method, public static, something.
Well, I have to implement it. Of course, this
can be used static void. For example, by saying
animal dot something can also be used now.
From Zoo or wherever. So we could say, animal
dot something. Yeah, you see, it's also formed
formatted differently. So we don't really
see this as a static method.
But this will not be inherited. So you cannot,
like override this or so. And the gorilla
class again, you can say animal dot something
will actually you can even say and this is
a bit weird. Gorilla dot something. But this
is not inheritance. It's just Java is a bit
smart. Here. The compiler is a bit smart.
It knows gorilla is an animal. So it realizes
this is an animal and then it takes the static
method.
But this is still not inheritance. Oh, K.
Let me remove that. I hope I haven't confused
you too much with that static.
Just remember, we only inheriting the members
of the clause. The instance methods and the
instance variables. All Okay. Well, I think
this is pretty much it. Maybe I should execute
it again. And now we see dog is eating. He
is calculated. Gorilla is eating gorilla is
implementing the H by itself. This was I was
overwriting the H method in gorilla, and only
in gorilla lion is eating, he has calculated
Tigers eating ages calculated. So inheritance
really is a complex beast. And in conclusion,
use it sparsely. Only use it when you can
say, when you can apply the is a test. A dog
is an animal, a gorilla is an animal, a lion
is an animal, a tiger is an animal, a tool
is not an animal. So you will not say tool
extends animal never. Um, if you're just looking
for something to like, not copy and paste,
to not duplicate code, you can do something
else, put your code into its own object, a
tool object. And then always you can use composition.
You could say, for example, a tiger has, I
don't know, um, has a leg. If that makes sense
or not, I don't know. So leg, leg.
And then you if you have a method, for example,
walk, you can say leg dot walk. And if you
have another animal that also needs up it
called eat still. So this would be walk. So
now if you have another animal that should
also use the lecture also use this method,
you can also make it to have
this member. And this by the way can and also
should be an interface. So that really makes
it much more flexible actually, even than
inheritance. Because using an interface, you
can exchange the behavior at runtime. This
is something I showed you in the last episode
talking about interfaces, where I said you
could have some condition, if I don't know,
Sunday.
He was
this implementation and otherwise the other
implementation. I mean, this is just not real
code. Just very fast. Else. I just hope you
get the idea. I could say if Sunday, like
equals to my fast leg, legs, you know.
And
the other days, I'm not so fast. I say used
to slow lag. And then after the instantiation
I would say like dot walk.
Okay,
so of course I mean this if else again introduces
some complexity. So whenever you design something,
there's always pros and cons, you have to
think, what do I really need? But so you can
use this, just to give you one example to
not use inheritance and still not duplicate
your code. Oh, okay. Let me remove that. Don't
want it to be read. Wanted to be working.
Okay, now, let's maybe recap before I finished
this video. So we talked about inheritance.
We talked about polymorphism. I showed you
you can use composition. And there's also
actually design principle it's called favor
composition over inheritance. As I showed
you you can mix using inheritance with was
that one of these classes? Yeah. With interfaces,
I showed you can implement several interfaces,
you can only extend one class. So I cannot
say it already. When I do the calmer Something
is wrong. So I cannot say this animal to this
doesn't work. Just believe me for now. Or
I mean, yeah, this is also a class, which
is implemented. Yeah. So you see class cannot
extend multiple classes. This works in C plus
class. And it's even more nasty than Single
inheritance. This causes something called
the deadly diamond of death. But I will not
continue. This is too, too much for now you
can google this deadly diamond of death. Because
Java doesn't support multiple inheritance.
I'm going to talk about the method finalize
of the class object. The class object is the
root of the class hierarchy. Every class in
the whole Java universe inherits the methods
of this class. So this is what makes those
methods here, very important. Which is probably
also the reason why those methods are very
often used in Java developer job interview
questions. So one way or the other, I hope
I have now raised your attention. Also, you
should now that this episode, as well as the
following ones talking about all those methods
are based on the really great book, Effective
Java second edition from Joshua block. I think
I mentioned it already earlier. Now I have
to say it again, buy this book read it. Even
better would be if you read it twice. It's
full of condensed information. Advanced Java
developer must know my episode is supposed
to give you an introduction to the topic.
But for more detailed information, it's necessary
that you read this book. Okay. So let's already
start talking about the finalize method. The
finalize method is actually a hook method.
What is a hook method? a hook method is a
method that, um, there is an empty implementation
provided in the class object. And the idea
is that when you want this method to be used,
he would provide an implementation in your
own class, by inheriting by overwriting sorry,
by overwriting this method. And then this
method will be called by the JVM. But before
I go in more details, the one the most important
takeaway from this episode is, this method
is flawed. So the best you can probably do,
generally speaking, is not overriding this
method. So not using it because it has its
flaws, will, in this episode, see? Why. I
mean, there are some few valid users, at least
according to Joshua blog.
I can tell you, I'm developing in Java since
2001. So quite a few years already, I have
never ever overwritten this method. So today
is probably the first time to demonstrate
you what it is what it does. Okay. So maybe
we should already jump into the into the code,
because it might be easier to understand for
you, or maybe before we read here, this description.
So the finalize method is called by the garbage
collector of an object, when garbage collection
terminate determines that there are no more
references to the object. So again, next question
was probably what is the garbage collector?
Well, the garbage collector is really a very
cool thing of the Java language. Other languages
such as c++, don't have it. As the name implies,
it collects the garbage what's the garbage
the garbage is or objects that you created,
worked on them. And after some time, the process
will be finished, at least on certain objects,
he will not need them anymore. And so it helps
to free up those memory resources. So that
you hopefully never run into out of memory
exception. And this is all done behind the
cover as synchronously by the garbage collector
for you. But here is already the problem of
the finalize method. Because I said it's,
it's called just before the garbage collector
runs. The problem is the garbage collector
is running as synchronously so you can't influence
when or if the garbage collector is running.
It is like its own smart beast. And you have
no influence to tell it that it should run.
You can only give it recommendations. But
you have no guarantee that the garbage collector
will ever run. And so you also have no guarantee
that the finalized method will ever run. Yeah,
and what would you usually do in the finalize
method, the idea was, you will also clean
up stuff, they're just not memory related
resources, but not memory real related resources.
For example, if you have a connection to some
i o resource, like a database or a file, those
are also system resources. And all resources
are limited. So if you don't want to get in
trouble, and if you don't want that your system
totally, totally freezes. You have to, again,
free up resources when you don't need them
anymore. So the idea was to do that in a finalized
method. Now the flaw is, you don't have a
guarantee that runs. And this already says
it's not working as intended. Okay. Besides,
Joshua Bloch also gives other reasons. For
example, He somehow measured that creating
an object and destroying it, again, is 430
times slower when you have an finalizer method
implemented. So again, don't use it. And now
let's jump into the ID and look at it in more
detail from a practical point of view. Okay.
Also, just before, in the API documentation,
you might have seen, this method is actually
protected. Here. Again, we can see it protected
void finalize, I mean, this Java API is just
written into the source code. Here, you can
see the source code of object dot java. So
you see, it's also just a regular Java class.
And you'll also see this method is empty.
This is what I said, it's a hook method. The
idea is that you override the method and that
you provide code that is executed for cleaning
up non memory resources.
And Java, try to prevent that you directly
call the finalize method, because as I said,
the idea is that you don't call it but that
the JVM calls it for you. So this is why this
method is actually protected. Protected is
quite hard to understand. One way you can
use a method that is protected is if you are
in the same package. So let's check this class
isn't a package Java Lang. So I thought being
nasty, I can just as well create a class in
this package. And this is what I did here,
test Java. In package Java Lang. You see,
everything seems fine. I don't have any exception
from the compiler. So now, let's try to call
this method. And you see, this dot finalize,
seems to be working. I mean, this is not working,
because this is a static method. So we would
actually need a non static method. Or I could
also say, new object. Well, there is an exception,
because it can throw a throwable as we see
here at the bottom. I'm not going to handle
this now, because I only wanted to show you
from a theoretical point of view, this is
possible. There's just one problem. Let me
now surrounded with a try catch to get the
compiler happy. So see, this would be now
directly calling finalize, from a class that
is in package Java Lang. So I'm within my
public static void Main method. So I execute
it. Bam, I get an exception, security exception.
It's prohibited. I cannot use Java Lang as
a package name. So this is not working. Okay,
I just thought I should show you. I think
this is quite interesting. Now, let's close
this again. And let's complete remove this
method. Okay, so what you should also know
I mean, I said object is the root class, but
it's also a concrete class, you can create
objects of the class object. What I don't
like here is that the word object is used
twice, because the class is called object.
That's a bit confusing. So anyway, you see,
you can call all those methods. But here within
the class car selector, we cannot call the
finalize method. Okay. So for this, I have
here, this portion class, that's also close
the object class. And now let's override the
finalize method, public void finalize, without
any parameter. So to override a method, it
is very important that you do it exactly.
Like in the superclass, the only difference
is, and this is allowed, I don't make it protected
anymore, I can make it public. Because public
is more visible than protected. This is fine.
Okay. And now, the idea would be that in here,
I do clean up my resources. Let's imagine
I had some i, o reader, i, o reader, reader,
Peter, I'm not going to implement this, just
so that you get the idea. So the idea was
that within here, he would like for example,
close those resources for this, usually I
already use provide a closed method. Now there
are several problems for one, I said, you
don't have a guarantee that this method is
ever called. This is totally in control by
the JVM, and you can not influence that it's
running out of your control, it's running
as synchronously. And therefore, it doesn't
really serve our purpose. Second flaw is,
if within here, we have an exception that
is not caught,
the
process here will be stopped. And our objects
will remain in some weird, let's say zombie
state. Yeah. Okay, so the question is, what's
the alternative than to using the finalize
method, the alternative would be, if you have
a class that you will use that uses resources
that you want to be closed before it's cleaned
up, you could provide, like I told you here,
the reader would do. You could and you should
provide some closed method. And then in here,
you do clean up i o resources. I'm going to
implement this now. And then make this compilable
in car selector. Let's imagine this was a
client of using Porsche. When we have Porsche,
Porsche, a new Porsche you use a try Finally,
we talked about Exception Handling array.
And I think, there in this episode, I told
you also, you can say try catch and finally,
but you can also use the finally without a
catch. Now, if we need a catch or not, this
is a different discussion. What is important
is that at the end, you have finally because
the finally the cool thing about the Finally,
even when there is an exception happening,
it will always be executed. Because this was
our problem, we need to make sure that the
non memory resources get cleaned up. Okay,
so try finally. And then in here, we could
say Porsche e dot close to clean up the resources.
This is how you probably do it in Java. Okay.
Also, shortly, let me show you what I think
is interesting. Let's go back what I had before
and the finalize method. What I also want
you to know is I mean, I said we overriding
the method from the class object which is
empty. And there's actually an annotation
that is quite helpful here. And this is the
annotation, the override annotation. See,
when I put the ad, there is override. So about
annotations. We have haven't talked a lot
yet. So let me explain that. In short, this
is actually some meta information for your
compiler, that you say, Well, my intent here
is I want to override some method. If this
has a different name, some other name. Here,
you see, you get an exception method does
not override any method from its superclass.
Now, you might not understand what this helps
us. So let's, again, call it finalize. Now
the thing is, you only override a method if
the signature is the same as in the superclass.
Now, if I add the parameter here, this is
not overriding anymore, but overloading the
method, because it's just a method that has
the same name. But as it has a different parameter,
it has a parameter string, and not no parameter.
This is not overriding anymore. And now we
get a compile error. So you will directly
notice. So this helps us to have the problem
directly at compile time while we're still
in our ID. And we will not because otherwise
it could happen, you think you have implemented
a method while you have not. And then you're
still using the superclass method. And this
you will only see when your code runs on production.
This is why whenever you override something
at this override, annotation. Okay. So I think
this is pretty much it, talking about the
finalize method. In short, again, generally
speaking, don't use it. Instead, to free up
non memory resources use a try Finally, I'm
going to talk about a method clone of the
class object,
a class object I said before, is the superclass
of all the objects in the Java universe. And
this is why you can use the method clone in
all your objects. Now, the question is, should
you Really? And the short answer is, you should
not at least generally speaking, and this
is similar to the finalize method that we
talked about in the last episode, which is,
again, the reason why I'm talking about clone
today, because in this aspect, they're both
quite similar. Okay, but before going in more
details, maybe first of all should clarify
what actually does the clone method do. And
clone as the name implies, it creates an identical
copy of the object that you call clone on.
So what it does not do is, if you have an
object, you can always assign it a second
or third, how many references ever you want.
The problem is with references, that when
you work on this reference, all other references
will have will be influenced by your changes.
And sometimes this is not what you need, you
want an independent copy. And for this reason,
you could use the clone method. However, there
are actually better alternatives, which I'll
tell you later. But now enough of talking
Anyway, let's jump into my ad and look at
the code. Okay, so, here you see my Porsche
test, you might remember the pushy and the
other cars from my earlier episodes. Before
I show you the nasty stuff, I wanted to show
you one case, where actually I think using
clone is actually good. And this is here I
have prepared an array of strings 123 and
here, I mean array is also an object. So it
also has the clone method and for the string
for the array, it was already implemented
the way it should be. So you can and you should
clone your array. So I can say string copied
array equals to array dot clone. And then
I can assert not same, which means this check
checks. Now, if we just have a reference.
In this case, it would be the same
airy
and copied airy. Which, to show you that their
friends I can also call, assert same and use
twice the same reference. So this should be
true. They should with not also be true. So
there are two different instances.
You see, it finished with a green bar, this
is what we want to see. So it seems error
and error compared to itself, it's both the
same reference, they're both referring to
the same object. But the copy is not the same
reference, it's not the same object, it is
a new object. And now, I mean, I want to make
this short. But I want to show you at least
system out, print ln. And then, you know,
this is not I just want to show you the first
element and then I just hope you believe me,
or you can do it at home can print out the
whole elements in in an in a loop. Now I'm
just showing you the first element of my copy,
and you see it's one. So the other ones are
also or unlike just as well. Otherwise, you're
telling me copied error. This way, you also
learn how you can print out the whole array.
And this is now I can print odd STR and this
will then in the loop and a for each loop,
print out all the strings
for us.
So I hope this is working now. 123 C, out.
Okay. So for now this should be enough. This
was just a very short demonstration of a good
case of clone. Actually, I found on the internet
and very interesting article Actually, it's
a newsletter article from Dr. Heinz Cabot's,
he's really a very cool guy. I love his newsletters.
And he actually made a test and found out
that clone for very small areas might be a
bit shorter, f slower. However, for large
arrays, it's actually faster than any other
method. Well, I can't go in more detail, we
don't have the time. And this is also very,
very advanced already. And we're still on
beginner level, approaching more advanced.
So anyway, let's continue with our portion.
And this is now really test driven style programming.
Because I start with an empty test. The code
is not finished, we start with writing a test
to test Well, first of all we read, and then
we are working our way to get the test screen.
Okay. So I say Porsche Porsche equals to new
Porsche, actually, this is something you can't
know. Before doing this episode, I have extended
adjusted my class a bit. I mean, you might
remember the Porsche from my last episodes,
because it was empty. Initially, there was
no attributes, no instance members. So this
I had to change because I want to show you
something that we copy. So I added a string.
And I said, it's the owner, the name of the
owner. And well, which name should I choose?
Because I always wanted to own a Porsche.
I thought I might just as well make me the
owner of the Porsche. And because you probably
also want to own a Porsche. I thought I should
make you the owner of our copy of our clone.
Because I will not give you my pushy, but
I might just as well copy mine and then give
you this copy. Well, in real world, this is
pretty much impossible. However, here in Java,
See how easy that is? Only problem we have
is I don't know your name. So for this example,
I just assume your name is Peter. So I say
Peters for xi equals to new pushy. But this
is not what we wanted to do. Right? We wanted
to clone. Yeah, because this is no easy. I
can just say Peter, and then you have your
pushy but this is not the original idea. So
let's remove that. And now let's say Porsche
dot clone. And interesting enough, really,
I mean, we can see what happens behind the
covers, because this is done really, by the
JVM. And we don't care too much, as long as
it works. But there is never a constructor
actually cold. So this is really internally
copied from the memory. It's just see, we
still have this read something is still wrong.
I mean, I said, we start with a not working
test. So it says clone has Protected Access
and Java Lang object. And this is something
we have to fix. So the method that says the
method is already there. The problem is, it's
not visible to us, because it is protected.
Protected would be visible in the same package.
The class object is in the package, Java,
Lang, as I showed you last time. But here
we are in a different package. Also, my Porsche
test does not inherit anything from Porsche.
Because this is from Porsche, so I can't use
clone in here. Okay, but what I can and what
I will do, I can override the original clone
method. But still, I want the code the implementation
of the class object. But let's already jump
into the Porsche class. So I will override
it, public, Porsche, because I wanted to return
a Porsche to me,
clone.
And then you might still remember from my
last episode, we can and we should put the
override here to have a check from the compiler
side, that we actually did everything correctly.
Now, let me format that. Okay. And you see,
there's nothing red. So it seems like so far,
everything is fine. We'll actually went into
one interesting thing is the original implementation
says object, because in object, what could
you return, you don't know. The object that
the method always is exactly copying whatever
object there is. And in our case, we have
a Porsche. So the so it is also fine to directly
make this return pushy. But now we have an
empty implementation. And we have to return
a Porsche. Or we could say return new Porsche.
But again, this would not be a clone. So this
would, our test would fail in this case. So
this is not what we can do. So we have to
say super, super means. I want to call a method
from superclass in this case object. And you
will see already here I see clone is actually
the first method, because my ID is already
smart, it knows the name of this method is
clone. So it assumes I want to call super
clone. Okay, so and then I want to return
it. So all we did so far is we override the
method. And then again, we said, well, actually,
I don't really want to override it. All I
want is I want to use the method of class
object. So all we did so far is we made the
visibility public so that we're able to use
it this is all we did so far. But now, you
see there is still a problem unhandled exception
Java Lang clone, not supported exception.
And this is already in my opinion, a flaw
because, like, why does this Now throw a clone
not supported exception, if we do support
clone. So, anyway, this is how it is. And
now we have to fix that the way we fixed that
is we say try, because there is an exception
that could happen. And we will catch the exception.
Catch. And there my ID Egan helps me clear
not supported exception.
I usually give it the name here. Okay, now,
what should we do here? Some people say return
now. Because we have to return something.
This is just the signature forces us
to return something. But this is not so nice.
I mean, actually, we assume this is hopefully
never happening. But if it for whatever reason
is happening, we really want to see that it
is a problem. So in this case, and I kind
of copied that from Josh block. Because again,
my episode here about clone is based on his
book, Effective Java second edition. And it
was exactly the same with a finalized episode.
So I can only give you a short introduction
to the topic. Um, Josh block in his book,
he has like, I think eight pages only on the
clone method. You should really buy the book
and read it. So for this, you can go to macros
minus bu.com, click on mastery, it's, and
there you will find the book and you can buy
it directly. Yeah, also all the books in the
must read section. I mean, I have picked the
name for a reason. Those are really books.
I want you to read them all. They're really
classics, the best of the best best Java books
you could find, in my opinion, at least. So
if you trust me by that book and read it,
okay, anyway, so what he did and what I will
do the same, as he said, throw new assertion
error. Because if this happens, this is not
even an exception. Is this really an error?
We really have a big problem here. If we get
this clone, not supported exception. Okay,
so this year now seems fine. But there's still
something wrong. And this is it says I'm calling
super dot clone. And as I told you, this is
the method from object, an object returns
an object, at least from the signature of
the method. But we are smarter we know actually,
it's safe to say pushy, because this object,
I mean, the super type is object. But the
subtype is a Porsche. So we do an explicit
cast, and we cast it to Porsche. This is safe
here. Yeah, if it was not safe, it would throw
a class not support F. Class cast exception.
Sorry. But in this case, believe me, we'll
see. It'll it should work. Okay, well, are
we done? It looks like we were. Well, actually,
as I said, this method is flawed. So we are
not done, we still have to do some more thing.
But this I want to see. I mean, my idea was
to implement the method I did that. So now
let's go back to our test, you see, everything
is? Well, I can't say green, but the red stuff
has gone. So I can execute the test. But I
haven't asserted anything yet. So the first
assert that I want to do is I want to assert
not same. This is just a shorter, Handy form
of saying not equal. So it won't be the same
if we say pushy, not equal to Porsche Peters
pushy, because the idea is that when my clone
word that I have a new object. And because
it's good to have a method that already from
the method name tells us what it does, I use
this one. And I compare not pushy to Peters
pushy. So my first test is just asserting
that this reference here is not referencing
this Porsche here now. But something else,
this isn't our first test all I want to achieve.
Okay, so I execute the test.
And bomb.
You see the assertion error? I said, Well,
everything will be saved law when it's not.
And this is why tests are so great. Yes. And
now we can see what happened. And think about
why did this happen? Okay, so by jumping here,
see, line 28. I see this happened. Problem
is here in this case, without further knowledge,
it would really be hard to know why this happened.
So here, sorry, I have to help a bit. Thing
is, I mean, I told you this method is flawed.
It's not enough to use the power of inheritance
here. On top you have to use, you have to
implement an interface here. So we are already
implementing car. But for interfaces, I told
you in the episode about interfaces, we can
implement several interfaces. So here I have
now to implement the cloneable interface from
Java Lang also. Now, funnily enough implementing
the interface, normally, I would expect that
I would have to implement some method. Well,
in this case, it's different. We don't have
to implement anything. And this is a specific
case, this interface we call a market interface.
So this interface is actually empty. There's
nothing in there. It just tells the JVM. I'm
implementing cloneable. So you can call cloneable
here, it's a clone here it works. And this
is a bit awkward, because normally when you
implement an interface, you would on the Reference
Now, like I can now say that I implement cloneable,
I can also make this a cloneable. So that
my pietras portion now plays the role of being
a cloneable. The problem is, this doesn't
help me anything. I don't have the method
cloneable. Here, all I have is the other methods
of the class object, which we're not using
now. So because I can also say car, I mean,
I'm implementing, also the car interface.
And then I can call the methods of car, which
is drive, plus all the methods of class object.
Okay, well about macros interface. That's
also another topic. This is a design pattern.
haven't talked much about design patterns
yet. Marker interface really has good users.
So a marker interface, generally speaking
is not bad. It just here in this case, it's
a bit weird that you have to implement a market
interface and then on top, you have to override
the method. Okay, so I make this portion again.
But now, and now the same as already, again,
working because otherwise you could not compare
different things. Let's try it again. And
see, now we have the green bar process finished
with exit code. So my first assumption is
correct. Peters pushy is not the same instance,
as pushy. Okay. So now I want to see who is
the owner at the moment of Peters, Porsche,
Peters, Porsche, Dodd, s string. And this
is why before I prepared this method, because
it returns Porsche II off plus the owner's
name, because at the moment, we don't have
another way of seeing the content of owner's
name. So I wrote this method to see who is
owning it at the moment. Okay. And my expectation
when we're finished is that the name would
be Peter. So I would say it should return
partially off, Peter. So let's write a test
for this. assert, equals, first, the expectation,
you also see it expected. So I'm expecting
it to say pushy off Peter. Okay. And then
comma. And I put here pushy, Dodd as string,
which is calling the method. So I expect the
method to return portion of pizza later on.
I mean, there's also again, a method called
equals. In an later episode, I'll talk about
this and we will have a better way of comparing
that for now. I'm using the S ring method,
because we haven't talked about the equals
method yet. So there's still something missing.
Okay. I can remove that. So let me also execute
this test now. And it should be read. Yeah,
oh, there's an error. I have missed a semicolon.
Again, sorry. Yeah, comparison failure. Expected
portion of Peter bar is still mine. Now this
is even cooler for me. Now I have actually
two portions. But okay, I said you get one.
So let's change that. And for this, I will
now change the owner. So I will sell on my
second car. Okay, and I will sell it to Peter.
Which means I mean, I just made this method
up before I assign the owner's name the new
owner. Okay. Also, by the way, I mean, here
I'm using string to have this as simple as
possible for our example. Usually, I would
prefer to have this proper object also, like,
name, for example, and I also already have
that here. But in this fast example, I use
string. But more object oriented would be
if you have name as an object there. Okay,
so I sell it to Peter. And now I expect the
test to be green. Let's try it again. Okay,
it's green,
it worked.
But now I have a fear. What if now my pushy
would not be mine anymore. So on top, I want
to assert that the The original pushy is still
mine portion of macros to the original portion.
K, which also worked. And this tells us now
starting from my pushy macros, I called the
clone method, it created a new object in memory.
And this new object was assigned to the reference
Peters Porsche he inserted that they're not
the same object to different objects. And
then I changed the second object. And I gave
it the owner of Peter. So and I asserted that
now, the owner's name is Peter, by comparing
the string. And second, I asserted that what
I was working on the second object, the copy
was not influencing my policy. So this is
like proving that our clone operation did
work. But now let's look at the code. What
we needed to do for this, I had to say implement
cloneable, I had to override the clone method,
I had to call the super clone method, I had
to catch the clone, not supported exception.
This is a lot of lines for only this. And
actually, there's more to it. Because actually,
what this does is it creates only a shallow
copy, and not a deep copy. Now, again, this
is a more advanced topic. So I try to keep
this as short as possible. What's the difference
between a shallow copy and a deep copy? Okay,
well, a deep copy for this, I have prepared
here a more complex object BMW. And here I'm
using actually the object name. And I'm even
using a second object color. And let's make
this a bit bigger. So you see more, a deep
copy would mean that not only BMW is copied,
but also all the objects inside of BMW are
copied. So that they are also independent,
that they're not referencing the same object.
But a shallow copy will here, only copy the
reference. And the object for name, as well
as the object for color will still be the
same objects for shallow copy. Sometimes this
is okay. And sometimes it's not, it really
depends on your implementation. However, in
short, if you're using clone want to make
a deep copy, you will also have to call clone
on the internal objects, and this here, I
have prepared. So here, I'm calling clone
actually, three times. Now, one more problem
of the clone method is what I'm actually doing
here is, first of all, I cloned BMW, and then
on this attribute, and this one, which is
already fully functional, I assign a new value,
which only works if this is not final. So
it turns out not to in order to make a deep
copy, it only works if your internals are
not final, and sometimes you want them to
be final. So this is really a limitation of
the clone method. And also, I mean, how complicated
it is, is not so nice. Okay. Um, and for this,
there are alternatives I told you. I've written
here a lot of code. I have written this code
so I could show you what to think. Yeah, I
would want to make this episode not as long,
because I noticed many of you are only watching
like the first minutes. So 95% will already
be asleep anyway. So let's keep this short.
So in short, let me show you alternatives
to using the clone method. There are two alternatives.
The first alternative is using so called copy
constructor, and this is this thing here.
The copy constructor has one parameter, and
this is the same object. And then you see
here, I say new name, on owner's name, new
color on BMW dot color. So I'm taking the
internals and I'm creating new objects on
it.
And so in the end, I will have a new object
that has the same values as the original object.
This is One alternative. The other alternative
would be, and this is actually my preferred
one to use a so called static factory method.
And this is this here, it's a static method.
So you can directly say BMW as the class name
dot new instance, you can give it the BMW
object you want to copy. So in this case,
probably Marquess BMW. And then you You see,
I again, call the constructor, new BMW. But
here, this is a more complex object. So I
have to recursively we call this recursively.
Because again, I say new instance. And he
also new instance. And I have to again, call
those methods to also cop copy the owner's
name, because now I'm actually doing a deep
copy, I could have also just assigned the
values, this would be a shallow copy, but
it's safer to have deep copies. Okay, so And
for this, we can also have a short look into
name and color. Because there again, I do
the same thing. Here I have my new instance
method. So this is taking a parameter of name,
and then says new name, first name, dot last
name. Now, first name and last name are both
strings. And strings are also objects. So
why do I not need to copy down? Okay, now
it gets more and more complicated, I'm sorry,
um, thing is a string as an object, but it's
actually an immutable object. And immutable
means whenever you change the object, like
you assign, instead, first name, Marcos, you
say, Peter, you will not influence the other
reference. But instead, whoever said make
this, Peter will get a new object. So this
was really helpful. And for string, this is
done for you. Actually, you can do this for
your own objects too. And in order to achieve
this, you just have the limitation that you
don't offer any method to the client that
allows the client to change the values in
here. But instead, you will always for any
change, return a new instance. And then you
have an immutable. For this, I have also here
an immutable test. Because there's another
class that actually does it, which is big
integer. Big integer is similar to an int,
that we already looked on it just a bit better.
First of all, because it can work on ends
of, well, at least theoretically, any length
until your memory is full. And there you have
operations to add and subtract, for example.
Now, when you say one, add one, this is returning
a new object to but the original object will
not be influenced by this operation, you can
also subtract, but everything that you call,
every method that you call will never influence
will never change how the object looks. So
it's created once with the constructor, this
will like assign one to it. But after this,
you can never ever changed it again, which
is very helpful. In many cases, it's really
a good design principle to use immutables
whenever possible. Um, yeah, and it's also
very good to use multiples when you do code
multi, multi threading. We haven't talked
about multi threading yet, we will at a later
time. But there immutables are also very helpful,
they will make everything more easy. So, maybe
you take one more thing with you from this
episode. And this is favor immutables try
to design your objects your classes in a way
that they are not mutable, that they cannot
be changed after they were created. Or came
here at the same thing with string. Maybe
I can show you so I call so assigned twice
Hello, which in memory is actually the same
object. But when later on here, I Say hi.
This will influence the string one, and not
influence a string to let's execute this shortly.
So you see, like the speaker so we can see
Bo's bigger even. Okay. So now I see the first
string here printed Hi, the second string
printed Hello. And so they're not equal, the
first one has high, and the second one has
Hello. And if I remove this, this is why I
had commented it out. Let's execute it again.
Of course, now they both have Hello. So that's
the difference. And this is one example of
an immutable strings are, by definition immutable.
Maybe we could also call this here. So I print
out any n 01. And two. And also, I assert
to do a few things. So the input value of
one is one, the input value of two is two,
and the end value of zero is zero. Well, I'm
operating on these objects, they will always
return a new object, return a new object,
they will not influence the original object,
this is an immutable, this is something that
you should try always to achieve our K, let's
go back to Chrome. Let's recap. So in order
to properly use clown, you have to first of
all, override the clone method so that it
is public. Second, you don't have to, but
it's recommended. Use not object here, but
use the type of the class that you're in,
then you will have to do an explicit cast
to the class here. Catch the claw not supported
exception, thrown your assertion error, which
will show you in case you forgot to implement
cloneable, which you will also have to do.
However, what this is going to achieve, it
will create a shallow clone for you. Which
means if there are objects that are not immutables,
and you then operate on those objects, this
can break another object, because still you're
not totally independent, you're only potentially
independent, you're only on the first level
independent. But if here you have name, this
will only copy the reference and the object
here would still be the same. If you also
want to achieve this, you have to implement
a more complex clone method, you have to also
call clone on the internal objects and then
assign the new clone values to your internal
attributes, which will only work if they are
not final. So this already limits the way
you can implement your code. See if this is
not working now. So and this is one of the
one of the many, sorry, one of the many reasons
why you should not use clone, other than to
clone an array. And I showed you two alternatives.
One is use a static factory method. I call
the new instance. Same like Josh block in
Effective Java that you should buy. And here,
I call the constructor. And again, recursively.
I call again, a factory method on name. And
again, a factory method on color, which even
creates a deep copy. Or I can do the same
thing with a constructor. But you see this
is actually shorter. So this is why I would
prefer to use the factory method. But it both
works. Okay, so here, I call twice a new constructor,
I create a new name object, and I create a
new color object. Okay, and then in name,
we can also look. You see, I do the same thing.
And this now is strings and I said strings.
Now we don't have to call clone because a
string is immutable. So you have to do this
recursively until you reach either an immutable
object or a primitive. If this were again,
like first name object, we would have to continue
with cloning, or copying, like calling the
constructor until you reach either a string,
or a primitive value or another immutable
object. See here also implemented clone.
And then we can also look at color one last
time. For all of them, I have done the three
different implementations here with a static
new instance method, here with a clone method.
And last but not least, here with a copy constructor,
it receives a color object, and then it retrieves
the string from the original object, which
is a string, which we don't have to clone
any further. I'm actually going to talk a
bit about various smaller topics. We're still
on track, talking about the class object,
and all its methods. The last two methods
I need to tell you about are hashCode. And
equals. Actually, they're one of the most
important methods in Java, I think. However,
hashCode and equals are a bit more complicated
to explain. So before I can tackle them, I
decided to push an episode in between to straighten
things up. And to talk a bit about the missing
pieces in this episode. Okay, so let's start.
As you see, I have prepared this demo test
class for you. Actually, we're not really
testing something today. This is really only
to use to demonstrate those few small missing
things. So let's do one by one. And the first
thing is, I want to talk about static imports.
You might remember, I think I talked about
static imports, in the first three episodes,
and I kind of promised you to later on give
you more details about it. The problem at
this time was we hadn't talked about static.
Well, in the meantime, we have, I just didn't
have any better opportunity to talk about
it. And I felt a bit guilty. So I think now,
I should really finally tell you what exactly
is a static import, how you can use it, and
what it helps you. So actually, we used it
all the time. And you might have seen it.
Here on top, I have this import static org
j unit assert dot star, it's just grayed out
because at the moment, I'm not using it. This
is also set here unused import statement.
Now you can see it. And you can also see here,
the regular import or j unit test sub question
is, what's the difference between the two
of them? So this one imports the code of the
whole test class? Well, this one here, a static
import just focuses on all the static methods.
Because in j unit, you know, when we want
to test, we always use these assert methods.
assert equals assert true.
Let's do that now. Like assert. True, you
see, it already helps me true. I mean, when
true is always true. There's a stupid, but
I just want you to see the method. And the
thing is, this is only not working because
I have this here assert and seeing, it's not
great anymore, it turns white, because now
it's in use. So let's actually have a look
at this class, I can jump there, you see even
it says it extends object will no wonder all
the classes extend object anyway. So here
you see, I see the decompiled code. This is
what my ID he can also do to show me the code.
This is very helpful, so you understand better
what happens behind the cover. So you Here
you see a lot of static methods. So this class
actually like groups them and makes them usable
to me. And as you might know, from static
when I talked about static, the way you would
use a static method would be normally you
say class name, dot assert true. Now you can
either use the full fledged class name, which
is org dot j unit dot assert, and then assert
true or if you don't want to use the package,
you would import the class and then you can
just say assert dot assert true. Of course,
there are also other methods, you can have
a look on those, by yourself. actually quite
complicated ones like you can even compare
areas, and so on and so forth, not equals
equals, with message without is equals, and
so on. Well, we have used some of them. So
this means I can also say, assert dot assert
true. But now you see this is not working,
because I have not normally imported the assert
class. So if I would want to do this, I would
have to say org, J unit dot assert, and then
import it like this. Now you see it's not
used anymore, because now I'm not statically
importing it, but regularly, and I'm using
the class name to use the method. But I mean,
when they introduced it, I think this was
with Java five. The reason to introduce this
where it was to just make these statements
shorter, because you don't always want to
write assert dot all the time.
Okay,
and you could also do it as said before, without
any import, this would even be more longer
than you could go without the import. Now,
they are not see, but there it is working.
That's the difference, because now I don't
do any import. Let's put it back. And then
we can go with or without. And if you wanted
like this and the shortest form, you need
the static import and not the regular import.
So that is a static import. And the dot star
means just input all the static members or
members, static is not members, all the static
functions and also the static variables of
the class. So if you have variables you want
to import that are static. This also works
with the star operator here. But you can also
say you import only specific functions or
attributes. So this is up to you. Okay, so
that's all I can tell you about static imports,
I think sometimes they're helpful. More often,
it actually happens, then you would think
that you would import several methods or attributes
that are the same in different classes. If
you have that it's exactly the same, like
I told you about the imports, you can only
import one method name once by using a static
import. If you're not have a second class
that has the same method, you will then have
to use the full fledged, or at least a class
name so that the JVM, the compiler knows,
in this case, I want the assert true method
from this class. And in the other case, I
want the assert true from another class. Okay,
so you can't I mean, there must be a way that
the compiler understands what you're trying
to do. If I only import this statically once,
I mean, then it's just obvious the assert
true is part of the assault class here. Oh,
okay. So that much about static imports. The
next small thing I want to talk about, let's
open this up is default values for different
data types. I think this is quite important.
And also interesting. Because I see many people
that would have here, member variables defined.
And then they would say something like, here,
or for cards, different weight. Like for the
Boolean, they would say false. Or for the
object, they would say novel. And you don't
have to do that. Because now for object, as
well as false for a Boolean is the default.
So this is in my eyes, this is just clutter,
you write code that you don't have to. I mean,
for every rule, there's always an exception.
For example, if this is very important that
this is set to false. And this is really a
specific case and you want to give a message
with it. It might make sense to sometimes
right here explicitly false. But then it also
maybe you should name your variable a bit
different so that it says why this is important.
And because my Boolean now I mean, this might
be the problem. It doesn't say why this is
always false. Okay, so And now let's have
a look at all the different defaults. But
when I say default, this really only applies
for these member variables up here. If you
for example, have a local variable Like Boolean,
B, you can't do that, if I'm not trying to
use it, this is not going to work. If b, this
will give me a problem variable b might not
have been initialized, but it does work with
the Boolean up here. This is going to work,
see, and now it will count as false. So the
if would not be executed the branch. Okay,
but now enough of talking, blah, blah, blah.
You might already be asleep, so wake up. Okay,
so let's make this a bit bigger, so we can
see it properly. Okay. Now, so you see, by
default value, short default value, those
are all zero.
Actually, there are many number types that
we haven't talked about. And this is also
what I'm just going to introduce right now.
Because we totally focused on end, because
this is actually the one that is most times
used. But as you see here, there are also
others. I think I shortly once showed you
bite, and I also showed you one's car. Um,
but there are also others. In my opinion,
this is just the smaller data types, we will
see the ranges very soon are only here because
I think like this or similar, they existed
in other programming languages before Java,
like maybe c c++. In my opinion, this is a
The reason is probably because like something
like 30 years ago, the memory was so expensive.
And that was really the memory space was so
limited, like you would have a memory of,
I don't know, a few kilobytes. Now with gigabytes
of RAM, this is totally a different issue.
So the space end users actually a bit more
bytes. But the space is really not relevant
these days, in 99, and probably 99.9% of the
cases are always use int. So wide and short,
in my personal opinion on something like deprecated.
I mean, this is not true, actually, because
I'm sure someone can tell me there is a specific
case where you would need them. It just that
on average, generally speaking, you should
be fine with an int. And we will look at actually
the sizes of these types in a second. So yeah,
that long is actually bigger, can save longer
numbers than end. This sometimes might be
needed, but also not so often really, I think,
now float and double, as the name implies,
at least for float, they're both floating
numbers. And double, I think the name comes
because it's like double the space or something,
then that of a float. Actually, also these
I hardly use, because first of all, I personally
did not worry too much with these kinds of
floating point calculations. And second, in
case I did, for example, calculating on money
that you would need that. But they are they
are quite problematic, actually, because they
don't calculate properly on the scent, it
can happen that when you have something like
two euro 20 multiplied by, I don't know, divided
by a number of people that in the end, you
lose or you gain a cent. And like in India,
in the financial industry, this is just not
okay. So therefore float and double can't
use be used there. The reason I can't perfectly
tell you but I think it has to do with internally
these numbers of course stored in a binary
format, you know, a computer only knows zero
and one. And then when, from this format,
it's transferred to our decimal format. For
those floating point numbers, then there are
rounding issues. And therefore, when you really
need to have a correct floating point result,
there are various other solutions. One is
to store the number without the floating point,
for example, as a long or end or alternatively
even as a string. And then you do your calculation,
and when it's finished. You insert the floating
point visually at the place in the UI where
it's needed. Which is also dependent on like
local settings, like numbers are formatted
differently in different languages. So therefore,
this is usually the way you would go, at least
definitely in the credit card or in any financial
industry. Okay, so anyway, float and double
are both floating point numbers. What is interesting,
by the way, is like, when you have a constant
value,
like 34 43.31, this here, I mean, this is
a value of constant value. And if I just write
this down like it is at the moment, this is
now by definition automatically a double.
If I want to have this as a float, I have
to say, the capital a lowercase F, at the
end, which makes it up float. So, if I have
like float my float node equals to this, or
he really have to say f at the end, because
if you leave it, I would get a problem, because
it says it found a double, but float is required.
And the same applies actually for int, short
bite, there is just the other way around,
because there is the default. And when you
want to use a short short as equals to 43.
This just works implicitly because Java sees
the space is fitting. And then it will just
implicitly convert the end because this is
really an end to a short. Ever. Let's try
the same thing with a long, long for d3. This
also works because now you try to store the
smaller thing, the end into a long, which
should always fit. Okay. So what else, so
we have object, the default value is now as
I said before, Boolean, the default value
is false. Car. Now this is interesting, it
depends on if you safe if you display this
as a car as it is. And then this is I think
it's called the null character. And I think
this is just nothing or maybe space here you
see there is something it just can't be displayed
by my UI. I mean, here, if I try there's nothing
blue. But here when I go over it, it's displayed
as blue because there is actually something
it just not visible. And I can convert this
character, the default character to an end.
And then it's a zero. Okay? Now, so these
were the default values of the different number
data types as primitives. Okay, and now, as
the next topic, I also want to tell you never
told you so far, all these number types, they
in parallel also exist as objects. Let's have
a look, and then see and discuss why that
is. Okay, so you would have bide my, this
is used already on top. So let's call, let's
just call it b
equals to bite dot value of now, this is a
static method method, which can and should
be used to convert convert, sorry,
a byte primitive to a byte object. You can
also say new byte. But this is just not recommended
because this might use more space. So, I don't
want to go in details because then I could
talk forever for performance optimization.
But this is just creating always a new object,
while the other one might reuse an existing
object of the same value. So, this usually
is good enough. Okay, there's also other methods,
static methods like pars. The difference is,
this works not on a string as far as I know,
let's try to Yes. And let's go into the function
See, I can Also see it here. And this converts
it not to the object, but again to the primitive.
This is the value of it converts it to abide.
He even you can give the radix, like the radix
of 10, or eight or 16, or whatever. This usually,
well, I never really needed. But there are
a lot of lot of functions. What is also interesting
is that these objects, they all extend the
abstract type number, abstract class, we talked
about inheritance already. So you're here
you can see all these different functions
that each of those number types have to implement.
So each of them, you can convert to an int,
long float, double as the primitive value.
The green stuff is, by the way, the Java API
documentation that you can also read online,
short. So this, all these types automatically
will have. Okay, so back. Now, besides offering
these cool methods, that might be helpful.
There is also another reason why these exists
as objects. The reason is, I think, mainly
because there is something called collections
that we will talk about very soon. I think
I even mentioned it shortly, it's something
similar to an array, it's like an array on
steroids. It's just a container that you can
throw in objects. And that's really it, you
can only throw in objects. And so you could
not throw in any primitive. And therefore,
this is also called a wrapper type, because
this object then will wrap around this primitive
type, and can be wrapped and unwrapped. Which
by the way, in the past, when working with
primitives and collections was needed. So
before putting it into the collection, you
would have converted your primitive data type,
like the CMI byte, input, the object would
then have, let's just say collection, let's
just say add, I mean, in reality, it looks
a bit different. But just so that you get
an abstract idea, you would have added this
thing here. And later on, when you wanted
to retrieve it again, you could then say,
wide dot, get the byte value. And then again,
there were people saying all this is just
too much work. And so I think also, with Java
five, there was an auto conversion introduced,
that now Java can work with a primitive and
an object, and will automatically behind the
covers convert a primitive to an object and
an object to a primitive, whatever is needed
by a certain function. Now, this is heavily
in used by almost every developer, I really
don't like it, and I really activate in my
ID, that I get displayed these conversions.
Because for one, this could even be an issue
with performance, because I see functions
that would like convert from a primitive to
an object, and to a primitive and so on back
and forth several times, which is just stupid.
Second, for a primitive, you have the default
value of a zero, that is safe, that will never
throw a null pointer exception. Ever for an
object. When it's not initialized, like here,
the value will be now and then when you on
an object call, b dot byte value, this will
actually throw a null pointer exception. The
problem is you don't see it, because it'll
be automatically be inserted by the compiler
for you. You only see it at runtime and then
you get a nullpointerexception. So really
be careful with these automatic conversions.
I personally hardly ever use them.
Okay, but so, so that you know of each of
these primitive number types There is also
the same type as an object. The names are
pretty much always the same, like there's
a short object. For int, it is integer. So
there's an integer. For long it's long. For
float is float and double, it's double. And
also Boolean exists as an object. Which by
the way, also has static Boolean object values.
So you can even say Boolean be laughter Remove
the bite. Because this is also B, Boolean
b equals to true, or equals to false. But
now this is an object. I can also show, you
know, the automatic conversion works. Even
though this is an object, the aesthetic value
here, can even jump there you see public static,
final Boolean false equals to new Boolean
false. So the cool thing when you use this
is there's only one object that is always
reused, and you don't always say new Boolean,
to save some space. Okay. And now you see,
I can assign this object to the primitive
type, because internally, the compiler will
do this for you, you just don't see it. Okay,
so that's, I think, all I can tell you about
the different number types and their object
variants. Now let's have a look at their ranges.
I said for example, byte In short, they have
smaller ranges. But enough of talking, I think
the best is I just show you. So execute the
test. And we see, let me scroll this down.
I think this makes it easier. Because then
we can see the test and the code in parallel.
Okay, so here, I used the system print long.
Remember, don't use it avoided. Just try test,
it doesn't really matter. I just shortly wanted
to show you the results. Otherwise, in productive
code prefer logging, because it's more flexible
and would probably lead generally speaking
to more performance, okay, but enough. So
here you see. So there are signed types and
unsigned types. Signed means you see, there
is a minus, so it goes from minus 128 to plus
127. Interesting is, this is not 128. But
127. While he is 128. This actually is for
all the sign types. The reason is, the JVM
in your memory of your computer will actually
need this one number to store the information
if it's a minus or a plus. And this is why
they had to take one number away. And they
just decided that minus has one, one more
number than Plus, I mean, they could have
also done it the other way. But this is how
it's done in Java. Okay, so you see, this
is only for very small numbers. 120 minus
128, two plus one and 27 short is already
much bigger. It can store 32,000 something
plus and minus again, one less here on the
right side in again is much bigger. I think
this is like 2 billion or so long, again is
much bigger. I don't even know how long this
number is. Um, yeah, usually you should be
fine with int can in some rare cases you need
a long Yeah, actually, sometimes I needed
a long Okay. And then there's his float floating
point number with the exponent minus and plus
and the double see here even is much bigger
324 to 308 minus plus and the car this one
is unsigned. So, this is why there is no minus
which is also why the size here is 65,000
something is the double size down to the short
because the short has the same space, but
it needs to have it in a signed form with
a minus and a plus. So this is why here we
can store zero to 665,000
Okay, and car as you have seen before, usually
is used not to store numbers, but characters.
But if you convert it to an end, you can also
use it to store numbers unsigned from zero
to 65,000 something okay. I think this is
actually interesting to see all these ranges.
Okay, so these were the ranges let's go to
the next. And so, in order to be able by the
way to show you see here I converted this
two intz and also our This is also interesting
you see here I used actually the object, the
objects and the These are static values, which
gives me the min and max value. This is really
handy. When you need those ranges, you can
just use them out of the box and say min value
max value, because I wouldn't know them. Yeah,
directly, I can just look them up. And Java
will tell me then, okay, let's close this
now. And go to our next test. Because now,
what I want to show you is actually, you can
also save your numbers, not only on the base
10, but also on the base to base eight, and
base 16. So now it depends. I don't know,
if you had this already in school or university,
I'm assuming you had, they should be really
easy for you to understand that, for example,
with the base two, you would store you would
display a number would be displayed differently,
then with the base 10. If you never heard
of this, then don't don't mind this really
is not so important. I think I never needed
to display the number in one of these formats,
decimal was always fine to me. I mean, this
is also the way the value will be stored here
on the left side is always the same, no matter
which bass you use. So this might just be
used, because you are in a certain domain
and a certain business area where you need,
for example, the hex. And so you would, for
example, have documentation that speaks of
a hex value. And so you could have the same
value as you have them in the documentation
here in your code, which would make it easier
possibly to look at the code. However, this
has nothing to do with how they're stored.
I mean, they're still stored on your computer
in your memory. And your computer can always
only store them as zeros and ones. So internally,
no matter what format, you use them internally,
they're saved always in the same format. And
by default, they're also when I print them
out, which I'll show you in a sec, they will
also always be printed out on the base of
10 just like a regular number like you know
them. So this is only a displaying issue in
the code. If you want to display them in the
binary format, you need specific formatting
options. This will be an episode on its own.
So I will not go in detail on this. Now. Also,
I think this is not needed in many cases.
What is also interesting, by the way, I mean,
the space two was introduced with Java seven
only. So this only recently got added. Speaking
as of 2015, before, you had only the option
to store, base 10, base eight and base 16.
Now the Edit base two besides to make this
stuff more readable. I mean, especially with
base two, you will get these long strings
here of zeros and ones. So that you could
easily read this. And also for something like
credit card numbers, you can add these underscores
actually as many as ever you want.
You're just not allowed to do it at the beginning
of the string and at the end of the string.
But I mean, I don't see how this would make
any sense, because this wouldn't help to read
it. So this is why you put them here in between,
you can also add more like here. Now the question
is, is that more readable? In this case? Of
course not. But I think it can be quite helpful,
especially for something like credit card
numbers for long numbers that you can read
them more easily, like on the phone talking
to a colleague, and you want to read out the
number nine you can talk about the blogs makes
it easier. But these underscores again, this
is just the displaying issue in the code.
The way they are stored is exactly the same
like before. So now let's execute the test.
So I mean, so that this gets printed out,
and we can have a look at it. Okay, so here
you see the first one ob this just indicates
I'm storing the number in binary. The number
is given in a binary format. So this is just
the zero. You can use the capital and a lowercase
it's supposed to same. So this one is an apple
On this long thing here, so ob four is binary
format, and undo redo Do you do all this,
you can use your calculator and calculate
it. And in the end, you will see this is this
number in decimal format.
Or K.
By the way, of course, just shortly, binary
format means you can't, for example, use a
three, this will give you an error, integer
number two large, because now we are in binary
format, indicated by the B and zero here with
the base eight, and scroll down. It, it started
with a zero only. So zero and seven means
this is a seven now, but 010 is actually the
eight in the on the base of eight. As I said,
if you know it from like school or university,
you will understand what I'm talking about.
If not, doesn't matter. Not important. Yeah,
you will hardly ever need it. Let's have a
look at it. So as I said, this is the seven,
this is the eight. And this is some large
number. So these underscores are not displayed
in here. This is just to help so that it's
more readable in the code. And the base 16
hex code is started with zero and x. And then
the zero is 01. The F, you know in Latin,
no, I think our numbers are not Latin, their
Arabic numbers. And these Arabic numbers,
they are based on the base 10. So nine is
the last number. And when you want to say
10 you need one zero, while on the hex, you
don't have any more Arabic numbers. So therefore
they used ABCDE, F for 10 to 16. So the F
is actually the 16. Let's execute this. Well,
I was lying to you. It's the 15 in this case,
because we start with the zero. No, yeah,
it's the 15. Because the 16 again, would be
one zero. Okay, yeah. can get really easy,
confusing. Sorry. So anyway,
I mean,
I think it's not so important. It's just interesting
to show off. I mean, like in a job interview,
I think you really should know, Java inside
out. And so I think you should know that this
is possible. The question if you personally
will use it, because you personally in your
project will need it. I don't know, depends,
maybe you need it. But if you need it, it's
here to be used. Okay. So now, I think really
did an in depth view on all these small topics.
And I think this is really now a good base
to talk about hashCode and equals. Going to
talk about the two methods equals, and hashCode.
This tutorial actually concludes my presentation
of all the methods of the Java Lang object
class, equals and hashCode both follow a contract
that ties them closely together, which is
also why I'm talking about both methods in
just one episode. Knowing all the details
about these two methods, will make you a better
programmer today. So get yourself some popcorn,
and listen carefully. So let's start with
the equals method. What does it do? What's
it actually useful for? the equals method
is used to compare two objects for equality,
similar to the equals operator, which is used
for primitive values. But before I'm going
into much more detail, let's first jump into
my ID and see this in action. Now in my ID,
let's first of all, see, what do we need the
equals method for anyway, because so far,
we happily used the equal equal operator,
and this was working. Let's see this again,
with two primitive values, I equals four,
and J equals four. So now I assert, with the
equals operator that they're both equal. And
we get the green bar. Old tests passed, everything
is fine. So i equals to J. Now let's do the
same thing with strings. Here we have a constant
value of Hello, and another constant value
Hello. And each has assigned to its own string,
reference variable. Now, we all Want to compare
these two strings with the equal operator?
Let's try this. And Ted Ah, this is also working.
And I told you a string is an object. So as
this is working, it seems we don't need the
equals method at all. Well, with a string,
it's a bit tricky, actually. Because with
a string, there is some optimization going
on in the background for constant values,
because for this constant value, there's actually
only one and both variables, they both point
to the same object in memory. The variable
is stored in a memory area called stack, the
object is stored in a memory area called heap.
And there's only one, but things get quite
differently. As soon as I add a new string
variable, and always say, string hello, three
is only age. And then I say at runtime, hello,
three equals two, hello, three, plus, concatenate
ello to it, which will be Hello, at runtime.
And just to be sure, let's also print this
that we can see there is really Hello. In
the variable, hello, three. And then let's
assert, hello, one, equal operator Hello,
three. And this is not working, we get the
red bar, nasty, nasty. So now they're not
equal. But here you can see it printed out
Hello. So from our expectation it should have
been equal. So this is something really tricky
with string.
And ensured you should not use equal operator
on objects, also not on strings. Instead,
for strings, there is the equals method. Let's
try this. Hello, one equals Hello, three.
This works, it seems like using that method,
they're both equal. Now, let's have a look
actually at the method. Here we are clustering.
And there is a method equals operating on
an object. It says things like if this equals
to the object given return true. So if it's
the same reference, if it's the same object,
this is actually a performance optimization.
Now it checks that the object is actually
a string. This is achieved by the instance
of operator so that we can safely cast the
object to a string. And so that we can compare
both strings. Interesting thing about instance,
of By the way, which not many people, many
developers know, or at least not all, yet.
This also includes a check for now, if an
object is now this will never be a string
will never be true and will return false.
So anyway, without going into further details,
there's this while loop. And this compares
character by character of both strings. And
only if they're completely equal, it will
return true. So this is how equals was implemented
in the class string. But actually, I told
you, the equals method is a method from the
class object. And yes, it is. Well, it turns
out string is also a subclass of object and
the string class overrode the equals method
here. So then it works on strings as expected.
Okay. So it seems like for strings we can
happily use equals, so that we know that a
string like hello one and hello three is equal.
Now, how are things with classes that we implement
ourselves? Like here I have created a class
car with owner Marcos. It is a Porsche and
it is it has the color silver So it seems
like it has both instances have exactly the
same attributes. So I would expect them to
be the same car. Now let's first of all, try
it with the equal operator, like before. And
this is false. It's not working test failed.
Well, of course, because we have two different
instances here. Let's try the positive case.
portion one, equal operator, my Porsche one
again, comparing it to itself. So yes, this
is working, of course. But it seems like for
to be able to compare Porsche one and Porsche
to we again need to use the equals method.
Let's do this now. For sheet one. Oh, let's
first of all, I want to push it to here. But
let's also do this, my portion one equals
my portion one,
I would expect that to be true. And yes, it
is true. My Porsche one, so it is equal to
itself. Now, let's compare my Porsche one
to my Porsche e two. And let's see if this
works. Huh,
it's not working. We have the nasty red bar.
This was so nicely working with a string,
why is it not working with our car? Let's
jump to this method again. And you see, we're
in the class object. Because in our car class,
we have not overwritten the equals method.
So what happens is, the original method of
the class object is used. And as you can see
here, internally, what happens is, we compare
this which is the object itself, in this case,
my pushy one, we compare it using the equal
operator to the object that is coming into
the method, which was pushy to. And this compares
only the reference variables and not the objects.
So this is false, because we have two different
reference variables.
What by the way, is also possible. To make
this true again, we could assign my portion
to the reference variable of my portion one,
which would mean this object is somewhere
in memory, no variable is assigned to it.
And there is this one object
here in this line, and both variables, point
to it. Let's try this. And see if this works.
Because now actually, we only compare the
same object with each other. Like here. This
compares the reference variables, which now
have the same value. So this would be working.
But this is not what we want. So let's remove
that we really want to compare both objects.
We want to compare this one with that one.
Okay, so let's have a look at the class car.
This is a small class I wrote. And it just
has a constructor and these attributes for
now. And there is no equals method overwritten.
So this is what we have to do. Public Boolean
equals now, I want to compare a car car. No,
this you cannot do in the class object. There
is object. So we have to say object here.
And then later on, we have to cast it to a
car, like we saw on the class string.
And then it's always good to add the override
annotation so that we make sure we have properly
overwritten the method. Now, I mean, this
is not a true implementation. I always return
false, just to see that when I'm in my car
test, not jump there. See, it jumps to me.
I overridden method. Now, of course, when
this always returns false, this will also
not work. So we will have to implement it.
But actually implementing such an equals method
is not so easy. And we need some more theory
for this before we can continue. So let's
first of all, jump back to my slides. Before
we are able to implement the equals method,
we need to come up with a proper design first.
Actually, many developers just skip the design
phase, and simply click on autogenerate. But
this may lead to severe bugs, or at least
two sub optimal performance. Let me show you
how you can properly do it. First of all,
you have to define what it is in your specific
program that makes two car instances equal
or unequal. In your program, are two cars
equal when they have the same manufacturer,
maybe when they have the same manufacturer
in color, or the same engine, the same number
of wheels, the same top speed, the same vehicle
identification number, or when In short, based
on a knowledge of the business you are working
in, you have to decide which fields are identifying,
and which fields are redundant, and not helpful
for the equal comparison. Besides for improved
performance, you need to define in which order
you want to compare the attributes. Are there
any fields that have a high chance to be unequal?
Are there fields that may be compared faster
than others? To implement a meaningful equals
method, you must first analyze all these aspects
in great detail. Let's go through this process.
With my example. I would assume that the car's
top speed relates to the type of engine and
some form. So that seems to be a redundant
field, that will not be helpful for the equals
implementation. So let's just remove it. Let's
just say the number of wheels is always for
in our specific example. So number of wheels
would also not help us to differentiate the
car. What about the VIN?
Well,
this again depends on the type of program
you want to create. For a public authority
like the police, this one is probably the
only proper way of identification. But what
about a program used by the manufacturer itself.
While the car is still being built, and not
sold yet, I would assume the witness of less
importance. But I personally wouldn't know
that in detail. This is what you will have
to clarify with the business people of your
company or your department. Based on their
knowledge, you have to select which attributes
to compare in which order. In my artificial
example here, I'm the developer as well as
the business analyst. So for my example, I
just arbitrarily define that two cars with
different wind numbers can be seen as equal.
Therefore, I will not include this field in
my equals comparison later on. Now, before
you think that's it, I'm sorry, there's actually
some more theory to cover. In the introduction,
I already told you that there is a contract
of equals and hashCode we have to fulfill.
First of all, there are five conditions, our
equals implementation has to comply with,
believe me, it looks much more scary than
it actually is. Let's go through each of them
slowly. reflexivity. An object must be equal
to itself, so that when I call my old car
equals my old car, it returns true. I think
this makes sense and should be easy to understand.
symmetry to objects must agree whether or
not they are equal. If my old car equals some
other car, then some other car equals my old
car must also return true This sounds obvious
and very simple, when in fact, it is not such
a simple condition when it comes to inheritance.
If you have a car class and a BMW class, which
is extending the car class, it could happen
that your BMW is equal to a car. But the same
car is not equal to the BMW is every BMW is
a car. But not every car is a BMW. So you
see, the symmetry rule can actually lead to
some nasty problems. There are quite a few
interesting articles online discussing potential
symmetry issues of the equals method. cover
each contract condition with a dedicated unit
test to make sure your class is fully compliant
with a contract. Our next condition is transitivity.
If one object is equal to our second, and
a second is equal to a third, then the first
must be equal to the third again. This rule
sounds much more complicated than it actually
is. If object A is equal to object B, and
object b is equal to object C, they should
all be equal to each other so that C is also
equal to a consistency. If two objects are
equal, they must remain equal for all time,
unless one of them is changed. So when you
repeatedly compare the same two objects with
a equals method, it should always return the
same result. In other words, calling the equals
method should not alter the object in any
way. The last rule model returns false is
what Josh Bloch calls nonlocality. When knowledge
is given as a parameter to any equals method,
they should always return false and never
throw a null pointer exception. So now, you
know quite a bit about the equals method.
But what is the hashCode method actually useful
for? For processing similar objects are usually
put into a collection. Such a collection in
Java is like a more powerful array, or an
array on steroids, as I often call it.
Besides other things, it allows you to look
up objects not only based on their index position,
but also based on their specific values. This
is where the equals method comes into play.
To speed up this lookup process, the Java
creators added specific hash based containers
that will use the hash value as a grouping
mechanism to reduce the number of equal comparisons
needed. In the optimal case, each object that
is considered unequal by the equal method
will also return a different hash code. This
hash code is used to group the objects in
so called buckets. Now, in this optimal case,
you will be able to find each object simply
by a lookup based on its hash value. However,
there may also be something called hash collisions,
where two unequal objects will share the same
hash code, in which case they end up in the
same bucket. Now, if I'm looking for that
scar, I have to look up the correct bucket
based on the hash code minus 391. That car
will return. However, as there is a hash collision,
I will on top have to do an equals comparison
on a list of two cars in this case, illegal
but inadmissible bad performing hash code
implementation could statically returned 42
for all objects. In this case, however, the
whole hashCode logic would not help at all.
In the end, you would have to do an equals
comparison on the entire list of cars just
as if the hashing logic had never existed.
Okay. Now that I have talked about the general
idea of the hashCode method, I have to further
tell you about the contract that the hashCode
method has to fulfill. The first condition
that has to be fulfilled by the hashCode method
is for any two objects return same hash codes
when equals returns true. To achieve this,
use the same idea Define attributes for both
methods in the same order. Don't worry too
much. Now, if you don't fully understand what
I mean. As soon as I'm finished introducing
you to the hashCode contract, I will jump
back in my ID and show you a practical example.
When hashCode is invoked more than once on
the same object, it must consistently return
the same int value as long as the object is
not changed. This role is similar to the equals
consistency rule, I introduced to before both
equals and hashCode methods must return consistent
results. To fulfill this contract, you should
override hashCode whenever you override equals,
and vice versa. Also, when you add or remove
attributes from your class, you will most
probably also have to adjust your equals and
hashCode methods. Last but not least, aim
to return different hash codes when equals
returns false. This is not a hard and fast
rule, but it will improve the performance
of your program by minimizing the number of
hash collisions. to the extreme, the hash
code contract would allow to statically return
42 for all objects, as Josh block states in
his book Effective Java, however, this could
result in quadratic rather than linear execution
time, and therefore, could be the difference
between working and not working. Actually,
the hashCode method is a rather complicated
beast, I couldn't practically fit in all the
details without risking that you would fall
asleep. Therefore, I have done a follow up
tutorial, that will give you an in depth view
on the hashCode method, which you will need
to understand to become an expert in Java
programming. Below this video, there's a link,
you can click to watch my follow up tutorial
for the hashCode method. For now, that's all
the theory, you need to be able to implement
your own hashCode and equals methods. to round
up this topic, let's jump back into my ID
to show you some practical examples of hashCode
and equals methods. So back to my ID II, you
can see I've implemented both equals, and
hashCode based on the fields manufacturer,
engine, and color, also here and hashCode,
manufacturer, engine, and color. So I've implemented
them based on the decisions I made during
the simulated design phase that I did during
the theory session. So the car clause has
fields like Vehicle Identification Number,
Manufacturer, engine, color, and number of
wheels. But in the design phase, I decided
that number of wheels and Vehicle Identification
Number are not helpful for the way I want
to compare a car. Of course, this is totally
arbitrary. So this is not how you would do
it. I really can't stress that enough. In
your case, in reality, you have to talk to
the business people and find out what is important
and what is not. Also totally arbitrary is
the order that I've chosen. I just thought
about it. And I thought that while there are
millions, or however many colors that for
usually for cars, there are not so many colors.
I think most cars are either black or white,
silver, blue, red. A few might even be green,
or yellow. But that's probably it. So I thought
they there are probably more different manufacturers,
and also more different engines. And I want
the equals method. If I compare two objects
which are not equal, I want to leave the method
as early as possible, because the earlier
I leave the method, the faster the entire
code will run. If two instances are equal,
then usually it has to go till the very end.
So in this case, it doesn't make a difference.
But it does make a difference if it's not
equal. If we can leave the method here. So
for perform performance optimization I have
chosen this order
on.
So this is what I would also ask you to do,
think about a good order to improve the performance.
And if the performance is important, then
you should test it, because you never know
for sure until you test for the performance.
What is important that the order is the same
hashCode and equals. And now, we should also
talk about all this stuff here on top. This
mostly is also a performance optimization,
at least here, this equals object. So, if
I compare the object to itself, I want to
directly return true, because then the reference
variable references the same object in memory.
And so I directly know it's the same object,
I don't have to compare all these things.
So, this is why I have this here. If you have
a specific case, where you know that you will
never ever compare an object to itself, you
might even leave this if a way. Yeah, this
is the this depends. Generally, this is done,
because such a check doesn't also cost a lot,
then this object equals null return false
is actually very important here. This is the
last rule that we have to fulfill that when
an object that we compare is now that we always
return false, which is also important because
otherwise object dot get class would throw
a null pointer exception that this cannot
happen, because now we are already, we have
already left the equals method with false.
Okay. And then the third, if check compares
both classes. So that we make sure that the
object that is coming in to all equals method
is also a car. So that we're not comparing
bikes and cars, for example, or cars and apples
or whatever, right? Because otherwise, also,
this explicit cast to car would also throw
a class cast exception. But now that we have
made sure that they both have the car class,
we can safely caused the object to a car.
And now I think this is quite interesting.
Because now I can easily say manufacturer
equals other dot manufacturer. This field
here is private. But because we are here in
car, even though that this is another instance,
but it's also an instance of car, I can directly
access this private field. So I don't have
to use any method, I can directly access the
field. This works and makes the code I think,
much more readable and shorter. So if it's
not equal, then I can directly leave the method
and say return false. I do this with all the
fields. And if I'm here, that I'm sure that
all the three fields are equal. So I do not
compare number of wheels as well as we equal
identification number, because as I said,
about them, I don't care because number of
wheels, in my specific example would always
be four. So would be the same anyway. And
we equal identification number, that might
be two different cars. But just like, if I'm
only interested in the price of a car, for
example, or the look, then I wouldn't care
that actually, they are physically two different
cars. I would just say well, this is a BMW
with I don't know, that kind of engine and
Lou. So for me, this is the same car. Period.
Yeah. Okay, so that much for the equals method.
Now the hashCode method. This is actually
very complicated, I'm sorry, and it's so complicated
that I've decided to do a follow up tutorial,
as said before, which I really recommend you
to watch. There is a link below this video,
you can click to watch the follow up. So he
only in short about the hashCode method. The
31 year is a prime number and a prime number
he is multiplied with always the result. So
this continues to take the hash code of a
field, which will return some in number
will edit, starting with one, and then multiply
it with 31. And this for each attribute. The
reason is this is an optimization to have
less collisions, because I told you about
the collisions, that this can decrease the
performance. As you see, I'm actually not
really doing something here, I'm just calling
recursively hashCode for each class. And this
is why now we should jump in the other classes,
at least, I can show you all the classes,
but I've chosen engine here in this case,
to see how it's actually hashCode implemented
in one example. So let's jump to engine. Okay,
so the equals method is pretty much the same,
or at least similar. Then in car, the only
difference is here, I added something that
I called optional field, because I defined
that this optional field could also be now.
So therefore, my check here for equals has
to be a bit more complicated. Because I have
to save it's now then I check if the other
field is also now, if it's not now, then this
field is now the other is not so it's not
equal. And if it's not now, then I can compare
both fields. So I'm doing all this again to
prevent another pointer exception. In the
other case, when I don't check for now, my
assumption is that, well, this is a primitive
field, so it can't be null anyway, but for
car, my assumption was that a car always needs
a manufacturer, engine and a color. So my
assumption is, those fields will never be
now, if someone would introduce a bug. And
would forget to set these fields then, of
course, this could produce a nullpointerexception.
But checking for something that is exceptional.
This is what I call rocket code. Because it's
like extra safe code, this is just cluttering
your code, you have to have certain assumptions,
like saying mighty sign for bits that these
fields, these fields can never be now. And
so I trust on that. Otherwise, well, the program
will crash, okay, we have to fix it. But then
the problem is already fixed. And the code
stays clean. And this is important, because
your code should be really readable and maintainable.
Okay, so only four fields where you know,
they can be null at these extra null checks.
Okay. So that much for the equals method,
everything else here should be the same as
in car. Now for the hashCode method. Here,
you see there is some more stuff going on.
Because here, I cannot forward to a hash code
method. But instead, I have here a primitive
long. And for that, because the primitive
fields there, you actually have to calculate
some hash code. And this is a long, and so
we want to like convert a long to an int.
A long has that has like 64 bits, while an
int has only 32 bits. So you want to like
make the long to half its size, and you want
to make it in a way that will result in the
least possible number of collisions. And therefore,
this weird line here. This here does it. This
is actually based on again, Josh blocks book
Effective Java there, he explains it. One,
actually, he doesn't explain it too much.
If you want an in depth explanation again,
watch my follow up tutorial about hash code
there, I can explain you. Now here only insured.
This is a shift by 32 bits. And then this
is an X or Y you again, come like let's say
combine this field. And last but not least,
you do an exquisite cast from long to end
where you throw away Half of the long, but
this whole thing can't explain you in like
one minute, you have to watch really the extended
tutorial. But this is really a very performant
good way to create an end hash code from alarm.
This is the standard default way of how this
is done today.
And the second field here is a string as it
can be now, I need this extra knowledge check.
And I'm not sure if I have shown you this
before. This is like in if it's just shorter,
because otherwise the code would even be longer.
So you have to read it as is optional field
now. If true, then return zero, else return
optional field dot hashCode. So this again
calls the hashCode method of string. This
I showed you in the beginning of this episode,
where the code was like in a while loop, going
over each character of the string, and then
calculating an int value for the string. So
as this is already done for us, we can simply
call the hashCode method. Okay. So, again,
you also see, I have, in this case, two fields.
And in this case, I decided to use both to
differentiate if an engine is equal or not.
And so as I use type an optional field and
equals, again, I use type an optional field
and hashCode in the same order and same fields.
Okay, last but not least, some class now this
is this doesn't mean anything, this is really
totally abstract, I just wanted to it very
short, show you all the different primitive
types they are plus the string object. So
that you see like how the different cases
of equals and hashCode could be calculated.
So let's first of all look at hash code. So
this with long we have already seen, same
one here, float, well float has the same size
32 bits like an end. And then there is a native
function, which will convert the float to
an int to be used for the hashCode. Double
A has the same length as a long. So this is
done in two steps. First of all, it's converted,
again, with a native function too long. A
native function is a function that is not
implemented in Java, but in machine dependent
code. So I can't show you. But again, for
details, watch my follow up tutorial. But
anyway, so long we take and again, we do this
weird line here to convert it to an end. Next
one Boolean. Here again, this weird stuff
here. If it's true, question mark, then 1231.
And if it's not true, then take this number.
All this stuff is really technical might be
a bit hard for you to understand. This is
just really important for performance optimization
to have the least number of collisions. Um,
car is just taken as it is because it can
be handled like a number. For string again,
we call this hashCode method. And for the
other fields, everything that is as big as
an end or smaller than an end, that's relatively
easy because you can just take the value as
it is because a byte will always fit into
an end short will always fit into an end.
And an end of course, should also fit into
an end our K so I know this was really rough
really short. I'm just not enough time to
go in more details. But exactly For this reason,
I have done the follow up tutorial you can
watch. I hope then it will be more easy to
understand. Now last but not least, let's
have a look also at equals. So I think for
the primitive values here, it's pretty easy
because you don't have to use equals If you
can just use the not equal operator.
So if it's if the bytes are not equal, just
looking at the variables without any objects
involved, false is returned. And also see
this is the order I've chosen, I start with
the smallest possible values, because here
checking them is probably faster than doing
all this crazy stuff down here. And this is
why I've chosen the order. All K, with a short
end, long, this is all easy. With float, it's
a bit more difficult, we have to convert it
first to an end, that will has to be converted
to a long, um, Boolean is, again, easy. Well,
actually, if this was a real whoops, if this
was a real implementation, I would have done
it differently, I would have put it to the
top. So this order is also based to explain
you the different types. So in reality, I
would ask you to really think about the order
based on what the business tells you what
is easy to differentiate. And like, then also
you have to think, like, from the performance,
what takes longer to calculate. Um, of course,
it depends if you really need the performance.
And if you do, then always test performance,
because you might think something is fast.
But when you tested, it turns out, it's not
as fast as he would have thought, okay, because
what I'm telling you here is just a rule of
thumb, but I might be totally wrong in a specific
case. So this is also what I'm doing, if I
need a certain performance, I test for it.
In all other cases, I just do how I feel like
it. Or I just use my gut feeling to sort the
values, as I think could be fitting out. Okay,
so I hope you liked this episode about hashCode.
And equals I'm sorry that this is all so complicated
and so long. I just wanted to put in everything
possible, because this is really such an important
topic that he should really understand in
detail. Of course, there is way more actually.
So I would also ask you go to my blog, www
dot Marquess minor spiel.com. I will put up
some links to some extended articles on the
topic on and also you might consider buying
Effective Java from Drush blog, he also talks
about it quite extensively. So
here
I will give you a high level introduction
to the Java collections framework. Unfortunately,
there are several overloaded uses of the word
collection. Let me clarify the various meanings
up front. The different use cases are a collection
without any it relevance as a compilation
or group of things. Second, the Java collections
framework, a library of different interfaces
and classes. Third, a collection as a data
structure. Think of a box or container that
can hold a group of objects, like an array,
for example. For us, the Java collections
interface, one of the two main interfaces
of the Java collections framework, and fifths,
Java util collections, or utility class that
will help you to modify or operate on Java
collections. This episode is based on chapter
11 of the OCA OCP study guide. The book is
packed with knowledge. As a great fan of the
author is Kathy Sierra and Bert Bates. I recommend
you to read this book, even when you don't
plan to get a certified programmer. So what
is the Java collections framework? from a
high level perspective? First of all, it's
more like a library a toolbox of generic interfaces
and classes. This toolbox contains Various
collection interfaces and classes that serve
as a more powerful object oriented alternative
to arrays, collection related utility interfaces
and classes that assist you in using the collections.
I'm going to describe both parts in detail
now. On the next slides, you will see the
interface and class hierarchy for collections.
Unlike arrays, all collections can dynamically
grow or shrink in size. Except before a collection
can hold a group of objects, a map can store
pairs of objects that have some kind of relation,
which ties them together, named key and value.
A value
does not have a specific position in this
map, but can be retrieved with the key it
is related to relax if you don't get it now.
We will look at it in more detail later on.
So here you see the hierarchy of classes and
interfaces, extending or implementing the
collections interface. Just try to remember
some of the names listed here. This is just
an overview so far. As you can see, the collection
interface sits on top of a number of sub interfaces
and implementing classes. A collection can
hold a group of objects, the collection interface
is extended by the interface of set list and
queue. A set is defined as a group of unique
objects. What is considered as unique is defined
by the equals method of the object type the
set holds. So in other words, a set cannot
hold to equal objects. A list is defined as
a sequence of objects. So unlike a set, a
list can contain duplicate entries. Besides
a list keeps its elements in the order, they
were inserted into the list. A queue has two
sides, entries are added to the end and removed
from the top of the queue. This is often described
as first in first out, which is pretty much
like a waiting line in real life works. The
first person queueing up will also be the
first person leaving the queue. Now let's
have a closer look at the interfaces and classes
that extend or implement the set interface.
Hash set linked hash set and three set are
all implementing the set interface. Hash set
is the default implementation that is used
in the majority of cases. Linked hash set
is like a mix of a hash set and the list as
it does not allow duplicate entries like a
set. But it returns its elements in the order
in which they were inserted. Like your list
would do. Chrisette will constantly keep all
its elements in sorted order. But keep in
mind, there is no free lunch. So every edit
feature comes at a certain Cost Of course.
After looking at the classes implementing
the set interface, let's also have a look
at the two extending interfaces we haven't
talked about yet. As the name implies, sorted
set is a set that is constantly sorted. The
navigate will set interface was added which
Java six, it allows to navigate through the
sorted list. For example, it provides methods
to retrieve the next element greater or smaller
than a given element of the set. Next, let's
have a closer look at the classes that implement
the list interface. Every list is the default
implementation of the list interface. Like
any list implementation, it does allow duplicate
elements and it does allow to iterate the
list in the order of insertion. As it is based
on arrays, it is very fast to iterate and
read from an every list. But adding or removing
an element at a random position is very slow,
as this will require to rebuild the underlying
array structure. vector is a class that exists
since JDK one which is even before the collection
framework, which was added with Java two.
In short, its performance is sub optimal.
So So please never use it. Use ArrayList or
linked list instead. So let's directly remove
it and forget about it. The next list implementation
is linked list. As the name implies, its implementation
is based on a linked list, which makes it
easy to add or remove elements at any position
in the list. Last but not least, let's have
a look at the classes implementing the queue
interface. We already talked about link list,
as it also implements the list interface.
However, the fact that it's based on a double
linked list makes it quite easy to
also implement the queue interface. linked
list is the default queue implementation.
priority queue is a queue implementation that
keeps its elements automatically ordered.
It has similar functionality like a tree set,
but it does allow duplicate entries. Now let's
look at the map interface. This interface
has no relation to the collection interface.
A collection operates on one entity, while
a map operates on two entities. A unique key,
for example, a vehicle identification number,
and an object that is related to this key
for example, a car object with the help of
the key you can retrieve the object it relates
to. The interface map is the root of a lot
of interfaces and classes, which we'll look
at now. The class hash table was the first
collection in Java JDK one that was based
on a data structure hash table. So the Java
creators called a hash table. Unfortunately,
this makes it a bit hard to differentiate
between the two. Like vector the class is
deprecated, because of its sub optimal performance,
so let's also remove it and forget about it.
Instead, use one of the other classes that
implement the map interface. hashmap is the
default implementation that you should use
in the majority of cases. A map usually does
not make any guarantees on how it internally
stores its elements. An exception to this
rule is linked hash map, which allows to iterate
the map in the order of insertion. Last but
not least, tree map is a constantly sorted
map. Now let's look at the interfaces that
extend the map interface. As the name implies,
the interface sorted map extends the map interface
and defines the contract of a constantly sorted
map. navigable map again extends the sorted
map interface, and adds methods to navigate
through the map. This allows you to retrieve
all entries smaller or bigger than a given
entry, for example. Actually, there are many
similarities between the map and the set hierarchy.
The reason is that the set implementations
are actually internally backed by a map implementation.
Last but not least, you might have noticed
the Java collection classes often contain
the data structure there are based on in their
name. To choose the best collection for a
given situation, you have to compare the specific
characteristics of data structures like array,
linked list, hash table or tree first. In
short, there is no single best option. Each
one has its very own advantages and disadvantages.
I promise to talk about this very exciting
topic in a later episode. So stay tuned. This
overview of the collection and map classes
that only show you a part of the whole story.
In a later episode, I will introduce you to
the concurrent containers of the Java collections
framework. generics is a topic at least as
big as the Java collections framework. In
the context of this episode, I will therefore
only explain you the bare minimum you need
to understand the collections framework. It's
okay if you have a lot of open questions after
my brief overview. Give both of us some time.
I promise to explain everything one after
the other I would recommend you to subscribe
to my YouTube channel to be informed as soon
as I upload the next episodes of the Java
collections framework. Now fasten your seat
belts. Here, it's going to be a bumpy ride,
I promise. You see this weird stuff in angular
brackets. Just relax. Actually, it's much
easier than you might think. And the first
line, you see I have defined a list variable
my list. And with a string parameter in ANGEL
brackets, I tell the compiler that my main
list reference variable is supposed to be
used only with strings.
Then I create an object of type ArrayList.
And again, I tell the compiler that this object
is only supposed to be used with strings,
and the compiler will ensure that no one ever
tries to put anything else than a string into
my list. In other words, this is what makes
the container type safe. Also, note that I
use the interface list for the variable and
not ArrayList. This makes your code more flexible.
Only at one place you create the object, but
at various places in your code, he will use
it. When you use list instead of error list
for the reference variable. You could later
replace the error list by a linked list, for
example. And all
you had to adjust was this one line of code.
In case you don't really need to specific
methods of a list,
you could also use the collection interface
instead. Always use the least specific interface
for the reference variable. Oh, by the way,
I'm sure you notice the integer 100 that I
use as a constructor argument. This I have
added for performance optimization. As said
before, the collection classes can dynamically
grow and shrink in size. However, aerialist
and all hash table based collections are internally
operating on arrays. When an array based collection
grows in size, it will internally on the fly,
create a larger array and transfer all contents
from the old to the new array. This of course
takes some extra time. What on hardware is
so fast, that is usually should not be a problem.
But on the other side, if you already know
the exact, or at least the approximate size
of your error based collection, this is usually
better than trusting on the collections default
size. In the next episodes, I will look at
the data structures that the Java collections
are based on, which will help you to better
understand performance considerations like
this one. However, to me, taking care of such
small little details, makes the difference
between a developer and a software craftsman.
So I wanted to let you know as early as possible.
Okay, enough, blah, blah, blah.
Let's get back to the topic of generics. Now
in the second line, you see how a hashmap
is instantiated accordingly. As said before,
a map is basically a relation of one identifying
key to one value element. Both these elements
can be of different types. Like you in my
example, I use Vin, the vehicle identification
number as the key and the car object as the
value. This has to be added as a comma separated
list in ANGEL brackets. And the compiler again
will check that this holds true. If you create
the instance reference variable and the object,
both in one line, you can also leave the second
pair of angel brackets empty, as it can be
inferred from the generic type of the reference
variable. This was introduced with Java seven
and is called the diamond operator. Because
the empty Angel brackets in a way, look like
a diamond. Actually, I'm sorry. That's not
the whole story. There are two parts. And
what I just showed you. This was actually
part two, the usage or invocation of a generic
class when you lock in the contract parameter
to be used. But this is only possible if the
method, the interface or the class was defined
to be used in a generic way beforehand. Here
you see a generically defined interface. In
the first line, the interface is defined as
an interface operating on two separate generic
types that have to be specified at a later
time. However, when these types are locked
in, this will automatically also specify the
type, the types, interface methods we'll use.
So, if you see some weird one letter types
in one of the next slides, just remember it
means this is a method that can be used in
a generic way. Okay, now we are ready to look
at some additional utility interfaces of the
Java collections framework. They are implemented
by classes of the collections framework or
the JDK in general, but they can also be implemented
by your own classes, making use of the power
of the collections framework. Well, strictly
speaking, the interface Java Lang iterable
is not part of the framework. But more precisely,
it sits on top of it. It is the super interface
of Java util collection. So every class that
implements Java util collection, will also
implement the Java Lang iterable interface.
Okay, anyway, let's now look at each interface
in detail. an iterator is an object that acts
like a remote control to iterate through a
collection. Let's look at its methods. Boolean
has next returns true if the collection has
more elements. ie next returns the next element
in the iteration. And void remove removes
the last element returned by this iterator
from the underlying Collection. This interface
provides only one method, which will return
an iterator every collection that implements
this interface can be used on the for each
loop, which greatly simplifies the usage of
your homemade collection. In order to plug
in your collection into the for each loop,
you will have to execute two simple steps.
First create an iterator that is able to iterate
over your collection with methods like hasnext.
And next, as we saw on the last slide. Second,
you need to implement the iterable interface
by adding an iterator method that will return
an instance of this iterator implementing
the interface Java Lang comparable defines
a sort order for your entities. The interface
contains only one method you need to implement
which is int compared to if you want to define
a natural sort order for an entity class,
make it implement this interface. return a
negative integer if the object is less than
a given method argument, zero if the object
is equal to the given method argument, and
a positive integer if the object is greater
than the given method argument. What means
smaller or greater is for you to define. For
numbers, that would probably mean that one
is smaller than five, for example. But for
colors, This all depends on how you want to
sort your entities. When you put objects of
an entity that implements the comparable interface,
into a tree set or tree map, it will use your
compare to method to automatically sort all
elements you put into the collection. As you
can see, the Java collections framework has
been greatly designed for extension. It offers
a lot of possibilities to plug in your own
classes. This interface is very similar to
the comparable interface. It allows you to
define additional sorting orders like a reverse
ordering. So the sorting logic is not directly
implemented in your entity, but in an external
sorting strategy class that can optionally
be added to a collection or sorting method
to the Find an alternative sorting order for
your collection of entities. The rules of
the interface contract are pretty much the
same as for comparable. return a negative
integer if the first argument is less than
the second argument, zero if both arguments
are equal, and a positive integer if the first
argument is greater than the second. Last
but not least, let's look at the two utility
classes, collections and arrays, like a Swiss
Army knife. They provide static helper methods
that greatly enhance the general usefulness
of the collection classes. Java util collections
offers methods like sword shuffle, reverse
search, min or max. And Java util arrays operates
on areas and not on collections actually,
similar to the collections class, it allows
us to swap areas or to search through areas
for example, I'm going to take an in depth
look at ArrayList. And the second half, I'll
do a practical coding session. Okay, let's
get started. Error list is the default implementation
of the list interface. As with any implementation
of list, you can have duplicate elements in
your array list. And you can go from element
to element in the same order as the elements
were inserted. As it is based on Aries, aerialist
provides fast access, but inserting or removing
an element at a random position requires more
time, as this will require to reorganize the
list. fast access however, is crucial for
most applications, which is why ArrayList
is the most commonly used collection. to store
data that changes frequently. However, consider
using an alternative container, for example
linked list. I will talk about this as well
as other containers in the upcoming episodes
of my free Java video course. Okay, before
I continue, let me introduce you to two different
terms, which are important to understand in
context with error list, size and capacity.
Size is the number of elements the ArrayList
currently holds. For every element you add
to the list, the size will grow by one capacity
or ever, it's the number of elements the currently
underlying array can hold. The capacity of
the array list grows in intervals. The error
list starts with an initial capacity. Every
time you exceed the capacity of the array,
the ArrayList copies the data over to a new
array that is about 50% larger than the previous
one. Let's say you want to add 100 elements
to an aerialist have an initial capacity of
10. As the list grows, the system will create
six more areas
to take the place of the first. First one
area that can hold 15 elements, then one for
a maximum of 22 elements. Then areas with
a capacity of 3349 73 and finally 109 elements
to hold the growing list. These restructuring
arrangements can negatively impact performance,
you can instantly create an array of the correct
size to minimize these merging activities
by defining the correct capacity at creation
time. In case you don't know the final size
of the ArrayList at creation time, estimated
as close as possible. Choosing a too large
capacity however, can also negatively impact
performance. So choose this value carefully.
I advise you to always explicitly set the
capacity at creation time as a documents your
intentions. For most projects, you won't have
to worry about optimizing performance to too
powerful hardware. But this is no excuse for
sloppy design and poor implementation. Here
you can see a simplified extract of the class
aerialist. Keep in mind, the real class looks
a bit more complicated. This is just meant
to give you a more concrete idea of what the
class ArrayList looks like. As you can see,
error list is just a class anyone could have
written. Given enough time and knowledge,
there is no black magic, you can find the
actual source code online. However, don't
rely too much on internals that you spot them
the source code as they may change any time
if they're not defined in the Java language
specification. Default capacity is the initial
size of the array, when you don't specify
it as I recommended before element data is
the array used to store the elements of the
ArrayList in size is the number of elements
the ArrayList currently holds get add and
remove are some of the many functions ArrayList
provides, we will look at those methods now.
So, let me give you a short overview of the
methods of the ArrayList class. To make things
easy for you, I have broken up the overview
into methods belonging to the Java util collection
interface, and methods belonging to the Java
util list interface. When I talk about other
containers in later episodes, implementing
the list or the collection interface, I will
refer back to this episode. Instead of repeating
myself over and over again. Make sure you
are subscribed to my YouTube channel. So you
will be informed when I release episodes about
these classes also. Okay, so let's start with
the methods belonging to the Java util collection
interface. The contract of the collection
interface does not guarantee any particular
order, and therefore does not provide any
index or order related methods. So here you
can see the first set of methods that implement
the collection interface. So what I say about
these methods does not only apply to ArrayList,
but also to all classes that implement the
collection interface. The method Boolean ad
appends the element to the end of the collection
to the next empty cell of the underlying array.
Boolean at all appends all given elements
to the end of the collection. The stuff in
ANGEL brackets is related to generics. In
short, it ensures that no one can call such
a method with the wrong arguments. From now
relax. I will tell you more in my upcoming
episode about generics. Boolean remove removes
the first occurrence of the element you specify
from the collection. Boolean remove all removes
the given elements from the collection. The
iterator method returns an object usually
use an a loop to move from one element to
the next element of the collection. Step by
step you say I iterate over the collection.
Hence the name iterator. incise returns the
number of elements of the collection. Boolean
contains returns true if the collection contains
at least one instance of the element you specify.
Wide clear removes all elements from the collection.
Boolean is empty. This returns true if the
collection contains no elements. And to array
returns an array containing all of the elements
of the collection.
Alright, let's move on to the methods of the
Java util list interface. The methods are
similar in part to the methods we just looked
at, but they differ in that they require an
order on the elements of the list. So here
again, you should know that everything I say
about these methods does not only apply to
every list, but to all classes that implement
the list interface. This add method with an
index parameter. It's actually more like an
insert method. It allows you to insert an
element at any index position of the list.
Instead of just adding the element to the
end of the list. And the process the elements
of the underlying array will be shifted to
the right and migrated to a larger array if
necessary. The remove index method allows
to remove an element from any index position
of the Similar to the Add method we just looked
at, this might require to shift the remaining
elements of the underlying array to the left.
The get by index method returns an element
from any given position of the list. The index
off method takes an object and returns the
index of the first occurrence of the element
in the list, or minus one if the element is
not found. In last index of returns the index
of the last occurrence of the element in the
list, and SP four minus one if the element
is not found. List sub list returns a view
of the list starting with the position you
specify as from index and ending one possession
before the one you specify as to index. Last
but not least, the sword method sorts the
list following the order of the given comparator.
Alright, so let's end the lecture session,
time to move on to some practical coding.
So now I'm in my early and you can see I have
prepared a little test method. So we can do
some practical coding with ArrayList. I have
already created an instance of ArrayList.
And I've assigned it to a reference variable
of type collection. Now, this might be a bit
counterintuitive at first, because why is
that not ArrayList? Or at least list. While
there is a reason to it. And let me cite Robert
C. Martin, he says, a good architecture is
one that maximizes the number of decisions
not made, or the number of decisions D fared.
And this is such a situation, because by making
this collection,
I mean, you would create this instance for
a reason, of course, and you probably would
forward it to either other methods and or
other objects. So now, if you make this an
ArrayList, this will really limit all your
other objects, because they all only have
to work on an ArrayList. But now, the requirements
of your business, I mean, requirements, usually
they change very fast as you know. And if
they change, like for example, an ArrayList
can hold duplicate elements. But now there
might be a new requirement that tells you,
you cannot have duplicate elements, you have
to prevent that you have duplicate elements.
So you might want to use hash set here. Now,
if you use list or every list everywhere in
the code, it will be very tough to change
your mind, you will have to touch a lot of
code, which is very dangerous. But if this
is a collection, a collection can be so so
many things. And so it will be much easier
to change your mind. Because all you will
have to do is change the instantiation of
the object that is actually being used. So
if you can, like of course, this limits the
number of functions that you can use, because
the collection interface is less powerful
than the list or the error list interface.
But if you can, like if you only need the
methods of the collection interface, well
then do it like this. later on. We will switch
here to a list interface because I will also
show you methods that only appear in the list
interface. But we'll start with a reference
variable of type collection. And then you'll
also see the difference. Okay, what else can
you see in the single line? Besides you might
spot that have used generics in the angel
brackets, so we have created a collection
of type string. And here, you might spot the
so called diamond operator that was introduced
with Java seven. Well, because we do both
in one line, we do the object instantiation.
And we create the reference variable in one
line. The compiler directly sees this must
be a string. And this is why here we can use
the diamond operator. But we could also do
it the old way by typing here string. This
is just a bit shorter. Okay, and last but
not least, you should notice here I wrote
initial capacity, which is a constant, which
I have defined here as private final int,
initial capacity five. Now you might say well,
you could have also said just five I mean,
this is faster. Well, at first, it might seem
so but this is a so called magic number. And
this is evil, because it makes it so much
harder for the next developer to know what
this five actually means. Like not everyone
knows that an aerialist has an initial capacity.
But if you use the constant value here, you
document in the code your intentions. So this
is actually quite good. And I recommend you
to do it also. Okay, but now let's already
start using some methods. I mean, we're not
doing I'm not going to properly program something,
but we're just playing around with the methods,
so you get a better feeling of like what aerialist
is all about. And as this is now, a collection
reference very Oh, of course, you'll only
see all the methods of the collection interface.
And we'll start simple with ADD. Of course,
like one limitation that we have now is we
don't see any index based methods, which was
also the reason why before in my slides, I
divided the methods into methods that are
related to the collection interface, and methods
that are related to the list interface. Because
now I can also go back to the slides and compare,
because now we're doing the methods of the
collection interface. So this is a collection
of type string, so I can add a string. So
let's add B, capital B. Let's add some more.
A
later on, I'm also planning to sort the error
list, which aerialists allows. But right now,
with the collection reference variable, we
will not be able to sort it. But stay tuned.
I'll do it soon. Oh, okay. And I mean, even
though we have a reference variable of type
collection, still, the fact that we have an
ArrayList influences that we can have duplicate
elements. So let's do that. Maybe I should
also add one eight here. Okay, and now let's
count how many numbers elements I added 123456,
the initial capacity or ever is five. So that
means when you add the sixth element, internally,
within the execution of this method, the error
list will realize, well, the capacity is insufficient,
will then create a new array of a larger size,
and will then migrate all the existing data
to the new array. Before the next element,
the second he is added, which costs some extra
time. But really don't worry, I mean, in the
regular situation like this five, six elements,
the performance difference is altra altra.
Low. So never, I'm never worry, in such situations,
this should really be only, like only think
about this when it gets a problem. And usually,
this could get a problem if you have like
1000s or 10s of 1000s, if not a million of
elements. So it always depends on the amount
of elements, you have the amount of iterations
that you do. Okay. So and then we can also
print the error list as it is now, there are
two different ways ArrayList has also a two
string method. So I could directly say system,
out print ln elements. But I'm doing it a
bit more complicated, because I want to show
you how we actually iterate over the ArrayList.
And this is because every list, and every
collection implements the iterable interface,
which is used in this new for each loop. And
so we can iterate over the array list by saying
string string, and then column and then elements.
And what is required to iterate over this
list will be done here inside and you don't
see it. This is all done by the compiler for
us internally. In short, I can tell you, there
is an iterator method that I showed you showed
Before, which will then be used. You might
also check my last episode where I introduced
you to the iterable. And the iterator interface,
both will be used here. For now. I mean, it's
enough, if you see, you can use the ArrayList
and the for each loop. And now we can print
out each element separately, which of course
gives us a bit more flexibility. Like I could
print something else here also. Okay. So this
is called iteration going over the collection,
element by element. And I also want to show
you, let's comment this, oops, let's comment
this out. I also want to show you that which
is a feature of list, this order, how we added
the elements, AB AC E, will be also exactly
the same order as the elements are printed
out, which would be different if we had a
set. Okay, but enough of talking, let's already
execute it and see it in action.
Okay, so here you see a B, A, C, E, exactly
like we added that, which is a feature of
list. Okay, now that we added elements, we
could also remove some elements, which is
also just as easy we move. And now on the
collection interface, I can't remove by index.
But I can remove by stating the object that
I want to be removed, which by the way, internally
uses the equals method. If you don't know
about the equals method, I also have a video
about the equals method. So it goes over each
element and checks by using equals, which
is implemented in the string class. If there's
a is equal to one of those elements here,
and will then remove it. You might also notice
I have two A's. So now it's interesting to
know, like will the first a be removed will
the second AB removed of or both be removed?
And there is another tip I have for you. Like
if you have such questions, you can look for
a book for video tutorial, you can look in
the API and so on and so forth. But you will
never be as Sure. And probably also never
be as fast if you just write a simple test
like this. And you just try it out for yourself.
I mean, how pragmatic How cool is that? Because
the code doesn't lie. If you see it, he will
be sure that it behaves like you can see it.
So let's do this and check which element is
removed. And here you see B, A, C E. So the
first a is missing? So the answer is the first
element is removed, not all A's are removed.
Okay, so what else can we do? Let's check.
We can also ask for the size. Let's make this
a bit simpler now. To have it as short as
possible. So now we have 1234 elements. I'll
copy that copying some code that you will
reuse is just safer not to introduce any typo,
or K. And as long as you're just copying the
code and not duplicating the code, it's also
fine. So this supposed to give us the number
of elements. Let me document this out. So
we just see the number of elements. Let's
also do it directly after instantiation of
the object. So I expect here to see a zero,
no elements included. Or I mean this would
be another alternative possibility that this
would throw an exception if the list is empty.
So let's check that execute the test was actually
not really a test. I'm just experimenting
but here. So you see it return zero and the
first line and then four. So this is the size
method. You can even ask, Are you empty? Which
should probably here say Yes, true. And here
probably false. And there is true and false.
Okay. So let's now switch Over to the list
interface. And let's also play a bit around
with that. You see, I have not a reference
variable of type list. And I can use all the
methods exactly like I used them before, because
the list interface
extends the collection interface. So it includes
all the methods that the collection interface
has. But on top of that, we now have more
methods
than just the methods of the collection interface.
For example, I can insert an element by giving
an index position. So I could for example,
say, at index position zero, at me, I don't
know T and S at index position two. And then
let's use the simple fast print odd method.
Let's remove this because it'll format the
list in a one liner. But let me just show
you what I mean. Okay, we still have the true
we can also remove this. Okay, but for now
it's fine. So we have T, because we added
that at index position zero, which means this
will be inserted where a was before. Before
I added that at index zero, this was the index
zero. So this, put it to where a was before
and then shifted everything else to the right.
And this is why now this is nice to see it
like this in one line. Because you see, this
is all shifted to the right, which when I
remove an element, the opposite happens. Like
if I remove the s, everything will be shifted
to the left. But let's see this later. Okay,
and we added the S at index two. So now this
is index 01 and two, which again shifted the
rest to the right. Okay, so let's also remove
something, let's do this here. Let's say I
remove index. And now let's see, I remove
index one, which is which should be the B.
Okay. And there, it seems I am wrong because
the a is still there. And the B is still there.
Let us see. Well, of course, because it's
a bit confusing. As I added the T at index
position zero, a is now index position one,
and this one was removed. So removing by index
is always not so easy. Really, I have to tell
you these index based methods, I hardly ever
use them. Normally, you're fine, actually
with most of the methods of the collection
interface, which again tells you like, often
it's a good idea to use collection here. Okay,
so this actually inserts an element. Okay.
By the way, let's increment this a bit, just
for demonstration purposes. I mean, this is
not so flexible. I mean, really, as I said
in my slides, you should really think carefully
the number of elements that you need. Just
here, it's different because we're playing
around, because I want to show you the difference
again in the example between the capacity
and the size, because the size of the list
is the number of elements. Let's do this here,
and not the capacity, because my area with
a capacity of 100 the area will be 100 elements
big even though they're empty, but the size
however, will be much smaller. And here you
see the size is four and not 100. So there
is a difference. Okay. Now we can also ask
for the index of a certain element. Let's
do this here. Index off and there is also
last index off and also is empty. Yeah, this
we should also use. So index off. Let's use
the aim. Yeah. Which is maybe we should remove
that. to not make it too confusing to keep
the A where it is. So now index off gets you
the first index of an element. So I would
expect that to be zero now, let's see this.
And they receive zero. And we can also say
last index of, which should be the second
a.
Check that. And you might ask, Well, what
do I need the index for? All you can use that
to more flexible, like combine the methods
now that you have the index, you could also
say like, like, remove this index or so on,
I don't know, might be helpful. Okay, so now
I can also show you the clear method. And
the is empty method. I think the is empty
method we already saw. But now let's use rim
clear. This method is void, so I cannot cannot
print it. But I can put it here, clear, will
empty the list. And then we'll ask
is it empty now. And we can also print out
the list. An empty list, which is also interesting,
because this would be another question. Can
I print out an empty list? Or will this again
throw an exception maybe? Let's test it. And
you see yes, it is empty. And you can print
it. It's just the square brackets and there's
nothing in there. So this was an empty list.
Okay. So I think that's already it. A really
short introduction, some practical coding,
I really recommend you to do the same fire
up your ID or your text editor and play around
with the methods of earliest. I know there
are many, many more methods of course, it
just that in this video i don't have all the
time. So this is just meant to give you some
motivation to play around with it by yourself.
Okay, that's it for this episode. If you have
any questions, leave them as a comment below
this video. And please remember to give me
a thumbs up before you go. Thanks for watching,
and see you next time.